[Music]
n
mik check mik
check realm how we doing how we doing
out
here what's going on real talk to me how
my levels are sounding Sunday Sunday
Zach Riley what's going on the hoodie
Canuck what is up yes we going talk
about it official young dreads I see you
what's going on Jo M OG got to hit you
up right quick with a$ Super Chat just a
little support is all all held the IL
salute the Lord shout out to the chat
great to see Xbox World Order is fully
operational okay the take over the
breaks
over oh man sherka with the popcorn all
right all right lot spicy topics you
know what I'm saying popn Anthony
Capello I see you going to get up in
here shortly n n oh you being messy I'm
watching this on my PS portal oh way I
can't
wow John W what up no doubt Pon Fusion
the gaming new was going on you already
know we going to have Lord gamesy up in
here in a couple of minutes and uh yeah
what's going on Dr Strange Love who else
up in there Dr scoty doing the
beat Mexican zoyberg what's up what's
going on see y'all ler in early Mark
Smith what's up what's up yeah we going
to talk talk about it we going to talk
about it um let me see oh hustle I see
you baby I see you I see you get you up
in there later Isaac Hayes salute e
ranks Thomas bot Commander rmus is that
rmus Prime
reference B slay what up Celly what up
yeah I got to get back to you man I
think you left me a message I got to get
back to you crazy week you already know
so yeah we going games up in here he'll
be here literally about a minute and we
going to talk we going to do some
history we got topics we got crry your
lord we got a defeat solve y'all he been
running away with this this competition
we do with oursel every year but this
the year he going down I got to take him
out anyway see y'all in a minute we
going to get gamley in the realm and we
going to have some fun man it's have
some fun talk to Y
soon here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all to messed up and turn me
to an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's sing up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the range you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm antisocial
love my city but I'm still by coal I got
let's switch that up
what did you do Don't Stop N that was
dope keep that keep that keep that going
keep that going n Go ahead look I guess
you can say that I'm very spoiled to be
your dog they very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the bo
you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making vultron with a
gang of cougar and I'm going places
better tell a uber cuz it's pretty hard
to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank me being
accountable I know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable I kill a beat and
they want to compare me to Freddy and
Jason I rather be Hannibal they be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all too Dramatical I know it's random
but I addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is that Yoga Fire Flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
it department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the range you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hard is started regardless back
we was messaging people on a check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm antisocial
my city but I'm still by Coastal I got
let's
switch you st that waspe keep keep keep
go ahead look I guess you could say that
I'm very spoil feel to be your dog they
very loyal but I ain't going to hold you
I ain't heard the boy you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougar and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not M go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am U what's important is
that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all the of me
being a accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a be and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and makeing it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sing up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to started
regardless back when you was messaging
people on a got check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let's Swit
that don't stop n that was dope keep
that keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you can
say that I'm very spoil feeling to be
your dog thing very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the bo
you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making vron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell a u because it's pretty hard
to sleep on Fredy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heades be swearing they real
but come to find out after that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a canable and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting and range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to started regardless back when you was
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by Coastal I
got's you don't stop that was dope keep
that keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoil feel them to be
your dog they very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougar and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all Miss up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sing up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest of start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let's Swit
that what you stop that was dope keep
keep that keep that going keep that
going no go ahead look I guess you can
say that I'm very spoil them to be your
dog they very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you ain't
got to say it I'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making vult Tron with a gang of cougars
and I'm going places better tell her
Uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the range you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
was messaging people on a check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm antisocial
love my city but I'm still coal I got
let's switch that what you do don't stop
that was dope keep that keep that keep
that going keep that going n Go ahead
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoil feeling to be your dog thing very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you ain't got to say
it I'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making Vault
Tron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flamable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they they can s up in the apartment they
call a department and I get the blame
still I be running collecting the r you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest start regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
antio love my city but I'm still by I
got's what you do stop that waspe keep
keep going keep that going no go ahead
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoil them to be your dog thing very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougars and
I'm going places better tell a uber cuz
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heades be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all for drama I know it's
random but I addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's aring up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
and range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still coal I got's
Swit don't stop that was dope keep that
keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you could
say said that I'm very spoil feel them
to be your dog they very loyal but I
ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being aable and they say I'm better than
money because you can Bank on me being
accountable I know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable I kill a beat and
they want to compare me to Freddy and
Jason I rather be anbal they be like why
use a video game just be original y'all
too Dramatical I know it's random but I
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that this is
De Yoga Fire Flame they think it's Saron
up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the r you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest of start regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
antisocial love my city but I'm still by
I got let's switch that what did you do
don't stop that was dope keep that going
keep that going no go ahead look I guess
you could say that I'm very spoil feel
them to be your dog they very loyal but
I ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy krger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we about to get started I am well
it's not important who I am um what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speak and uh I guess I'm here to keep
you entertained until it's time to get
this show started so
um look y' to messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all Dramatical I know it's
random but I addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Aron up in the apartment they
call a department and I get the blame
still I'll be running collecting the
range you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still coal I got let's Swit that
up but what is you doing Don't Stop N
that was dope keep keep that keep that
going keep that going n Go ahead look I
guess you can say that I'm very spoiled
feeling to be your dog thing very loyal
but I ain't going to hold you I ain't
heard the bo you you ain't got to say it
I'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making Vault
Tron with a gang of cougar and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Fry KRW
that's let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being a accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be hanal they
be like why use a video gang just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to started regardless back we was
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial
[Music]
oh call Proclaim loud and clear a
proclamation of invitation turn not on
me I C the of
theal the River St L with a water St
through and more
I'mma just chill and watch them and
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young whoop
but then they would mistake me for atct
if I can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cuz if you don't give her that
option you going to be single player
like Sovereign you going to get tossed
in the bushes by King David Royal and
not a pretender detrimental to a
Elemental what's a avatar to a knee
Bender I got to be NE I know it's my
destiny work kindo who cares if you fly
if you still a mosquito you swear you
ain't something but really be steo you
like to collect stuff and that's cool
but I got bad news even if you really
was that D King never still be the king
of the statu since a juvenile I've been
cursed with a curse to be Musical and if
you hated will me in The Crucible other
than that it's cool and it's beautiful
we let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cuz you can listen to this
in your cubicle on the Lord's
day if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's
day oh yeah
[Music]
y hot mic switching give me a second fix
this uh little borders we got a king up
in there I don't know why his camera off
all a sudden what's going on with that
but games Le let me get a mic check real
quick I was doing final touchup final
touchups what you backstage what are we
doing I had to get I had to get my
right oh man there we go I'm ready for
my closeup now
[Laughter]
Mr do your homework on that do your
homework on
that different when you know stuff let
me just check yeah good check 2 no
doubt and uh adct real quick I just want
to make sure you coming through good
again M check 3 2 one yeah s you got to
be different
huh
Resident Evil
4 oh okay I see what we doing I see
what's going on in here trying to one of
them things happen already one of them
is is is is speculation oh one of them
is speculation oh okay we going to get
to
you shout to the cops going by they
excited here ye here ye and we are live
welcome to the iord podcast on the run
and also live on Lord and gaming.net
episode number 331 and it's another the
Glorious Sunday we're back at the round
table on the Lord's date very excited
about our special guest and we've got
Xbox tax at the game awards Crown your
lord returns sof
mustache why it's got to be
colon erased his name
yes the Persona series I I can't wait to
talk about that one Mario
RPG I I have less in in stock than you
know someone maybe like Sol you know
yeah yeah I'm just happy it's coming to
you know the game coming to the platform
I play isn't isn't an L to me so I'm
happy no doubt bario RPG and October NPD
to discuss so we going to get right into
it I want to introduce a lord who is not
only the personification of perseverance
within our Gaming Community but is a
true gamer at his core and a worthy
ambassador of the fighting
Spirit introducing the paralympic taon
do silver World medalist three-time
National Champion Asia open champion and
the bronze medalist for the
international wheelchair and amput
sports
Federation the Lord of smoke
himself smoothest back kick in the game
and self-proclaimed disabled gaming
Beast live from Montreal and making his
debut into the realm of the Lords my man
Lord gamesley AKA Anthony Capello how we
doing
sir wow fantastic thank you so much and
you're welcome for being here
um oh yes oh
yes oh honestly I love it I love you
guys and I'm glad to be here appreciate
you appreciate you but Lord in your
realm finally got a chance to make this
happen
got to show you the proper respect in
the round table what have you been
playing so I know you talk to me offline
but to the to the realm what have you
been playing yeah right now I'm on a
Nostalgia kick right now I I have the
analog pocket right here which is like
notoriously hard to get and it's green
so we can't see
it it's all the the
background shout out to you for picking
the
RO that glow-in-the dark col
but yeah I got it and uh I'm playing
Final Fantasy uh 1 the actual RPG you
know oh is that a shot wait hold on you
hear
that do we consider that a shot I think
that was Cent it's only an acceptable
shot if you're taking shots at Final
Fantasy 16 I
absolutely absolutely am that's the
whole point and yes I it's it's ad
approved okay fair enough fair enough
but yeah I'm on a I'm on a Nostalgia
kick I I I grew up with the Game Boy
Color and The Game Boy fand I was a
hardcore like handheld gamer because
that was the easiest uh machine for me
to play obviously with my uh my hands
and all that stuff so uh all that boring
stuff you that's dope I I didn't realize
that was part of it pretty much I'm on
that stuff I'm also on the gb hold on
look at this I'm on the uh 3DS kit as
well oh it's
Charizard yeah I got their replaceable
uh plates on that one and uh unlike the
PS5 which is going to be useless in a
few oh he on this type
of this is one this one of King's
disciples that that infiltrated the
realm listen he's he's a disciple of
King he's definitely a disciple of King
it's it's not it's not a coincidence
they're both wearing red
today well you know listen we did talk
in the
background this this how you're not
supposed to mention it you're not
supposed to mention that I didn't tell
you the soldiers What the uniform for
today
was oh this is a K&N affiliate
from speaking the truth this is this is
the street team this is the stre listen
you know the curtains must the Dr oh my
Lord yo bu he say he's a caned
journalist
he's my boots on the ground dude keep it
up he private security too facts no
doubt all
seriousness uh it's true is it not like
they they came out with these plates for
the PS5 to make it all pretty and then
they swapped the whole design and now
those are useless right like I mean am I
wrong no no you're right cuz obviously
for a new form factor that it won't fit
yes I got you I got you exactly they got
the slit in the middle which is
completely disgusting
looking I I don't I don't understand how
like PlayStation thought that was
it it's a weird decision let's make
something because you that's how you
know that this new design it was a pivot
it it wasn't initially thought of
because to me if it was initially
thought of they would have waited to the
the Skins till the new redesign comes
out me no ahead no they just want ni and
dime you exactly that's the oh my Lord
this going to be a funny show I already
se you know what it is because if y'all
watch my last video when you trying to
pop it open they show they said they
said it it pop open so easy that's why
he laughing cuz he know you gotta yo yo
zo what's up I'm telling you how much
strength I had to use the pop off the St
and I said no I'mma break it I'mma break
it and I said BR and the PlayStation
looked at me like oh
God it's like it's like that dude that's
been doing Chiropractic moves on animals
on and the animal looks on them M they
does like yo yo what you
do yo it is Yo and I know the new ones
are easier I I know it has to be I know
somebody at Sony they was like okay so
do the demonstration for the kids he
like anyway so I know this one is
easiest so this that was the pivot that
was messy mess so that's been that's
been it sir gay wise uh this this week
uh Lord games I I was just letting him
Ramble On I love it I love
[Laughter]
laugh so yeah I'm on I'm on the Pokemons
I know that's a a weird thing for our
your audience but the Pokemon on all
that all of that uh but that's that's
that's what I've been playing I I
tried um to get into 16 and that's why I
went backwards got I tried to get into
Final Fantasy 16
um I I'm going to get into it more like
closely but the the PS5 controller
actually all Sony controllers and that's
not a shot at them this is for Real uh
don't play nicely with my my grip gotcha
um so the sticks I'm I have one right
here the Sticks being in the middle
there is really hard for me to kind of
you know hold triggers so the offset so
would you say the offset for the Xbox
controller makes it easier for you 100%
And that that's part of my like gaming
story into
Xbox that we so are you are you
interested are you interested in that um
PlayStation uh handic capable controller
that they got coming out it looks really
good yeah I was I was going to talk
about all of that as well I all right
yeah it's awesome hey I'm I'm talking
about games here that's
right Final Fantasy 16
Final Fantasy 16 I tried to get into it
but I couldn't I wasn't efficient enough
in it so I was like H I'm going to put
this down and also it being completely
an action adventure game let's be real
okay let's not lose the let's not lose
the narrative there um because let me
put it this way I'm not coming after
Final Fantasy it's actually a jrpg as
well I know you are uh it's it's not a
it's more of a jrpg thing for me because
when when I was growing up uh I was uh
heavily a PC Gamer and also uh my gaming
Journey kind of started with uh cards
and stuff you know card games board
games you know uh with my brothers um so
I grew up with d and d gotta gotta and
to me an RPG is kind of a blank slate
that you create from zero right and you
go and take a journey into La La Land if
you want and you could beat up barkeeper
you're like hey give me some beer and he
doesn't give you beer and you beat him
up you know make your own stories you
know right and that's that's what I
think an RPG should be and was kind of
like every single Bethesda game you know
branching story narratives you have an
unnamed character you know you create
your story you know Mass Effect you can
argue yeah it's Shepherd to most people
but uh it's the same
thing um so that those are RPGs to me
not even Final Fantasy like the early
ones 12 six or whatever I I don't you
know there's a branching there's like a
a a specific narrative that you're
taking through with those games right
almost like you're on Rails with it yeah
I got what you said yeah you're on Rails
and there's not really a branching
anything right so I I I guess that's
just a jrpg thing for me I I hate I hate
it I I think it's a marketing thing
really to be honest when Japanese RPGs
tried to make it into the West they
probably had that name in front of it
you know oh yes this genre
right which was controversal at the time
yeah I remember that yeah exactly and
they they they Market it that way so we
eat it up but uh RPG I don't know not
fair not fair enough you know turn-based
action adventure more likely yeah
probably both so turn-based action I say
that yeah not fair enough save the ball
you give it up all the bars we didn't
even start the history we got to save
I'm sorry I'm sorry no no I got
we we get into it know say so let's get
get intr out he ready he ready I can
tell he's ready he's ready K is in the
building he's
ready no doubt but let's get the the
rest of the Lords in here so we can get
into the show and talk about Lord gabes
even further my co-host with the Coos a
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord addict of the addict show back
to back how we doing sir doing pretty
good yeah I'm I'm I'm exhausted I I
spent I
thought the editing for my ranking all
Xbox One games would only take like an
hour to
four uh so you know and like 30 minutes
of that was finding the videos to do it
because you'd be surprised when you go
back to early Xbox One quality of those
videos aren't that great like so uh you
it took a little bit man you know U
people that didn't catch my live stream
I ranked every Xbox One game exclusive
game I got to get to that people got
upset where I put Quantum break and U
you know it is what it is at this point
you know you you should be more mad at
Remy for making the game than mad at me
for ranking the game W very very spicy
sir yeah so it is what it is I will be
live stream uh premiering that video
after this podcast so you know all of
you can come together and uh talk talk
about my hot takes cuz there's a few of
them in there there's a few of them in
there especially what what I uh what I
gave Reco people
wasn't okay okay F enough F yeah but
been playing a lot of persona tactica
yes um you know while I was waiting for
it to render I was playing the Mario
game oh Mario RPG we talk a little back
about it later yeah
so got got a lot of stuff tactica is an
interesting game we'll get to that here
in a little bit but it's it's been a
It's been a crazy week man you know
shout out to King he's he's approaching
his 5,000 on his Subs oh that's what's
up Salute to the to the front line we G
get we we we working hard out here we
push you to
l no doubt that's been it D yeah it's
been a lot of games I've been playing
this week I feel you getting it in I
seen you and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the sof stradamus
the of clarity and Lord patron of the
iron bank PC Master rac's own Lord
Sovereign show us the bill show us the
bill yeah show us the build the build is
looking is very beefy looking very
beefy I'm going to take this opportunity
I need to petition for an upgrade in
title I I oh what's the title though
what call S damus fits me anymore oh so
what's the new t let me let me update
what we doing H something light you know
something you know just Airy just kind
of flows off the tongue you know what I
mean such as Messiah something like that
I calling you the Messiah nobody here
refer to you as Messiah to be
fair I I think that works Messiah you
can't to to to be fair solve you can't
demand a name change after losing the
Persona 6 thing okay I haven't lost
anything you you are still in your yo I
the funny thing is when they come out
and say yeah we can we believe we can
sell million on PlayStation
5 you we will disc so the S doas is
retired and we're doing the Messiah I'm
I'm I'm going need that upgrade thank
the Messiah of Xbox no no not of Xbox
that's you you can have that K imagine
back in the day asking someone I don't
like my nickname change
it say I I don't want to be called
Peanut no
more I want called alond call me alond
no
right you will forever be the sa no no
no not strong enough anymore the Messiah
the Messiah of what it's the Messiah of
everything of all of all this this is
the listen this is the second time he's
pulled this right remember wait what did
I do this before so remember before we
used to call him the most technical
right yes yes so yeah the most technical
and then one one Saturday
that's not even that's not even true
anymore one Saturday he shows up and he
puts his name in and his
Sovereign like what the hell and Jamie
pulled up and was like yeah call me
K oh yeah yeah that's what everybody we
had we doing our wuang names remember we
had like everybody had that you're the
this what what did Ken say he wanted his
l
AEL is it was it was is guys are
ridiculous yeah we all came up with Cod
days for ourselves Ken Ken had Ken had
some spicy ones too they were hilarious
yeah K was hilarious K were
hilarious yeah that was during the fight
game eror
beel beas Mor remember
that more anyway what game you playing
sir uh yeah this week uh a couple of
things actually so last night I I put in
like three four hours into Spider-Man oh
um you turn that into a 40 hour game
yeah let's go I know I'm I'm doing story
stuff right I'm just trying to kind of
get to the story and I'll come back
stuff yeah so what I'm seeing is a
couple of things right okay first off
and this isn't a spoiler because they
put this in one of the trailers uh a big
chase scene that happens right a big
chase scene happens on the Water right
yeah so I'm like I'm I'm pretty good at
traversal in this game I'm I'm very good
at traversal in this game I get into
this Chase SC I'm like okay cool yeah we
GNA go it took me 30 minutes to get
through this scene
because there's there's imaginary walls
on either side of you as you're pursuing
these like boats and Jet Skis or
whatever and when I would be using my
wings to fly or be using you know my
webs to propel myself forward yes it
would say n you're done and it would
drop me into the water what multiple
times saying it
sucks I'm saying that part was not fun
um it took me like 30 minutes to do I'm
like what the hell anytime I got close
there's imaginary
walls yeah that was really just stopping
me like look if you're in a CH you have
to walk 10 minutes to find
them this is is Starfield go at this you
gota got stay current guys stay
current and then the thing is sometimes
there will be times when you when you
finally catch up to one of the uh to one
of the the things that you're chasing
and then you have like a little mini cut
scene there where you you attack them
whatever and then you're able to use uh
what they're what they're writing on as
to propel you forward the problem is
that some you know like five times it
propels me right into a bridge or
propels me right into something into an
obstacle and it's like it didn't even
give me the opportunity to be able to
look at where I'm going to go or
whatever it was just frustrating it felt
like it was not polished and to the
point like after a couple of times you
failing it it comes out and tells you
hey in the um in the options menu
there's something to make this easier
you know you made something that that
just not working well I'm like a man oh
man you wasn't following the path
oh it bothered me I was like what's good
here man so what's your rank of the
game I'm enjoying everything about the
game except like I said the bugs I
didn't have any bugs yesterday apart
from that if you want to call that a bug
yeah that's a banger bug I was just like
what are y'all doing like I can tell
what people were saying sometimes you
haven't played it yet you hear things
you think oh that's cap like you know
this is this is insomniac but there is a
little a little bit less of a layer of
polish on certain things here where you
like this could have cooked a little bit
more because it's just frustrating and
it's not frustrating in the way that
like MJ stealth missions were in the
first one that were just annoying right
they kind of it fixed that a little bit
because they gave her a little bit of
power so you can go through them faster
but this doesn't feel it feels like
there was certain things they could have
done just to make that flow smoother
instead of hey if you can't beat it the
way it is here's some easy here the easy
mod bring it down a little bit yeah yeah
so that was it um I'm at a point now
where things are getting interesting
although I do think story-wise it jumped
really fast it went from you know it
went from Peters got the suit right
into oh my God it's got to come off him
like he he he got so bad in so short
amount of time I was like it feel like
there was any buildup to it so I was my
final assessment I guess will be
forthcoming whenever I curious very
curious It's little
things so I don't I don't know we'll see
um another the last thing I did was um
so I over the week I had been listening
to Masters of Doom the audio book and I
listening also to John Romero's book
Doom guy right so his his uh his
autobiography and I just I felt Down The
Nostalgia sort of Wormhole I said let me
get me throw that old school doom and
old school Wolfenstein to really because
it just brought that back because those
guys on the PC side they revolutionized
the game like they revolutionized they
literally karmac and Romero and their
Partners did something that no one had
ever done and to see to go back to
original Doom to go back to Wolfenstein
even 3D um and then see that progression
into quake and Quake to and to see how
you know these guys you know the fame
sort of tore them apart a little bit
Romero the carac is very was very much
the workaholic and he just he was about
you know creating the engines and and
programming and Romero was that in the
beginning but ultimately he wanted to be
the rock star yeah and that sort of
drove them apart and then you know them
sort
of putting the hubus aside growing up
and then you know figuring coming back
to each other in some ways or whatever
very cool man just to see those games
those games still hold up you know
knowing a young a young person know
games they still fun enough to play they
simplistic right but they still move
well play well and then to see the jump
to like Doom you know 2016 and then do
maternal what they've done with that and
the things that have jumped off of quake
as well like yeah it was it was it was
fun to do that but it took me away from
everything else so I did that that was
fun and a little bit of Mario wonder
which is still great you know
one of these super chats is wow crazy oh
no
no of course we had the incredible H
this aka the ex gamer yeah you saw that
one why do I come here for this
stuff the prophet of Xbox swamy King of
the statues it demands nothing less than
that premium experience and is the
leader of the advanced the line mov
back I I cuz you switched it up last
week oh I switch the front line oh it's
Xbox front line movement okay okay cuz
we got a K&N affiliate here and you know
we we can't have him cuz he he's ready
you know my bad the Xbox front line got
my legs my legs are ready belov it Lord
King how we doing sir oh man um kind of
crazy this has been the wildest week
ever like the most bananas week ever so
regardless you know doing the videos
every day um got into a car accident on
the third so I'm going back and forth to
doctors and stuff like that right and
I'm I'm doing this without a care in the
world so you know my aunt passed away
and everybody's Gathering and this is my
my grandmother's sister so you know we
talking about the the the matriarchs of
the family and we're finally sending
them to the resting place so um the the
the wake is on Friday at 9:00 a.m. in
the morning right so you know how my
schedule is but I gotta make sure I'm
problem right I go out on Thursday night
CU his wife was like oh you know get
pizza so all right so let me take my son
home take my son home go get the pizza
coming back to the house tell me why the
cops pull me over okay right so I'm like
you know whatever I roll the windows
down you know I do the black man thing
roll the windows down uh turn the lights
on all in the car take the keys put them
on the dash and sit with your hands here
after you give them license registration
while they coming to the call I already
got license registration Insurance in my
hand window those down lights of
everything here you go and I'm
FaceTiming wifey because on my my my my
D I'm FaceTiming wifey talking to Wifey
this that and the third so they go I'm
like I'm thinking he's just G to come
back and watchall he was like oh cuz you
had like a piece of something on your
license plate or whatever and we just y
whatever BS you talking about I don't
care right mhm they come back to the car
they say yeah could you please step out
the car oh
I'm
like so you know how you go like oh
going different now you go you go from
confidence to what
the yo yo would you would you turn
around put your hands behind the back
what yo tell me why I had a suspend the
license did I know cuz I thought I I
paid my ticket I thought I paid my
ticket right no yo so so he goes don't
worry about it I sit in the jail cell
wait Y what this hours but I'm telling
wife I had just got the pizza so I'm
telling I'm like he calls wifey the
pizzas in the car that's exactly what
I'm saying I'm let your C get the pizza
so cuz I'm down the block literally from
the house right so uh the Bronx is here
I hate going to the Bronx hate you Bronx
you're the worst and um Westchester is
right here so I'm in Westchester had I
been on this side of the street they
could have bothered me cuz they they
they New York cops they cannot come
across this side
so okay I go wifey comes picks up the
car so she's distressed she's distressed
I'm in the jail I don't see her and he
goes don't worry about it you get a desk
appearance ticket so but this this goes
to say I'm driving around oblivious not
knowing this my joint been suspended for
like 3 months are you serious so for the
take Joint so I don't okay I had to um
you know how you got to do inspection on
your car yeah DMV DMV hits me up you got
inspection this I know I got inspection
DMV hits you up for for the minor stuff
whatever right why you Ain hit me up
telling me my license suspended so I
could just P the like why you got me
driving riding dirty out here right you
you millionaire now n they're like the
IRS yo they wait get they wait so like
yeah there be time if you pay the ticket
or the ticket was late it'll just wait
they let stuff ACR and then once it gets
to that limit then yeah then they then
then then yeah but okay so the cop the
cop was like yeah I totally understand I
got to go through the whole criminal
thing and then they released me right so
they reled Me 2 hours later I got to
take a uber go home so remember now the
next day is 9:00 in the morning I got to
go to the weight oh my god um I grabbed
my clothes I got home didn't get no
sleep went straight there got straight
there from work
and my my auntie and my uncle CU we from
the island from St cro we had so many
people from St Croy there and to be in a
room with a whole bunch of people with
your face yeah your your body but you
don't know them but you they feel famili
you know so it was so many people there
and it was just it just she she was um
such the pillar of our family she was
the one to get the cookouts together you
know um the house was the house that
that was the only house that we had in
and our family uh her and um my uncle
that passed uh they were the ones that
only had a house you know um and that
was my inspiration to get in a house I
didn't even know all this stuff so I'm
sitting there and all this stuff is
flooding back and I seen my cousin poo
and we reminiscing when we was playing
with uh the the Planet of the Apes toys
was little like and we talk about video
games and stuff and I show him the
podcast stuff and and um it's just I
want everybody to just you know make
sure you stay a little bit more
connected with family you don't want to
meet up at these last you know things
but I just remember at my darkest moment
my auntie was there for me her and my
uncle
and it was the greatest feeling to be
able to convey that to everybody there
and to let them know you know that she
was completely loved it was the most
beautiful thing that you know but um all
right so then K and all this other stuff
this week so I didn't get a chance to
put up the the table yeah I see it still
sitting there right there it's got to
get done it's got to get done had a
whole bunch of stuff shout out to adct
with the with the help on everything um
okay so I was supposed to give a game
away
yesterday on um well Friday on uh Xbox
uh front line so our secret benefactor
and this is what he says he doesn't he
doesn't want his name out there he said
because he said King you know I'm an
industry
plant these are the DMS you get yeah he
said King I'm an industry plant I can't
be having my name out there so I'm not
going to say you know I'm not going to
say who he is all right so this is the
first game please uh and he don't let me
know what the games are okay right he
just gives me the codes of like share
with
them what's funny is we we did like that
whole thing and then King was like oh
man I'm like what he's like I forgot to
do that giveaway giveway the whole
reason continue y it's dope so all right
please let me know what he
gave please retweet it all right so the
first uh letters is v p j
KF next is p c m
CX next is 6 C
V7 K next is T C
jf6 last is
hxx y z okay that's the whole thing let
me know what you got I'm going to give
away another game because he told me to
give away a game from the realm so it
was a game from my show and it's a game
for the realm um shout out to the almost
5,000 uh followers of Xbox Frontline
news this is
crazy you guys is dope we are we are
monetized now so you can leave super
chats you can leave super thanks on the
videos that you like if you like the
video leave a super thanks that's great
patreon is coming I'm sitting down with
Sovereign we going to talk about that
and the merch store will be up and
running in a week graphic and I is
working on that me and Dallas have a
meeting today that intro that I got is
not finished yall going to get the full
intro and then we're going to be working
with adct on his intro for his show
eventually yes what I've been playing
this week you playing Call of Duty
campaign okay okay for all you frauds oh
boy here we go for all you frauds I see
I don't play war zone right so the fact
that I don't play War
Zone when they they said certain Maps is
just from war zone right I would never
know that but these are the most
intricately uh uh put together boards
the way that I'm able to attack a
mission is so open this is very
different for me when it comes to Call
of Duty I'm used to Call of Duty being
on the rails you go this way you got to
take care of it this way and you got to
do this not this one this one you able
to
um attack objectives in a manner that is
easy for you like you can go to it
through stealth you can go through a
board through just loud Ruckus I like
the Ruckus mode I get a rocket launcher
and do stuff that I'm not supposed to do
or call in a strike and do stuff that
I'm not supposed to do but I still get
the mission done and I I think we're at
the Pinnacle of uh firsters Shooters
when we got a nickp pick storyline and
how the story is being told because you
can't attack it on Graphics this is like
a big budget movie Graphics type stuff
like the cutcenes look like it's ripped
straight out of the predator and stuff
cuz a lot of times they're in the jungle
now this is where it's at and now I've
been playing fortnite and I just found
out my Mario RPG and this through atct
yesterday because I was watching his
show and he was like yeah I gotta play
the Mario RPG I got that I was like oh I
got it too oh my God so I jumped off
watching him and wifey on they show and
I was just like yo let me get over there
and play this Mario RPG so I was playing
Mario RPG as well that's what's up no
doubt and of course we have the gaming
ninja himself the Shinobi Lord Cognito
spreading out realness in the ran IP not
telling what you want to hear but what
you need to here shout out to find Duke
my man matd plays talking about game
awards and snubs and all that and then
obviously the last word he bontis T guy
Travis talking about season of The Wish
coming up and then for me I just been on
one game uh like a dragon giden the man
who erased his name I'm on the last
chapter um having fun having a lot of
fun with I almost almost quit the game
in the beginning cuz that combat was
rough I was like I see why we needed to
evolve from this I was like this is
Antiquated like but I'm not going to
front as you buy and upgrade your powers
in the agent mode cuz he's on this
little James Bond joint he gets little
this little lasso rope thing he gets all
these little gadgets he got these shoes
they like James Bond shoes he speeds
across and runs into people it's goofy
it's silly but the story is really and
I'm trying to get through this because
once you beat it then it unlocks the um
demo for infinite wealth but you got to
beat the main campaign so I'm trying to
get through it so I can get to my man
itchy but curious real talk so far super
cool I know why he's beloved I get it
I'm enjoying learning more of the
character history this is the yang
version one that you got no this not the
no English dev is ready yet so I would I
want to put it there because I want to
hear it I want to I cuz it's so funny
you say that because like a dragon I
played with I love ich Bond's voice so I
can't play the new one without it being
in English so me and young gonna get
cool we going to have to figure this out
when the dub is released for both cuz I
am not playing ich bong without the
English dub so anyway I just wanted
that's kind of weird though right isn't
it like I don't why wouldn't you have
both ready so you can drop it at the
same time it is weird that it's not
available I have to admit me and adct
talked about that it was kind of weird
it's not available it is what it is the
only time I saying that is something
gets localized after the game already
launched like like it's successful so
okay now let's get this game up there
but then again you know I don't keep up
with stuff like that so that might not
be how things go you know hold on coming
at me he said n k you got to get good
I'm bad nice in the combat I'm
dominating the combat it's still
Antiquated and
old that that can build up a biased
though mean right because if you're
listening to the Japanese voice and then
when you get the American
I think if they both at the same time
yours is not tuned to the Japanese voice
you had a choice right so if you just
first her her young yay and you had the
ability you it won't be so much of a
bias this is going to build a huge bias
against them because when they do drop
it agree and they do go to it they're
gonna be like no I played in the JB I
like that voice better I wish it was
available at launch so I could I'm sorry
get ad I'm sorry I I'm gonna be real
with you like car gave it way more of a
chance than I did oh you didn't like it
at all yeah I I play after I started
doing some magical rope stuff I was like
yeah we we we we we good we good on this
we all the way good on
this and people like they're like qu
addict they're locking the the demo for
the game you want to play behind the
whole story okay that game comes out in
two months I'll
wait kills me he don't like a magical
rope but you can summon
Dragons It's only only when is what what
he likes it doesn't matter what you
could do it doesn't matter the thing is
it it just felt clunky it it felt floaty
at the same time like I don't know why I
just I've never liked their like I like
the the way the samurai games I I I
really like those cuz those feel the the
controls feel tight it's just I don't
know something about that combat has
never clicked with me you know it says
the man who erases his name erase that
game oh damn like I'm sorry games you
was gonna say something you about to
jump in you about like it's all good
yeah I love when you guys are talking
that's sh up uh so so uh kind of like
when you play God of War Ragnarok right
you play a God and he can't you know
climb a rock you know that's
like and you're like what is this that
kind of game breaking and then you want
to step off of it or no it's more so it
look it it for its time I can tell like
that was the age of the era of the beat
him up and don't get me wrong it's
refined the new toies he has is cool he
has this little dra drone thing that you
could said and like irritate people
while you're fighting he's got um I said
this rope thing like you tie people up
throw them and toss them he's got oh the
cigarette thing is cool you goow like a
little cigarette bomb and stuff like
that so it's kind of playing into this
like James Bond he doesn't want anyone
to know who he is kind of thing but then
you could switch stances and go
traditional you know the dragon of
dojima power and cinematic flare and all
this other stuff so it's it's cool is
just that like it's clunky and then it's
like the lack of really being able to
Fus sometimes it's not clunky and then
you're just like okay this is good and
then you and then like five minutes oh
it's clunky again yeah it's there's no
lock on right there's no lock on I've
been trying to find people said yo RB I
press RB then he's like he has a Dodge
and lb is like a a block and stuff so I
I just my my work around is I just dodge
everything I'm just rolling around and
dodging everything so cuz what happens
is multiple enemies surround you from
different angles and it's hard to be
able to handle your business you know
what I'm saying without them trying to
at least get a you know a knock on you
that kind of energy but it don't get me
wrong there there is a lock on
apparently but for my understanding it's
just clunky it just for my feel it
doesn't flow good to me but the game is
fun as you get more powers and then you
can start handling them so I'll be
handling it's not like I'm getting
handled I just wish that part this game
needed to go to tournament I am so glad
this way great the turn Bas and Tra
traditional jrpg cuz that style he as a
character fire his control and his game
play no no no no that's not it but
anyway like I was saying is it true is
it true everybody walks up to him like
you're curio right like n every bro it's
like you know how like dudes walk up on
Superman they acting like they confused
like can't they acting like they
confused it's just his glasses he like
no you're the dragon of Doja but you're
curio no no I'm judio I am not I am not
they like bro it's you some some enemies
get getting no plastic surgery
just got glasses on and dudes is like
bro you still going to keep this lie up
we know it's you fam like isn't it so
Charming isn't it so fun fun it's fun
it's fun it's silly I wouldn't use the
word Charming awesome anyway real quick
last question were you able to play The
Master System yes oh bro I had they got
they got Alex kid fantasy Z I was
playing Enduro racer you have to get
yeah bro so much fun so much fun that
went at um at hang on so hard I mean s
was trying bro thank you Edward Walton
see RB is a lock on but it's more like a
focus Target exactly but um yeah like
the the the thing that makes the game
Charming is the side quest the mini
games are so much fun hey yo K I got
hear that addict
Charming I'll wait for the actual
Charming game the side quest there's two
there I got to shout out two side the
side quest are phenomenal vintage G fun
one side quest King gangsters is running
around thugging out well homeless people
for their welfare
checks and then they locking the
homeless people up in these rooms like
yeah we got your check and you going to
stay in these buildings we tell you to
do we go that was one Mission I said
this game is hilarious there was another
so what side of you on you on the side
of the dudes locking up no I had to stop
them dudes like come on stop ding the
homeless like this is
then it was another Joy where you go a
dude hire you and he's at the you better
to meet him at the Burger Spot so he's
like yo I'm really bad you know with the
women but you know what I'm going to
cancel this I was going to ask you for
advice K but now I'm going to cancel cuz
I have and guess what they write chat
DBP instead of chatting DD and he's
asking the the app how to go or ar
relationship advice so he's like well if
you really want to impress your mate you
want to do something Daren so he was
like what should I do Chad DDT how about
you know jumping from Heights is is a
cool thr seeking way so then the kid
runs out it's like I'm going to do this
and you're like no stop listening to
this Ai and you got to use your human
interaction cuz you got to save this
dude from doing all this foolish stuff
to impress this girl cuz he keep using
chat DDT that's that side quest is for
the future you got to save people from
AI bro they having fun rgg is having a
ball with these quests but anyway that
pretty quick question quick quick
question did you play the first Yakuza I
have not I started very late I started
with like a dragon as my first and then
I'm a ichiman fan and I'm a turnbas fan
so they told me that right yeah but
rightfully
so instead of playing this game go back
to play the the first one stands up it
stands up they give me all they me
all does kaami stand up or the first
one e kwami
uh but play play that game it's it's
it's amazing and also it yeah it's good
I've learned everything I need to learn
from him his flashbacks in the in the
updated version of the Antiquated style
I am not going back to that but anyway
salute to y'all the stories are so good
have you ever have you ever watched John
Wick the stor have you ever watched John
Wick of course he he's a yeah I ain't no
of course he's actually right W no of
course I watch
the the thing is it's amazing the story
except for the when we all went to watch
John Wick at oh you me latest one new on
yeah I was like y it's not for you then
it's dope it's dope it's all good anyway
so that was that so pretty much been I'm
the last chapter IA probably get that
finish this week so that I can start
infinite wealth but that is pretty much
it anyway um so we got super chats what
we got what we got we got some super
Chats on on a moment R back a little bit
we got Gerald Mack with the $5 Super
Chat just a little support is all oh
hell the ILP salute the Lord shout out
to the chat great to see Xbox World
Order is fully
operational always objective takes love
you he's a Cann affiliate yes he is yes
he is then we got Big Mad Mo member for
40 months Lord bronze shout out to the
Lords in the realm this popularity
contest show has exposed itself looking
forward to the world premieres though
keep on keep keeping on that is true
that's what we watching for the world
premieres there we got Doctor Strange
love5 I don't get why people say
Hogwarts got snubbed regardless of
controversy it was an allright game
heavily carried by its IP nowhere near
Game of the Year material I thought it
was good but I kind of agree I think the
at the end of the day probably didn't
deserve to be there but it's a great
game I like it not not deserving to be
in Game of the Year is different than
not ER get nominated at all for anything
yeah that's my is yeah okay I get that
no that was agenda I don't care oh that
was that for sure talk about yeah we'll
definitely talk about it then we got BT
Maverick 707 $5 Super Chat there will
always be an Xbox tax as long as Metro
contributes to Game of the Year Noms and
Metacritic whom openly punished high
five rush for being an Xbox game yeah
met Metro is a little suspect on that
one half the and guys remember the medic
critic is not Metacritic doesn't
determine the scores it just Aggregates
them everybody say Metacritic did this
it's the aggregate of the
scor they didn't do anything we got
blade X $2 Super Chat Taekwondo Bros in
the building shout out to you no doubt
then we got the the man who got them
horns member for 36 months Lord bronze
happy belated birthday to beefy [__] #
pause #k # Xbox
tax
then we got Robert kellet $5 Super Chat
blessed dayl Lords after getting ghosted
I'm going to enjoy your usual dose of
chaos and wisdom you guys played Persona
yet lowkey amazing so far yeah I got I'm
waiting I'm just wonder cuz if I start
persona it's going to be over for like a
dragon SO waiting did he say after did
he say after getting
ghosted yeah I don't know so so you guys
you guys you guys stood up on a date you
was like I'm just going to listen to I
Lord oh that's he rocking with the
homies he rocking with the homies you
know what yo forget her man stay we
always here for you bro we always here
for you exactly you here with the you
was going to take it to Cheesecake
Factory so what she missed out why is it
low key though Persona lowkey is it
really lowkey good I'm hearing I'm
hearing it's good not like you know blow
your we're talking about Q or we're
talking talking about Taca the new one
that came out I think that's understand
now oh they only say that cuz is in Game
Pass
that's D that's the real Xbox taxes Game
Pass then we got let me see Dr Strange
Love $ five Super Chat I feel bad for
King the rest of the Lords get lovers in
the chat but he don't got anyone to put
him on his stomach and get him give him
that Thanksgiving stuff hey yo he's got
me he's got
me
come come come listen listen let me let
y'all know something I don't need nobody
open your your heart we we good y'all y'
listen I let I let y worry about the
beef the juicy and added in his
pepperonis y can have fun with all that
g to come rubbing down the stairs right
now what going on over here hey
yo we good they they can have it they
can have it all back to
you back
get back to the show SP go 17 2 Super
Chat hey yo dror strange of Love on
demon time what the
he he definitely on demon
time then we got wictor fak with the 10
year old 10 year old Super Chat happy
late bday Cog May the best uh definitely
come your way I think he made death come
your way shout out you said made the
death come my way how you Happ born hope
the death comes your way you you made
another one for
now he wrote b f so I think he just
wanted to write def I thought you said
death oh you wanted to write beef
without the extra
e I'm like Dam this man been plotting so
he instead of writing deaf d f for
definitely he wrote bef so
got I'm like this man happy birthday at
defit the see Super Chat before hope you
had the greatest death
ever maybe next year this is Savage
sa proba maybe next year Jesus Christ
roll out let's go yeah we got face 23
pkny y $20 Super Chat Spider-Man 2 is
number one October MPD and number four
bestselling game of 2023 beating out
Mario Wonder Starfield and most
third-party multiplats on one platform
known knes today didn't someone say
Mario Wonder was going to sell more than
Spider-Man sounds like he oh just just
wait King's got a CRA I know I know
King's response coing yeah it's yeah
it's gonna we're gonna have some fun
with that but yeah shout out to you
running out with these numbers you know
your numbers don't look good in the
light so we could I don't believe y'all
oh but you know what was crazy so I'm
thinking because at the top of that when
we read it it's it because it's always
been specific saying hey Nintendo
doesn't report these right but then in
this one it said it didn't say that so
I'm like okay are they finally reporting
it and this is the full number so
apparently no like you have to you have
to really write that caveat down every
time you they had it there out there
like that was Final Nintendo doesn't
report digital don't worry about it let
him live right now you try to come for
him later okay okay okay I see we wait
for the topic face face he's coming for
you with the topic for stick around
face map you in trouble
Let Him Live then we got let me see chal
back was again $5 Super Chat is it true
PlayStation has been supporting Xbox for
a good uh Wyoming since Xbox owns Havoc
or is that a lie because uh asking
because I'm
curious I think the Wyoming was a uh was
an auto fail I don't know what that
means yeah I don't know we'll see U then
we got zip Davis $2 Super Chat send you
guys Good Vibes and zip with the drip
sending you guys Good Vibes and an extra
big
salute then we got country big 94
remember bronze the homie right there
happy Sunday Lords loving uh loving
playing the man who erased Ichibon wow
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa see I would I I could be evil
to you right now cuz I know a plot I'm
going to let you live right
now I'm let you live right now see he on
that time I'm
on you you beat that game sir you beat
that game we got things to talk
about we got Co I do get why people
don't like the combat but I like it
people hit that like button yes that
like no I get it y y'all from the old
school I get it yall like the you old
way of doing things but the old way of
doing new
way yeah he he the beat boxing combat
we got to do that turn base J rvg baby
ich B is the future that's what it is
continue There we got love country
big then we got wictor filac once again
with the five year old super chat random
question for addict what's your top
three anime of the year so far mine are
jjk op and mus mushoku
tensei um jitu kaisen Attack on Titan
and probably death uh
Demon Slayer I say that yep you saw the
new Demon Slayer
Crocs no I
don't theboy boots yo we got Yo they are
fire we got to get addict some uh Demon
Slayer Crocs bro so when we out at uh PX
East he rocking it yes heard it here
first that's right we get him un like un
like K I don't care we going to get some
Demon Slayer clock I I value my feet
hurting over over anything I feel that
yes Co said I feel that you know they
can chop my toes
off so nice they're so nice you can have
them you you be the representative
for continue I agree I'm not about that
no thank you there we got face 23 BK y
$20 chat I'm humming at you at you Lord
cogo series s x selling less than the
Xbox one gen Microsoft doesn't care
about consoles but this is concerning
why keep wasting money r& ding for
consoles when they are not selling just
go third
party why do they care no what FR is
remember remember ladies and gentlemen
revenue is not the same as
profit tell them tell just remember
ladies and gentlemen that's all all I
got to say when you hear people
screaming the roof about Revenue that is
not the same as profit so other people
need to be concerned about how much
profit they are actually making because
you can be making all this Revenue but
if you're operating cost the cost to
rent is a little bit High us us Puerto
Ricans call that suso yeah us Hood dudes
call it living living check to check
that's Check to Check energy yeah there
a difference ladies and gentlemen they
they they they dying for Michael just
just just just go third party just just
go third party no we going to kill y'all
first highly ADV check out highly ADV
checking out the latest um shout out to
Jess G latest article by Jess g s you
brought it to our attention about yeah
what's going on with Microsoft and and
the revenue and the and the profit that
type of Stu so we talk who is exciting
today face is exciting today we'll talk
about it yeah
yes then we got Spartan go 17 two power
Super Chat Metro is like the source
ain't ever getting five bics oh damn
yeah facts
baby I believe so I may be wrong about
that um let me see let me see Jonas the
dad $5 Super Chat all of us wave sticks
as swords wands as kids Avalanche n it
made it awesome how is that not at least
super Innovative same with New Game Plus
in
Starfield interesting we talk about it
then we got Mandingo MC thickens $2
Super Chat happy birthday cogito May
meaty things come your way
yo yo you started off good you started
off good you you you don't come the
wrong way though you got to go all the
way you gotta go you gotta go all the
way well we not going all the way with
that we are not going all the way salute
encourage your violence we got to watch
some what show did I stumble upon I
don't
know you know exactly what show you got
bro what you got
it look so I was like I ain't even let
you say
that good you could have canceled your
patreon long
ago you do damn well with
sir I will when I get to
cognit hold on very very real question
ILP is I love pork
or
no
here we go here we
go super pause time one
G then we have uh wictor Flack once
again two pound two Euro Super Chat
misspelled beef but that was funny oh oh
red
wsv salute salute there we got Doctor
Strange Love $5 Super Chat it's okay to
be in denial all you want King it's okay
to be in denial all you want King but
soon someone is going to make you be
saying O we all night long I was doing
that yesterday bro I'm good right UPS
I'm good we we good we good you ain't
got to boo me
up good
salute y we got Craig hooligan what the
question in the chat for Craig hooligan
gifting one IP membership thank you
brother salute there we got hargate chy
$5 super ch bless welcome to the realm
gamesley I've been trying to get Cog to
play Yakuza zero through six but but
he's too stubborn to try it sadly we we
could just team up man you're not
teaming up on
anything we are not teaming up a lot a
lot of lot today lot of suspect stuff
listen man I I'm fine with a the man
racist name I really I actually love I
love kir how he's rocking in that so I'm
good man I'm getting all the flashbacks
all the stories C he said I'm getting
his entire story I don't need all up the
DAT in the newest engine it's not good
enough you play the game they they want
you to love the game n adct they want to
tag T moving
on oh talking about oh
man this is going left continues
on we got JD gamer put the CR CH JD
gamer gifting five I thank you brother
zesty let's get to this show and that is
it we are caught up for now now um do we
uh we have a little pay the bill real
quick or yeah let's you want pay let's
pay B quick we want talk about n16 we
want to talk about other things what we
want to talk about Let's do let's do
Let's do let's do NXT they haven't got
the love let's do a little NZXT so right
now good friends as you see the realm is
powered by NZ XT go check power powered
by you see that purple on the side you
know what I'm saying so uh yeah Black
Friday right now so I'm going to put the
link in the chat there some great sales
if you're looking to upgrade your rig
get a new rig so me particularly I
wanted to talk about right now you can
get 500 off of the player 3 prime one of
those cool new new custom bills to your
liking go check that out again it's up
in there use that link right there what
else Lord I any any Black Friday sales
let's let's give the specs real quick
and that play that player three prime
spec wise is really out there it's a a
core I9
13900 KF and a GeForce RTX 4090 in the
oh it's a 490 out here that's great on
that 4090 right now I'mma tell you what
you need is that 50% off on the fan
upgrades and hybrids so if you're going
to use you know you know fix your fan up
because it's going to be serious
PA you can definitely do that or you can
do the upgrade with the hybrids you know
the water cooling stuff I think that's
great and right now you know it's free
ground shipping on all gaming PCs oh we
getting free ground shipping free y yall
know how these PCS are and you know it's
at least $60 to 80 on on ground shipping
to get to you so free saves you a lot I
like free free feel good to
me I like free exactly and I'm I'm going
to rep with the the machine that we have
in the house which is now $500 off that
is the player three AMD Edition that is
rocking the AMD ryzen 77800 x3d CPU and
for GPU is rocking the Radeon RX 7900
XTX a beast of a machine and we speak
from fir hand from firstand experience
it is a beast of a machine it usually
runs $3,000 it is
$5500 off right now oh 500 get that is
500 offer right now no doubt any sales
caught your eyes Black Friday
NZXT so uh unlike uh these other people
I'm not going to sit here and try to
sell you a game like that it's like look
I'm talking to the content creators like
you know you want to take stuff
seriously you got to upgrade your
equipment it happens with it happens
with everything you know that gets to a
point where you could either continue to
hit your head against the wall because
your rig just ain't cutting it out or
you can upgrade what I think people
should do you know if if you want to dip
your feet in just a little bit to get
you something to you know help you do
these live streams help you you know uh
stream these games because that ain't e
it's very It's very effective and uh you
know they they got $100 off right now
with the player ones man the the player
one primes you know right now you can
get a player one prime $100 off I feel
like with that what you could really do
is you C you could you can figure you
can figure out exactly what you want and
you know I personally feel like we have
a lot of Contra creers that follow us
and it's like you know I've always seen
people say I need to upgrade this I need
to upgrade that it's like get get one of
these Prime these level one primes that
you know they can easily they got 4060
TI and
i7 you it's a prominent machine 32
gigabyt of ram two terab storage space I
like that it's like could easily stream
the I mean
obviously what I would recommend doing
is you know getting this for rendering
times that there there's a lot of
different aspects of having a stronger
rig like my last computer well let's go
to the one before that because my last
computer had a pretty decent CPU it was
like it was like a ryzen five or
something like that took like 40 minutes
to to render some now I'm constantly
rendering videos on this CH on this PC
this this suck I have now which is the
uh the AMD uh Prime three you know got
good things right there takes me 10 15
minutes or rer like an hour video and if
if if you don't want to spend what these
cost and you saw said it's $500 off it's
like I say get that player one might not
render as fast but I guarantee you a lot
of the people in the chat that's you
know taking content creation seriously
it's going to render better than what
your rig currently does you know what I
do like too I like the the player two
build um the play two and player two
prime pre-build hybrids right now see a
lot of times you have to choose on where
your money is going to go because you
got to add a monitor and that raises the
cost but right now you get the player
two or the player two Prime pre-build
with the new SKS the H6 uh SKS you get a
free monitor free 27 inch monitor
monitor and that takes away the whole
how can I do the see I'm about to free
yeah I'm about to free free 99
exactly you can put all your money into
the PC to player two prime Bill and then
you get the free Monitor and remember
it's free ground shipping go to the free
Parts NZXT for the free right NZXT for
the free man they yo it's it's for the
win this is what Black Friday is really
about and keep in mind everything we
just said when it comes to the PCS it's
free shipping that's another $60 off of
your price that you don't got to pay for
no doubt no doubt you already heard it
here first round powered by NZXT check
that out got the link in the description
as well as pinned at the top and I
appreciate y let's get a couple more
Super chats that game pass ultimate
let's go oh facts facts you can do that
over there PC game pass you can do that
over there you see you see what Nvidia
and um Game Pass is done with that
Nvidia bundle it's crazy right now that
cloud stream y'all get
outside no doubt so let's get the rest
of super
CH we got uh country big 94 2B Super
Chat Cog don't sleep on like on uh like
a dragon Ean story is fire yeah I was
tempted I was tempted I just didn't have
time because now tactica is out which
adct is playing I want to play tactica
so yeah don't shake your head games I'm
playing tactica
D anyway no but I I playing the wrong
games I don't understand to be fair
though like they Ean came out without a
lot of fanfare they really didn't make a
big stink about when it came out was
very quiet it is interesting for those
who play I just want people to tell me
how connect it is to the kiru ichiman
arc from the vibe I got is like old
school joint but y'all correct me if I'm
wrong how connected it is to the Deep
you can tell low key K Tred to come out
and says he don't care about none of
these old people and Leon got ichon in
like oh facts ter base ichon and then we
get curio up to speed to where we at
they don't even have
that that's where I'm at facts even have
to have turn Bas in it man he's playing
like a dragon right now ich Bon's in
that story facts bro they did the
greatest markting ever kid they was like
we know you like the new one beat this
old one then you play the dev then you
can get you got to go through the dirt
to get to the
water reminds me of like them saying
look we're not you're going to buy Halo
3 but if you buy Halo 3 we give you the
devil for Halo 4 yo you know remember
what game was that that they did that
and we cck crack down crack down and
they let you play cck down for Halo 3
Halo 3 beta yeah cuz we didn't care
about Crackdown and we we went through
that to get to that but they did that
with something else too man they did it
with gear it was Metal Gear Solid to it
was Zone Zend Zend yo that okay that's
serious because I didn't give two craps
about Zona at all but I got to pay I got
to I got to pay this to get to that here
you go I didn't even turn Z all all we
went was straight to that demo it was
the boat it was the boat and that's
where you can put the bodies in the
lockers we like oh my God this is
amazing you got you can shoot all the
bottles yeah yeah oh man now you now
that's a that is a gous practice right
they know they game was hot garbage and
they said yo we going to put the most
anticipated game here but in order to
play the demo
you got to beat the wackness you got to
play the wackness pay for the wackness
I'm down for
that both of those games are good wasn't
that bad never know though I don't even
think I played it facts you didn't play
Crackdown one you play I play I play
Crackdown I'm talking about no let's get
to end this okay that is a game nobody
gave a This Is My Demo this is like they
got the new uh I don't know who the
battle rapper is new garbage Battle
Rapper there
[Laughter]
but they put they put the hot new
Butters a Nas joint on the track
youness
this they did a different they made they
made him play the game and beat it they
like you got to beat the game no sep
this is different you're right you're
right s they like it literally is locked
into it says the campaign better be
completed then they they they found out
that nobody plays on the Enders so they
said hold on we going to make you play
this to get to if if you think about it
too like they they Geniuses like Co said
they're like we know the majority of you
that liked this like a dragon one you
ain't playing this guess what we know
how to get you we know how to got they
got me great marketing salute to rgg for
the for the strong arm for the stick up
it was fantastic gladly take my money oh
shout out real quick shout out to
Country big and shout out to Harge
and they were saying that it's a
separate story with each in different
character Okay Okay cool so now you just
confirm I don't need
to thank you thank you thank you
completely separate all right anyway
more Super Chat let get out there uh
hary chny $10 super chat with ABK it is
possible the Xbox will beat PlayStation
in revenue and of course profit that
leaves 10 cent as possibly higher in
Revenue Xbox is fine worry about
PlayStation oh she trying to say that
they on track to oh wow that's crazy I
thought we might possibly talk about
later interesting cuz I heard otherwise
in earlier super chat but we going to
move
on and your garbage controller Jesus God
good Lord what have we done what have we
[Music]
done
say roman1 super CH Spider-Man 2 beating
Mario wonder is a lie NPD say did not
count digital sales lies that is that if
they did not count Nintendo digital
sales I guarantee you those numbers are
different that is for sure um JD gamer
$20 Super Chat serious question what
happens if Microsoft xboxxbox decides to
be the villain that the rest of the
industry claims they are now I.E they
buy Square Sega embracer Ubisoft Konami
and more and then make everything
exclusive I want tears this guy here the
thing is that's the world I live in I
mean sometimes sometimes you do you know
you will pick people off to the point
that they say f it I'mma Be the villain
I'mma do that to be honest with you I
think after the scrutiny that happened
with them buying ABK I think they're
already there they going chill or
they're gonna continue no I think I
think they're on there I think they're
on that you want to paint Us in this
picture let's amp this up let's show you
that we the demons that you thought we
wer that's what I'm talking about there
we go let's get it Messi Messi continue
finish
but y won though that's the thing
they're just bad winners man yeah it's
like I won but I'm would Scorch the
Earth anyway I ain't like how you looked
at me when I came down the
hallway that's like a quote to have like
having like people you socialize with
every day and you finally get a break
and they do everything in their power to
stop you from getting it and they're
like you know what on once they went it
they're like I'm G win this and and not
only am I win this I'mma show you why I
won
this
Mur hold on a second we got no that was
it that was it we're caught up so are we
going to do the other bills now or we
yeah let's just get it let's get it cuz
then let's get it mute ourselves or we
no no no I I I'll be I'll be I'll be
referring to you guys momentarily yeah
okay so don't mute your
mics Mary Ballas from our friends over
at
manscaped the holidays are approaching
but what if I told you that the
celebrations are starting early this
year it turns out the perfect gift does
exist and who else to bring it down your
chimney than the leaders in below the
waist grooming keep calm and let your
balls jingle this season with manscapes
brand new performance package 5.0 Ultra
featuring the new lawnmower 5.0 watch
all your wishes and mistletoe kisses
come true
look nice when you're going Naughty by
going manscape.com and use code iron
Lords for 20% off plus free shipping
unwrap the gift of smoothness this
season with
manscaped so now as I have done in the
past couple of weeks I'm going to refer
to my brothers my cohorts to see in this
this season of of giving and being
thankful what are their beards and or
balls thank
in this this
upcoming look man let's start with
Cognito Cognito you know look it was it
was the Lord's born day you know I was
out there you know moving and shaking
but you know we got to make sure the
Royal loins of the Lord are taken care
of you know what I'm saying so what we
got to use is that that 5.0 man a law MO
is official now here's the thing that I
like so you got your USBC right here you
know what I'm saying you get the USBC
get your charge it on and then the cool
thing is this y'all look fellas when you
getting your handling your handle right
see that right there for our melanated
brothers we got a new light y'all see
how you see that light changing so LED
light is bright too yeah man so when you
handling your handle you can see you
don't make any mistakes to your master
sword man you got to make sure that is
taken care of very well so yeah you know
I was out there moving around the town
and I had to make sure everything was
right I also on your birthday you was
smooth beans ioo you keep it high and
tight you a little fade little
fade right so your your nuts W roasting
by an open fire
that's they're nice and they're nice and
cool okay King how about you sir what
what are what are your friends thankful
for well my friends is thankful for the
bed trimmer um if y'all see uh K&N you
know what we doing out here CU our
reporters got to look nice so you know
the bed trim is definitely what I've
been using keeps everything a little bit
you little God is outside I like it um I
I love the package and I love the the
the underwear that it comes with it
comes with this
uh
man yo man we got to holl at y'all y'all
got to get this clothing line popping
cuz the briefs is
fire call called me one day he's like yo
them briefs though right I was like
yeah it hit different so so adct how how
different does it hit how different do
it hit well I I can't speak a whole law
on you know what I'm grateful but I'm
sure my girl grateful for
she she don't complain no more she she
leaves me
alone she she she loves the manscape
when I first said you know we we about
to get uh parked with manscape she said
finally it was a rough situation before
a good thing or a bad thing it wasn't
rough situations before it's just now
it's
nicer so when you got the tools of
perfection you got to be perfect
as for me as for me I've been rocking
with everything but today I rocked the
beard hugger as you can see it's a
little nice and clean got my I'm not
going to actually show the beard hugger
because it's I haven't cleaned it yet so
that would be disgusting
be but but uh I love mascap I love
mascap thank you so much manscape so as
my cohorts have told you manscapes
perform forance package 5.0 Ultra is the
ultimate bundle for the man who deserves
it all included in this special in this
special sack is the lawnmower 5.0 Ultra
the weed whacker 2.0 ear and nose
trimmer manscapes liquid formulations
and two free gifts starting with Santa's
number one helper we have the lawn mower
5.0 Ultra this fifth generation trimmer
features two NextGen blade heads a
standard trimmer blade for taking a
little off the top and a new foil blade
to go for that smooth finish whenever
your heart desires the lawn mower 5.0
Ultra body trimmer and the weed whacker
2.0 nose and ear hair trimmer feature
proprietary Advanced Skin safe
technology to protect your delicate
presence plus both are waterproof so
there's no issue clearing the snow out
of your
driveway I love the inuendo I love this
extra now that you've groomed the candy
cane it's time to make sure you don't
smell like a reindeer with the crop
smoother the crop Soother After Shave
lotion and crop preserver anti-chafe
ball deodorant once they touch your sack
you'll never go back the gift of
manscape doesn't stop there this bundle
comes with two free gifts manscapes
boxers 2.0 premium underwear as my
friends have just told you about and the
shed 2.0 2.0 toiletry bag which will
hold your GES so once you're done
shaping up it's only right that you put
your pants presents in the best wrapping
at all the boxers 2.0 these are
seriously the best boxers that I've ever
wor facts I'm going be real with you
yeah you know pause those those boxes
might be worth the price of that whole
package by
itself my wife saw me in those boxes she
was like oh
boings careful let joystick here that
yeah what I like is is I just naturally
I I just naturally sweat a lot and those
like are sweat resistant so I used to be
I remember I when I was like Elementary
School I when we would like go to the
playground I used to sweat so much that
my teacher used to send me like for a
while she was she sent me to uh to
timeout or whatever they called it back
then because she thought I was pouring
water on my
head it took a while for her to
understand I'm not doing that I just
sweat a lot like I'm sweater as well so
get 20% off in free shipping with the
code ironlord manscape.com that's 20%
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use code iron Lords manscaped get
your jingle balls ready for the
holidays and you know it's we yeah goe I
got I got something to say a good thing
about you know the reason that we really
wanted to cover these Black Friday stuff
is it's like we just we all about saving
money and if we can save you guys
money it's it is it's a win-win and you
know we we if we go above and beyond to
talk about these products like this just
because we rock with these products it's
use them yo we really was inside the DM
U pushing for NZXT to make sure that
they had the Black Friday deals up so we
give you that um and we really wanted
more so like he'll put something in the
chat we like no we need more deals and
um he went and gave us the maximum
amount of deals so all those deals that
y to see but to go back to the
sweatiness um real quick Sovereign
sweatiness was so crazy one Christmas we
went out and got him the airflow
controller remember that oh I remember
that because all right so we'll be
playing TK we'll be playing Tek and
he'll pass the controller over and he'll
pass it over with a swash of
water so that this is why I call him
juicy
right so we'll get the controller one
year we got together and this is how
friends dude nobody ever said anything
nobody ever made him feel bad about it
we went out and we got him that
controller with the air inside and we
you plug the controller in it blows cool
air on your hands he never has sweaty
hands again and yeah it was Y and I
don't know why uh controller people
don't make that anymore well I don't
think he his hands sweat anymore we just
in a competitive now now they be
drenched
up I yo I I have an issue with sweating
too I I I love the summer but it's it's
it's horrific for me because I I can't
sit down on the train I can't do
anything so it's uh it's bad and so I
one time people somebody told me hey try
Botox cuz Botox if you inject it in
certain places it's supposed to stop you
from sweating like your arm prits and
stuff like that the problem with that is
that it doesn't stop the sweating so
much as redirect it some say where's it
gonna go wow yeah yeah yeah don't do
that don't do that all your feet all of
a sudden your feet be drenched for no
[Laughter]
reason he W like
Aquaman let's get the last Super CH we
got Lord
games let me see that we okay we got
Marvin
ginyard $2 Super Chat all hell Sultan
swaave cleric of Clairvoyance I like
that but Messiah is all encompassing
that's
what this guy is crazy this guy
here we got JD G $20 Super Chat I want
to narrative ended in in in capital
letters Microsoft Xbox doesn't need the
game awards the game awards needs them
especially as they buy more the game
awards didn't exist just over 10 years
ago it was all about E3 and look at how
relevant E3 is
now he is trying go scor the Earth
trying to kill Key's show let's
go Robert Kell $2 which had addict's
Master Sword sharpened
damn I wouldn't we're not say nothing
sharpen anyone one that that particular
that they sharpen yeah that's different
that's different that's a little
different yeah different y you
dudes gamer $20 Super Chat uh to the
panel do you think mic Microsoft Xbox
should pay whatever the price is to get
both the marketing rights and some form
of exclusivity for GTA 6 whether it be
timed plus content or something else the
minds on this would be incalculable
expensive expensive I think point addex
point I think the number would be
incalculable the problem with that is
Microsoft is not going to waste money on
that because that doesn't do anything
that just separates people now the only
time I would say and this is a
possibility would to be put that kind of
money is if for some reason GTA 6 was
not coming on Xbox then it's like you
need that's the kind of title where it's
like okay I don't care what do we got to
pay to at least have it on the platform
but you know that that's not the case
you know for the most part as long as
they make sure that their port runs
correctly they'll be fine because here's
the thing Xbox is no longer for the most
part worrying about what other people
are doing they're worrying about what
they're
doing well caught up yep all right yep I
think we are caught now we finally
gotten into the the ler play and int
hour and a half later yeah hour and a
half later don't you be fair that that
that's kind of fair CU we we we were
doing uh you know the Black Friday sales
we lot of I'm surprised it's not two and
a half hours and we got to shift our
Focus back to uh Lord gamesley without
dying to hear the story about while I'm
pronouncing his name incorrectly his
video game system history his journey in
the Taekwondo and of course what led him
to being recognized with multiple
championships internationally in the
sport so Lord games man let's start from
the beginning what were some of the
first video game systems you had what
got you into
gaming all right so um first first
before we get into all that um King uh
one thing uh so that cop story from
before right when he pulled you over um
did you check his
badge oh oh yeah yeah yeah I got his
badge did it have like a did you did did
it have like a logo of any like a
like son
bad know you from the podcast speaking
of plants speaking of plants said get
that
guy messy no no uh bringing it back to
games uh in all seriousness I I started
with tabletop uh RPGs like I said in the
intro section um I started that stuff
very early I was my God I think I was
like five years old watching my brothers
play it
um it just fascinated me that and uh
Magic the Gathering which is a card game
I don't know if you guys play card games
but I play it yeah yeah so I've played
Yu-Gi for like 10 years oh yeah me me me
me as well uh so I loved that stuff so
much and being you know hand you
disabled let's just use the disabled
word handic capable handic capable there
see I don't even know my own terms I
so so uh I I didn't really play well
with console systems or mice yet or you
know any sort of controller I didn't
play very well with those uh so I
referred to card games and board games
so I started with that uh and then as I
grew up I had a solid uh support system
uh my two old brothers uh used to bully
me all the time God bless them now I
bully them uh so
uh they used to bully me all the time
and play rough and get my hands kind of
strong and my uh my mother always used
to buy God bless her you always used to
buy uh little army men toys I don't know
Army joint about the little green ones
little green stiff joints I remember
yeah I love those I love those and she
always used to not very safe for a
little kid but you know um she she was
told by the doctor to buy little tiny
things so that could you know get my
motor skills you're find motor skills
absolutely exactly so uh she did that
and I used to play with that a lot and
As I Grew Older and older and got more
strength and uh my mot skills started to
kick in more I was able to pick up uh
controllers so I picked up the NES
controllers um so I started with the
NES I mostly played Mario um I wasn't
really interested in anything else uh
and then that took me to the nice tube
PCS that I got heavily into PC gaming
okay so those big ugly PCS back in the
90s
2000 um so that's where my gaming really
started I was a huge PC dork still is
still am to this day uh and it all
started on PC with Heroes of Might and
Magic I don't know if you guys yes yeah
yeah it's it's a nice like resource
managements Sim you know tactical combat
kind of game very tactical and yeah yeah
I saw my brothers play it for the first
time and I was so fascinated with it and
they always used to bully me uh and be
like no no you you can't I was to be
fair to them I was very annoying
everything that they wanted buly is a
strong word like I'm getting concerned
with these brothers honestly I'm the
problem so they wanted something I
wanted it two I usually won get over it
now we've got to be clear with the
terror this is bullying of game time or
bassub n they bully they was like get
off the the damn PC bul it was that
situation oh my brother you know they're
rough we're rough
kids anyways damn kid so anyways someone
who used to DDT his brother into
Gladiator I know yes yes yes yes that
rise up
story KATU was rising up with
him that's when I was training Kai Batu
he's like no we ain't GNA do this no
more that's why I'm glad that I'm the
oldest there was none of that happening
you talking
about stor you need to share about Zach
there's like a 12 year old 12 year
difference between me and Zachary so
like I couldn't really bully him till he
was almost a grown ass man
so Jesus anyway continue how about how
about the panel the rest of the panel
you guys got any family something was
broke in the house it was my nice it was
it I got I'm my my sevene difference
between my sister and I is you know vast
so I was pretty much I'm was the one you
know taking her to school doing her
braids getting her clothes and stuff
like that so my thing that's why you
always look so fresh huh oh thank you
see that's that's that's a can and
affiliate thank you thank
youate that home cooking as cooking on
this
guest I'm just saying don't get upset
don't get upset guys don't get upet you
want the king with that compliment
continue continue like gam yeah give him
more give him
more so anyways uh so I saw them play
that game and um Heroes of Might and
Magic of course and uh there there
wasn't much input on it right it's all
clicking on the mouse so it was very
easy for me actually perfect hand for it
so um mouse and keyboard I picked up
very quickly um due to the PC games
weren't so complex back then so right
all started then and then I got into the
more complex stuff as I got older and
older which was like Quake nice and like
Doom let's go uh Starcraft like I'm I'm
so close so Cordon right from window
Central we je I'm I'm just name drop him
but um he's a huge blizzard fan I'm the
same way I am so heavily ingrained with
blizzard I I grew up with them every
single one Orcs And humans um even
Vikings I don't know if you played the
Viking
game shout out to rock and roll racing
Rock and Roll
Racing so blizzard is my baby and I love
them so much so when the ABK deal
happened I was actually excited uh and I
guess that's an unpopular opinion with
Sony fans or sorry did I say Sony fans
oh Lord he mess
Sony um but yeah I don't want to pick on
that fan base they're already losing so
um continue you're you're excited about
the ABK deal as a blizzard fan ABK yes
uh I just got entrenched with old games
and then Warcraft 3 popped along I I
lost my life to Warcraft 3 Warcraft 3 is
my favorite game of all time I could you
know say that with confidence and then I
got into the wow scene and the wow scene
you are a trouble you are a disciple of
K he got in trouble with the wow scene
too oh my god did I get in trouble with
the wow scene that that's when my life
was at my most my lowest point I I I was
as a kid I was always like athletic is
you know I always used to play sports my
mom uh kept me active and uh I went
through the ranks in soccer I'm a big
soccer player nice um but uh at one
point since my height wasn't right I'm
very short guy I'm a little white man uh
you know uh shout out to the little
white man
uh uh the series s small and mighty
little bit little bit no doubt yeah yeah
so I grew up in soccer but I got cut
because I was too short I was way too
short I I was a I was a middle so I
couldn't win the top I couldn't win on
the top balls you know I couldn't win so
they cut me devastating big big
devastating year for me they cut me and
I fell into a a really big hole gotcha
like a right um yeah so I picked up wow
full
time you went fulltime Wow Let's Go
fulltime wow got me in trouble with my
dad and and all that stuff but it was
the funnest uh time of my life as well
because it bonded me with my older
brothers that were bullies to me the my
whole life no I love them very much um
so we bonded over that and then
naturally naturally when Xbox um I I I
dabbled with consoles you know I went
all the way up with uh Nintendo systems
I'm a big Nintendo head as well uh
obviously Simplicity for me is key so
handheld consoles and the NES controller
and such and such Game Boy Color I grew
up with Game Boy Color I love Nintendo
so much um but they were always easy for
me to play easy for me to control except
for 64 which oh 64 wow a little bit yeah
a little bit of a a control problem for
me on the 64 cuz the the
aner yeah so I was like yeah exactly so
like reaching everything was so awkward
for me but that's when I adapted and
again good parents uh I adapted
to I've been adapting my whole life so
adapting to a controller took me not as
long and uh I started using my knees wow
for triggers oh for for the underneath
part so you would keep it like on your
on your lap so to speak yeah
would control the joystick and kind of
like press if we remember the the N64
correct me saw and and did they have
what is it the the Z button or whatever
it was like an underneath button right
yeah yeah the continue again trigger so
that really got me uh used to
controllers with joysticks at first
which is nice
practice um and naturally the Xbox was
like the Xbox console was announced uh I
forgot the exact date but it it was
announced and I was super hyped because
Microsoft right so you hyp coming in
okay as a PC game okay okay you're
looking it from the PC perspective cuz
see for us as a console we were like
what are they doing in console like the
thought process like we know you for
office we don't know you for gaming kind
of thing so it was a little bit of a TR
so in your case as a PC Gamer you're
like wait a minute I want to see what
Microsoft I'm kind of excited on PC and
I was also well the big thing was for me
is that
uh they were very social right like I
mean it's a it was a social platform as
well PC Gamers have been social for a
very long time tabletop as well you know
like very social and for me growing up
so being social was important uh
wherever I can get it so I was really it
really transformed my experience right
with online play and Halo right um so
that really catapulted me into consoles
uh even more heavily and then I you know
I had a PlayStation 2 and I had a
PlayStation but again those controllers
were just God awful for me uh no no
disrespect to them like I know we're
throwing shade for no reason sometimes
but uh their controllers are just not
for me and that's they used to not have
mapable buttons like I'm sure everybody
knows right so like right now I can get
away with a PlayStation 5 controller
because they're all mappable so I can
map like
if I can't reach the trigger because I
my hands on the the joysticks you know I
could map shoot in my Shooters to X or
something right so would you um you you
were you purchasing a lot of third party
controllers when it came to getting your
controllers because there's a lot of
third party controllers that have offset
uh anal yes yeah yeah a lot a lot a lot
a lot a lot so so the difference I just
want to interrupt one quick second cuz I
just want to be clear a good point that
you made earlier Lord games so the
difference is the offset and an are more
helpful than the PlayStation's parallel
off exactly because see just the fact
that the the the analog one of the
analogs is is on the top left I could
claw grip the analog right get it and
then this finger right here could hit
the triggers both of them trigger y so I
could like move around my character and
hit the triggers for shooter games right
for car games or whatever and my other
hand would my Tom would be on the uh
analog and then I could wrap again like
a claw and hit the triggers if I it's
funny because we play the same way and I
think uh s you used to you and kot used
to clown me CU When I play fighting
games I don't play like position I play
like you so I CL I claw cuz to me I
actually yeah I actually feel it's more
precise for me I feel like I'm quicker
on the response with that way yeah with
me it depends on the on the character
like I won't claw for uh like King but
for like a Brian Fury I claw
King the character King in teken pause
that was that was a reach ad PA that was
messy that was a Halo Reach Around Halo
Reach very Halo Reach Around energy but
continue by the way if you need a claw
King I am the best
claw he's going to give assist listen
listen and and I'll let you I'll let you
and C claw your way together no no no
this is a c that affiliate he can
provide you services that you need no no
no he just pay for uh observations he
just CL for CLA for King the new
joystick look look you you you
legit King you are the general of his
army so you got to deal with all
about you got to punish you got to
punish I'm the general of my Army and
again the soldiers will get in line so
if they want to do the chlorin but the
solders love the kid they can do the
chlorin in the barracks do that in the
barracks we we're all inclusive but you
take the chlorine and you can put that
in the
barracks see see y'all made coko come
downstairs Coco said hey hey only person
he choring it's me that's right tell
him Contin that's also I don't think
that's a win that's also a weird you you
boy
gazley yeah so I I had to really adapt U
the Xbox controller was a little big for
me I have to admit like when I when I
got it I also did third party with uh
Xbox stuff at first um and then they had
that mini Xbox controller yeah yes I
don't know I can't remember forgot about
that yeah yeah uh that one was my best
friend I I had played with that all the
time sorry King
so see I'm convinced this we have found
yes all of the trolls in the chat right
now he's got like eight different
accounts good to you little G I wanted I
do want to point out that he
he's on the podcast and we haven't got
any of the new normals in the chat today
yeah they chilling
now he is them it's all wrapped up in
the one one person know where do you
where do you think all my fingers went
you know oh we G to move on from that we
GNA move on WE G to act like that we
didn't hear
that so back to the control back to the
lighter controller that's where we were
at yes lighter controller uh very small
so it it was less
wide so I I could reach everything yeah
um that really transformed everything
for me because uh Halo was so much
easier with that thing I I loved like I
grew up with Halo after that and that
that was actually my first uh experience
with like competitive like we had quake
and stuff but on console that was my
first competitive kind of shooting game
that I I fell in love with nice so I
fell in love with that and naturally you
know Nostalgia kept me in the Xbox
ecosystem forever even to this day I
love I love Xbox so much I love the
community too again to me Xbox is very
Community focused very social nice uh
again it's important absolutely
absolutely so that's why mainly I stuck
with it
um I did
love the what was it any other any
systems any other
things I mean CU I had a question before
before you go on but the question I had
is because all of this to me is really
intriguing right and then we we talk
about the the different variant of
controllers and how helpful that is to
you I do want to fast forward a little
bit because I had the um I was had the
blessing shout out to um me and Sam
Tober believe it was E3 2018 and this
was the debut of the Xbox adaptive
controller and we thought it was
gamechanging and again it was I forgot I
believe ch's name Solomon Romney and he
also shared a similar you know condition
as yourself and you know he was talking
about how much it was a game changer as
far as pushing that accessibility so
have you transitioned and utilized those
controllers as well I know even Sony
himself has run now it's called an
Access Controller have you use it and if
so have those been extremely helpful for
you or do you still traditionally game
like everyone else you know it's it's
super funny um I think I adapted to the
controller so much that it's hard to me
to adapt to something else I got you got
like it's such a weird thing like so
those controllers usually anyways how
how you use them is like they're on the
desk right kind of like arcade system
kind of thing and that was never
comfortable with my palm because so if
you look at my hands okay so one I can
kind of rest on something right so it's
flat I got an elbow everything's good
right it
works uh
so uh but this one I I don't have an
elbow and my palm is kind of
stucking me I know it's a weird so that
would be faing me and to go rest my palm
on something is almost impos it's not
comfortable it's just not comfortable at
all so the desk stuff doesn't really
work for me but I will say that the
attachment stuff like you could attach
like
pedals and okay and that stuff is is
really cool because if I did have to
adapt to it fully that would be like my
number one weapon is mapping L like the
shooting buttons with my P with my feet
with the
feet yes so if my left foot could tap
aim and my right can could shoot and
then all I got to worry about is like
joysticks that would be that would be
awesome for me I think that's a game
changer in shooting anyway and currently
the way it's set up we we can't mix and
match there's no that configurability is
not there currently as we stand I'm not
I'm not I'm not sure I'm look into that
I I believe I believe the PlayStation
one that you could because the
PlayStation one is is that that is okay
so it's a little circle in it's modula
and those little pieces go on um also I
think the Adaptive uh Xbox 2 you're able
to have those uh same modular forms that
you can add stuff to it because I I I've
seen um all type of different
attachments that they have and I thought
that was very
warranted in the gaming space right
because you want to and you kept talking
about like fine motor skills we we deal
with uh children of various ages and
worrying about their fine motor skills
very early on helps them achieve
different things later on in life right
you know when you see the kids growing
and and they're playing with each other
and I think your brothers and yourself
plus you know your eagerness and wanting
to to get those fire motor skills and
your mother giving you the toys to play
with help you in the gaming space
because you said these controllers that
are made for you to
use you're more likely to go to a
regular controller because your fine
motor skills and your ability to adapt
to what you've had your environment this
whole period of time at a curiosity you
know uh because I assume um the way that
you use like the Xbox One control and
stuff I assume uh did do they do you you
go through them faster or like the
joystick because I'm kind of curious on
like using them to that degree do you
have to buy controllers quicker because
like where there yeah I I do follow a
lot of Tik Tok people uh that I don't
know uh what particular uh dis disabled
disability they have but there's this
one person that he has to go through he
goes through like three or four Xbox
controlls a year but he does he plays
like Apex Legends and stuff so I'm kind
of curious your take on that do you
think these controllers are are built
for that
stuff well I mean first off being
modular helps a lot like swap out
controllers all the time right so that's
a good thing um but uh I I could see it
I I get drift a lot more frequent okay
got it uh because I'm like push like
joysticks
areu I think that's why he has to
replace them too hall effect uh
joysticks or whatever that are coming
out now that are supposed to not have
drift cuz it's magnets or whatever I
don't know what the magic is but um
those might work a lot better so the
tech as Tech enhances everything just
gets more you know just better overall
but this the drift thing is a problem
because I'm always squishing got always
squishing and move and pressing at the
same like it's
just I I could see drift being a problem
but I I don't I I went through
Xbox 360 was my most played Xbox system
MH uh for good reason yeah
um I went through at least eight or nine
controllers their joysticks um messed up
on me but I I wasn't aware right that it
was a me thing or I thought it was just
normal I grew up think I was normal the
whole time so kudos to my parents and
brothers for that as I said I'm very I'm
very lucky I'm very lucky abolute I love
love the hear the stuff and I'm sorry
continue I'm sorry say something I say
you know sh shout out to you know people
that are you know deal with the
conditions that you deal with just shows
how much like people love games it's
like you know I know a lot of people
that could have been in the same
situation but like I'm just not g to
play games but you like no I'm G figure
this
out 100% break because to me I can't
even being
annoying that's that's yeah go sorry to
to me I guess like we you know you were
coming through with these uh you know
reprogramming your mind like I have a
hard time re like going from regular
default shooting settings on Halo to
Bumper jumper without like dying every
five seconds because I'm trying to pess
the right bumper to jump or a to jump
and like I couldn't even imagine like
trying to like feel like I need to
incorporate my legs just to play a game
and it's like the fact that like the
passions there so strong that you was
like we're playing this it doesn't
matter what I got to do we're playing
this well I I think that was uh family
because you know when you hear it his
brothers was bullying him getting him
into stuff and um not treating him
different you understand like I I want
to play so all we all know and we have
older siblings the younger ones always
want always want to keep up with the old
facts right so that's the motivation I
want to to
dominate see this is the competitive
this the competitive that's that's
that's the thing in you and the fact
that you know you said you're very uh
blessed because they didn't allow you to
Stew in your depression if you ever
caught any depression they was like nah
n get back up into it n n you ain't got
no excuse you don't even know the terms
for yourself fact this is how this is
how you are inclusive in your family
because you don't even use any any words
as crutches to to to talk about a
disability just how you've been on our
podcast I'm sure the humor between you
and your siblings is crazy y I came in
he didn't even like the music I was
playing he wanted some ratchet
music in my I'm right in my defense I'm
right right right what I say Lord Gaz
like would because of your brother's
being out of pocket yeah always you know
what I'm saying challenge you do did
like that really motivate you to be like
okay did you have those moments when you
get them and like whether it be
competitive or just in in grinding a
game together stuff like that let's talk
about that oh yeah first off I
constantly R uh W hero Heroes of Might
magic playthroughs like constantly and
also when I play Pikachu on Super Smash
Brothers uh and I spam that
button you talking about the thunder
thunder know the know the I got to do
that's all I got to you got
do my cousin's wife had a mean ass
Pikachu man I hated playing her man oh
my
God
that she she'll take this little
innocent creature and just demolish me
over over and over so close your eyes
and and think of this right he just said
what he just said close your eyes
and think of it he say yo my cousin's
wife got a mean
Pikachu no he said a mean Pikachu there
was a word oh my God yeah like like he
been scheming on that part
of Pikachu is he said a mean a Pikachu a
Pikachu yeah I can't like besides like
you know the the 5-year-old stuff like I
couldn't I couldn't stand fling that
Pikachu man I
it would annoy me like could no cuz like
Pikachu designed Pikachu's designed on
Pikachu's design on Super Smash Brothers
to be like really annoying and just hit
you with one hitter quitters hey addict
hey addict think about that Pikachu
beating
you I'm out of here
out it's in my
nightmares know
go y' messy doesn't even know what's
happening he's
shocked but listen listen it was
motivation it was
motiv
yeah I don't even know where I was in my
jne we went left it was you was on
beating
him you you on destroyed
those yeah yeah I wanted to
win yes I was always competitive you
know uh I I skipped a huge part of my
life which was like naturally going
through World of Warcraft and and I I
was jez would know a lot about this okay
so next time you have him on you know
absolutely Arenas Arenas and PVP in WoW
were and open world PVP so player versus
player environments and wow was such
crack and so good in vanilla wow that it
was just it hooked it hooked you um and
also a side plot there uh wow being
difficult by the way uh multiplayer
games being difficult MH
um is the point because you're supposed
to you know build a community around
them and grab your friends to take out
things and and be social and um uh
blizzard turning into casual Studios for
some reason all right going we oh we
doing this okay I got a question we
going do this I got a question for you
continue when it's so easy but anyways
point is oh so you're so you're Pro ulty
versus versus accessibility so let let
me in multiplayer multiplayer games okay
so let this is this please finish and
then I ask a question actually have
question the reason why Wow the reason
why I loved wow so much and my is
because I was playing with my brothers
why did I play with my brothers not
because they're cool they're not cool um
because because I needed help I needed
help because if you're a solo player in
early World of Warcraft y you have to go
around sniping bores so they don't
murder your face one by one mhm you
couldn't grab three of them like Diablo
right and and and tornado everything and
they all die no no you had to bow and
arrow these things away from their
friends so they don't gang yeah don't
use that word don't use that word on the
Law's day but gang Destroy You Yes
um good pivot good pivot I like that you
know that was a switch kick that was a
Taekwondo switch kick right there I like
that exactly no back kickick back kick
so so that's that's that's the whole
reason that's the whole reason right
like grab your
friends to help you with the thing and
it builds your community right and and
nowadays the you know Warcraft stuff
that's happening here uh you could go in
Solo and you you don't care what mob you
pull or what creature you pull because
you know then you're safe you're safe
the whole game it turned into Diablo
that World of Warcraft is not Diablo
Diablo is Diablo World of Warcraft is a
community game right that you're
supposed to be it's supposed to be
difficult and grab your friends to
progress you know not fair dungeons
raids
anyways so since uh so to actually go
for I don't want to lose this question
before you move on which is this is a
great discussion point and you seem you
know very Pro difficulty there but I'm
ask the trophy question yeah for for
single player you know a bit of
controversy for some right now is in
reference to like for example Souls
games right and which the developer
generally the intent is it for to be
very difficult but some people have
counted back and say hey there should be
easy mode there should be something in
place for accessibility where does l
gamesley stand on that side for single
player games where do you where's your
position has to think carefully about
all this no no say say say say what's in
your heart say
um growing up I'm going to take a
different angle on it um growing up so
single player games to me if uh let's
say I don't know the hardest Mario game
or the hardest I don't know whatever
game pick a game um if it was oh Mega
Man Okay Mega Man good one good one good
choice good choice Mega Man is ridic
ridiculously hard um back then anyways
yes um if that game is hard you know
first off every every young person right
will pick up something and and beat it
with enough time because we're so we're
sponges we we adapt quickly and we learn
quickly and whatever um if you don't
like it you could put it down whatever
but back then you didn't put it down cuz
they're so expensive and the system's
expensive and whatever you pick it up
you practice you practice you practice
you practice you play the same game
50,000 times and and that's the only
choice you have and you get good at it
and you progress and you you beat the
thing right absolutely I love difficult
games in that way but right now as I'm
getting older and as the industry
gets with so many games coming out we
don't have that time right and our
reflexes are downgrading per second
right so I'm 32 I'm not that old right
I'm 32 I'm you know not older than you
guys this
watching what I prove that sound like an
adct disciple continue that's
right so you know uh now say it again
say it with your
chest so uh 30 Jesus yeah yeah uh so as
my reflexes get a little bit off right
I'm not as good at games
uh you know I could start seeing why you
need to add those things right I could
start to see why and add all the
millions of games that come out daily
it's not like back then right daily
thousands of games you know come out so
for those games it would be smart and
those devs would be smart to be like
well if PE like people don't have time
right now and especially our older
audience doesn't have time right now so
if they can't progress through something
they're going to drop it sell it move on
to the next game and try that thing
right so right now difficulty is is a
little bit it would be kind of weird not
to add the ACT you know the extra step
got it which because this is like why
why not right uh I for from software
games a lot of yeah from software games
I'm GNA give them a lot of credit okay
Elden ring I passed it to them they're
simple
uh pivot was open world not Corridor
right Corridor if you're like Corridor
and it's so hard you're you're beating
the same enemies consistently like old
school games and it gets kind of boring
and whatever and you'll you might drop
it for the next game right their their
answer to that was well why don't we
just make it a Sandbox right why don't
you just make it a Sandbox and they can
grind in their own way in different
places and see different things and you
know the thing is just natural right you
just oh okay I can't go here let me go
over there and getting there you level
up a lot then you go back to the thing
and you beat the boss right absolutely
and it's it's their easy mode and that
in that way in that sense as as well as
the summons and etc etc um so my stance
is very I I don't know I from software
keep doing from software everyone else
it doesn't hurt you it doesn't hurt you
to put the option in because to be
honest unless you're an
Allstar uh people are going to drop your
game after hours I think I think it it's
more systemic to a bigger problem that
we have in the society that we are in
right now I don't think it has anything
to do with your age uh you know uh you
getting older and your skills
diminishing um that's you um but you
know my skills get greater you know I
get
older listen I lie to myself anyway um
no I I just feel that in the society we
are in right now the way that we consume
things we consume things that keep our
attention all right so we we are built
on the scroll generation we scroll all
we're doing is scrolling right so
whatever catches our interest right
there we stick with it we can see the
video If whatever doesn't catch our
interest right there we drop it we have
so many games coming out rapidly and we
have so much access to everything if
when we first turn that game on if it
doesn't immediately catch you if we hit
a barrier it's O squirrel let me go to
this over here and I think that is the
bigger problem so the fact that the devs
and everybody sees this metrics sees
these analytics do they get past this
point let's put a easy mode in this game
to allow people to continue to progress
so I think it's more systemic to the
society that we live in now because back
then we didn't have access to that stuff
we have now yeah that's that that was
the the the point like on the second
yeah I know K that news you know yeah
exactly
do you feel the studios that don't do
these do you feel like they should be
more like you know in tone with what's
going on or do you think that you know
creative freedom is one of those because
it's like from software you know they
they make these type of games but I do
think they've done little things like
you know like Mak stuff open world you
know Elden Ring's the
easiest easiest from software game known
to man would you prefer them go the more
directions through that through that or
like establish more like easy modee
stuff that you know maybe this
particular boss is a is a certain you
know is harder for for you to maneuver
around and maybe give options for that
or do you think they should go the
ladder with you know just making the
game more accessible not necessarily the
control is more accessible if if if
devs want to have both things going for
them they do the thing where maybe they
don't have the option but they do like
many games like Yakuza if you get your
face yeah they be like yo you want to
put it down on E they told me yeah right
they insult you like my brothers my damn
Brothers they insulted me my ego didn't
let me put the down cuz I was getting
mad and you and they give you three
options right like easy easier you know
easiest and that's it do you think
because I think the issue is when
developers don't do it people attack
them for it they're like look this is
how we initialize the game uh you know
just get over it do you think that they
should reone or do you think that it's
like look that's the Crea free because
to me I I don't care if if from software
gam got a easy mode I ain't go play it
but I I don't care to give the option as
long as it doesn't affect the overall
product that I was going to play from
the start guys if the quality is there
the quality is there you know just that
that's that's as long long as the
quality is there so if you can't tell me
with a straight face that putting an
easier mode for more people to kind of
jump into your game um you know it it
doesn't make sense to me if you're going
to say you know oh my God we can't do
that because it's going to affect the
quality you're you're lying straight to
my face okay well straight to our face
so what do you say what a from soft game
is going to be a from soft game with an
easy mode or not or an easy boss or not
you know uh easy option after few deaths
or not like it's going to be S so I got
another question because uh BG is big on
like trophies and stuff and he's felt
like since they've went more towards
like
accessibility they've made a lot of
these platinums easier to get um you
know so he has a huge issue with that
because he he him and Jack move was like
real big people on you know fighting for
these Platinum but they they do feel
like since they have pushed for that
more like what a platinum would have
normally took like 20 20 40 hours takes
like a whole just one playthrough now do
do you think because to me once again
like I don't care about the trophy stuff
but I'm just going off of like the
community feedback and like around the
accessibility options in general because
I don't think accessibility options have
nothing to do with trophies but there's
a lot of people that feel like you know
being more into the accessibility when
it comes to PlayStation they have made
their games easier in general Hey listen
listen first off first off before before
I let King speak a little bit because I
want to laugh uh guys guys look at my my
face look
Twitter having having a trophy that only
1% of people
get doesn't make you
special it doesn't make you special it
actually does the reverse you should go
play some basketball or whatever you
want to play little grass touch grass a
little bit more you know and all those
five fingers but to use but anyways oh
my God
now ask your ask your girl about it
she'll
tell secondly hold on I'm a little messy
right now real Mr Steal Your
Girl the real achievements in the game
is beating the game or climbing a ladder
board or if you're competitive right if
you're
competitive all right you get grandmas
in League of Legends right or you get I
don't know Grandmaster in valerant
that's your Achievement System if you
don't like it okay no fair enough you
you have spoken we what is it's not if I
could get trophies and
platinums uh the same as you those 1%
with zero fingers to my name uh I don't
think it's a huge deal guys grow up
right no fair enough you you preaching
right now you you in your bag I I guess
I guess the last question cuz since we
being spicy let's go all the way so my
question that that's I said love and
smoke love and definitely love and smoke
definitely love and smoke all love and
we just having these real conversations
so what about what do you say to the
developer let's just say I'm from
software developer right and they say
but Lord gamesley Spirit of our game
this is the Creative Vision you're
changing the Creative Vision of my game
if you're telling me to put in an easy
Bol and I want to keep the spirit of of
of the gay what do you say to that
developer you know the they're
Liars they're Liars first off first off
I'm giving them credit way more credit
than I I should maybe but I I truly
believe that from software magic is
literally in their level design and and
and and that's where they Shine the most
they created that level design they cre
they almost created that whole you have
to be really talented and smart and and
to get to lay out a map like they do
they're very good at laying out the map
they're very good at atmosphere they're
really good at just games right they're
just really good at them so to say that
we play from software games and our
quality depends on easy or not is
ridiculous and I think you don't believe
them it's ridiculous I I don't believe
them I think if anything it takes a
little bit of effort and they don't have
the people to put in the effort or they
don't want the people or they just you
know it's a resource of some sort that
they don't want you know what's you know
what's funny where I've always stood by
this is like there's literally console
com console commands on PC that do the
cheat codes already just like just just
set up a couple of them as an easy mode
and just call it a day because like
these people are doing this after the
game's out so it didn't affect the
quality of the game I mean
but hip hop gamer is notorious for using
cheat
codes I mean that's that's that's been
in video games forever I just love but
my point but my point is is the games
hip hop gamer plays he has access to
these cheats goes did it affect the
quality of the game at all when he
played it no he still enjoyed it like
that that's why I just don't understand
where it's like giving a game an easy
mode just going to ruin it it's just
like I just like the fact that these
PlayStation Plus platinums mean
nothing you guys all I heard was you
guys is did you Platinum this and did
you Platinum that and I know I was
trying I was trying to figure out why
people aren't talk about platinums no
more it's cuz yo put Spider-man on easy
and still PL yo I don't yeah it's it's
ridiculous honestly it's it's absolutely
ridiculous I don't care like
congratulations you beat the game on
whatever mode okay cool they got they
got 35 platinums and not to not to I got
I got 35 gold medals
where perfect transition not not not to
mention like a lot of the harder
difficulties in this games all it does
is artificially make these enemies
bullet sponges so it's like what did you
really do you were you were a 10c more
patient than I was like Fair yeah well I
don't know people like uh to be fair to
them now I'm going to come back to ni
Anthony nice Anthony I to be fair again
guys I love guys I love difficulty I I
I'm I love it I I strive for it maybe
maybe you should too maybe you should do
it too right that's good on you but
let's not OV exaggerate gotta that's
fair that's fair I respect it's
ridiculous anyway no I respect I like to
collect the thing too I like to collect
the thing and I like to see the pop up
and I like to you know whatever but at
the end of the day it means zero oh so
people are inflating the world okay I
get your position I'm glad you had to
that I really respect that I do want in
transition because we got a lot to get
into and the thing I want as far as you
talk about championships you talk about
medals right we're talking about you
know this martial arts that
you5 exactly you know what I'm saying
and um go 35 gold oh 35 T hear that King
King true he listen listen you said you
got 35 gold I got one
I got one go we both I I could buy that
too King I could buy that too see the
thing is the thing is you don't got it
tomorrow you don't got it but I see your
uh your Twitter feed tomorrow you better
have so look now we got trans to what
what a lot next week's going to show up
with 35 of those things around his
check don't worry don't worry wait
there's more arms race don't wor more
lot lot lot of bling l a bling floating
around but yeah now I want to transition
to reference to like you said we talk
about real trophies and real
achievements and what you do you know
what I'm saying obviously you you we
both share passion for for tawo and you
know looking at your journey and you
know when did you fall in love with this
martial arts how did that skill develop
and what led you to competing you know I
I feel I feel like I'm I'm I must
somebody's watching over me and and
helping me along because uh since the
conception of like anything Marshall art
like that I was exposed to I I loved it
so whether it's Jet Lee Bruce Lee
whatever I don't I love I loved martial
arts since I was a little kid there was
something I was a n i was a little white
man ninja running around for every
Halloween every single Hall salute to
the ninj salute to the ninja suits
salute y i i i
loved uh everything martial art to the
look to
the technique to everything it just
looked beauti beautiful to me it looked
nice to me and uh I was intrigued right
away and naturally you know my my
brothers um went to a pretty prestigious
school here uh old male School poor them
uh
so uh all male school and really high up
here in Montreal um right they were
looking for my mom was looking for like
an after school again grade parenting
after school after school activity uh
for My Brothers whenever they like uh
ended school they needed to go do
something they would go to she looked
around for like a something for them to
go do so she didn't have to pick them up
right away you know right
um luckily there's a taon those school
right there and it's been there ever
since and it's my gym that I go to now
um and she found it and they she brought
my brothers there and I was always
coming along cuz I was very very young I
think around like 5 years old six maybe
M um
so from the moment I saw this coach and
from The Moment I Saw which again
environment and Idols are very important
you know father figures are very
important absolutely uh I saw this man I
saw how he interacted I I think he's a
lovely person I think he's the best
person I know um and I saw the technique
I was already outside looking and
mimicking everything I saw in there like
mimicking everything I saw even if I
fell on my face even if they look like
no oh look at me I'm doing a 360 look at
me I'm doing a double be chuggy well no
that's just you know flaring around like
a fish but anyway point is I was trying
to do it um and so naturally my mom's
like Oh look this fish let let him let
him get in there let let him get the
technique proper so she put me in there
and um it was just it's from 6 years old
uh to around 11 or 10 before I went into
soccer I was obsessed nice um I was
obsessed with it I loved it I made a bad
move as all teenagers do and uh around
12 or 13 13 13 uh I dropped it for
soccer because again I was again I was a
very social kid and taon do martial arts
um if you want to be
competitive yes the team does matter a
lot but it was a little bit too
individual listic for me right because I
had to push myself I had to learn myself
basically you know alone whatever
um for the most part um so I was like
you know what let me go do the social
thing and go into a team sport and let's
see how that goes I was really good
turns out I'm really good at it um both
Sports have nothing to do with hand so
God bless salute salute so uh I got into
that um and blessing and a curse M uh
like I said in the beginning I got cut
from soccer because I was too uh short
right and that was around 18 19 years
old I got cut and I went into that
gaming mode where I became like I think
one of the top I swear to God I was the
top Paladin in in in in North America I
was I was I was very much high up there
in the rank and I'm sure jez if I gave
my name I'm sure he could find me and uh
I have all the accolades there um and I
got obsessed in that and uh after
hitting myself in the face and my mom
being like yo you go to you gota you got
to move again my brothers are like go
move again I decided to move again and
who did I think of well the Father
Figure right the man that was so he just
had an energy right he he always he
didn't discriminate he didn't you know
he loved he from the moment I again from
the moment I saw this man he made me
feel like uh you know I was I was
something and uh so that's the first
person that popped in my mind and I
called him he REM remembered me
instantly I wonder why um and
I I rejoined and then it was just
serious from then on right at 20 years
old uh from I got my what green belt
back really quickly nice and then it was
just constant like I wait wait wait you
said you got your green belt back so
when you left Dojo they took your belt
away well no no so I was so far removed
right like it was like seven years or
eight years okay so you so it's like you
have to take the test again it's like a
road test yeah they were like he he
studied me for like two-ish weeks you
know I would come to class he would just
give me he'd give me my belt but but he
wouldn't like be he i' do white belt
classes you know okay okay and he would
he studied me a little bit and he's like
okay go back there you know you belong
with them so I went to the elite more
Elite classes right right right um so I
did that and then it was just from then
on from I think the morning toight I was
at that gym I didn't care he he he knew
I had a job I had my own I had my own
family business with my brothers kind of
running on the side um in construction
so my father had a big construction
plumbing company kind of thing um and
it's family-owned and I used to work
there all the time and I actually went
to them I'm like yo I I want to stop so
I could just sleep at this gym just
breathe Taw I just want to kick I want
to do this I want I don't care if it
pays less money I don't care nothing
again Lily I had the support system to
do so nice uh so they allowed me and and
uh my coach actually just gave me a job
there like he would just like let me do
the cash or the whatever I I was mopping
and scrubbing I was Mr
Miagi Dan Dan side wa wa legs kid legs I
respect that's what I did there and uh
and I just I I breathed it I got my
black belt when I
was
25 mhm so five years later I got my my
black belt ni uh CU I was just I was
always there um I competed all the time
on small competitions and then when I
got my black belt he put me in the more
serious competitions where you you know
you have to what's the highest what's
the highest color you get
to it's it's black belt but they give
you the D they give you the Dan system
the Dan on them right yeah okay so all
right so when somebody pull up with
their belt and they belt got other
little tabs at the bottom of it that's
how I tell what level they are right yes
so all right so if they pull up with a
regular black belt I uh we could just do
this but if they pull up with a black
belt with a couple of colors at the
bottom yeah well if you're if you roll
up and the guy has uh I don't know you
have to worry about the five or four
four and five DS are
particularly scary why because they're
in their Prime still right like
the system is made that if you're the
further you go the older you're go like
exactly that's how it works but it's
made to be super hard so it advances
every like to get a black belt it's
let's say two uh first Dan two years you
know but then second then four years and
thir then seven years or whatever right
so by the time you're fourth or fifth
you're like
35 but in in taekwan though it's a very
strong year 35 and 30s like mid-30s
you're you're very strong uh not not in
speed not in your power maybe you're
dwindling a little bit but your mind is
so sharp that you're scary still at 35
No Doubt so if you see four or five
danss stay away from those guys if you
say eight six seven you know ah they're
old you know you
should you R up you can rough up a eight
Dan but them four Dan yeah those four
and fives you know
say what Dan are you I'm a five Dan no
no no no no no no we're good we're good
we good I respect I respect I wanted I
wanted to ask cuz obviously with all the
you know the competitions and obviously
the uh par Taekwondo you know
championships and things that D like
from all your competitive
accomplishments what is your magic
moment what is the the one that means
the most to
you I would say
say I why this is a tough one because
the world's so world power taond do
Championship so that's the big one World
Championships is the big one under right
under actually most would get if if
somebody would get golden World
Championships arguably that's more
prestigious to you and in the sport than
even the Olympics why because it's a
point system and few that has the most
points will be going to the Olympics
right but to beat worlds like to win
worlds in Gold you're fighting every
single scary psychopath you could fight
even the people with zero points you
know some of these guys are scary young
guys there's they have fire they have
passion they have nothing to lose if you
go through everyone including the top
people right I mean to me that that's a
huge absolutely huge win right for
me uh so when I got silver in Worlds
that is technically the biggest thing
that I've
done um but my Shining Moment was Asia
because that was my first International
go mhm so internationally I didn't get
tons of gold uh and that was my first
one and it was a very special year
because my uh grandmother very important
to me passed away that year and I said
I'm gonna get that gold you next
competition I'm fighting and I'm going
to I'm going to win and it's going to be
you and I'll send you a picture and uh
sadly it didn't happen because she
passed but I did get that gold so that
that moment was blessing yeah that
moment was huge for me it kind of gets
me sad but huge for me but that's that's
my heartfelt uh true number one but the
world was gigantic cuz I also World
Championship also is very huge uh emot
let me ask your a question as one combat
dude to the next right um you stepping
up
to you're stepping up you got the
butterflies in the back I know you got
the butterflies right yeah yeah all all
the time right okay okay you know I hate
the guys that be like I ain't getting no
butterflies shut up you get butterflies
no no no they they they come uh I'm
going to let you finish the question but
they come the butterflies are um they
come in different ways it's not you know
when somebody says Hey butterflies did
you get any it depends
what time you're asking right on the mat
and about that day me no but one week
before yeah those butterflies killing me
right those butterflies are in my head
my question on the no yeah my my
question to you going up because um us
Fighters are are we are ritualists like
certain rituals that we do do you have a
ritual that you have right before you
step on the M right right before I got
into the ring my uh my ritual is a
thought process that I train my
mind uh you know stepping in soon as my
head goes under I'm invulnerable I'm
undefeated you can't stop me I'm going
to break you and it stays in my brain as
I'm walking through and as I'm walking
closer and closer and as the moment
approaches I feel like a shield of armor
come over myself and my mental state
becomes that of a brick wall um what is
what is your your your your mental state
as you're stepping to that mat what is
your process in your brain as you're you
see you can see your opponent or your
opponent you can see your opponent
coming what is your process as you're
stepping to that mat my this is going to
sound weird or not depending on who you
are and how you know me is that first
off I do this hockey thing uh equipment
is very important to me I have to have
my first Dan Black Belt if I don't have
my first Dan Black Belt I don't see that
sweat it's kind of gray now because of
the sweat kind tears apart the black and
it I really if I don't have that thing
my mind like goes off it's like if I'm
wearing that I'm like look how much
you've done you know sweat and Blood and
Tears is in this thing you you did this
and you're going to go in there and
you're going to show what you got you
know and if I don't have that piece of
equipment on me I go I get a little
jittery you know if I have it uh the
second thing that may be shocking is
that when I'm walking up those stairs I
look at the guy and I I instantly put my
mind in um a sun death a sun death match
and I'm losing I'm
losing and I am going through 700
scenarios in a couple of minutes right
walking in there of me losing and then
me coming back and what what what what
did he throw to make me lose you know
what did he throw what what stepping is
he using you know what kicks are what
what's his best kick what is he catching
me with and then I just consistently
just counter that move
right I consistently just counter that
move and or or those things and I come
back at certain points and then I lose
at certain points like I'm mentally
thinking of that fight every step of the
way because usually we know the people
and if we don't I'm doing the same thing
but got you usually I I'm I'm confident
on my feet after that that's dope so
basically it's the mental chess game of
that person's best Arsenal right and
then it's like okay what I'm going to do
to either take that away to counter that
and you're doing this up until before we
say fight oh even oh yeah as soon as I'm
I'm looking at him first of all in
Taekwondo we do this thing because it's
it's very it's pressure sensors now on
the pad so we have foot guards that have
pressure sensors on them and then the
connection is on the pad too so when you
hit it it transmits signals and then
goes to Bluetooth board and it scores or
whatever right right um so we do this
thing where we get on the pad and we
test right okay you kick him in the
thing
okay
I always what if I do have Jitters if I
I do this thing where if I feel a weak
kick I'm eating them I'm eating him oh
he L he fooled he fooled he
if you're hitting me like a
three-year-old on the test mat I'm I'm
killing you head the scenarios the
scenarios CH Checker the chin Checker
okay first kick I'm going to back kick
him through the roof so K if that if
that touch gloves is weak yeah this yeah
CU I'm thinking about it I'm like wow
that could be a huge setup to somebody
like let me tap him nice and light oh
yeah oh no but if if if this guy hits me
like a monster
right I'm still I'm
like okay how did he turn his hip how
did he turn his hip wow that knee was
pretty low that knee was pretty low so
yeah so you're looking for opening go
yeah yeah let's go how's this technique
because to hit hard you got to have a
technique in there you know not
everybody could hit hard so if you're
hitting me hard okay what what's that
technique oh that's your favorite leg
because we don't test both right
sometimes so you know the CH game I'll
see if you test your right leg and it's
hard and your left leg sus oh yeah if
your right leg is hitting me like a
softy and your left leg is hitting me
like a monster you like your left and
I'm going to kill
you doesn't matter I'm running something
either way either way salute no that's
dope that's dope I love this type of
stuff the mental aspect of fighting last
question before we move on cuz we got to
we got we got to get going but this is
this is a dope m no this is F this is
fine this the mental aspect just cuz
we're Tekken fan I didn't know if you
associate with Tekken at all or any
fighting games I was just curious based
on you being a fighter if if fighting
gam n not so much all I love them if I
could play them effectively I would love
them even more uh I could play them
effectively that's downgrading my skill
but I I I'm
not not I instead of taking my time on
Tekken I'm League of Legends guy right
I'm wow that's where I was going before
with Wow being competitive it
transformed me uh because wow is so big
and so competitive but there's a lot of
buttons and as wow went along there was
more like more and more skills to press
more and more buttons to press right at
some point yeah so when when League of
Legends came out and it's three buttons
yeah I'm like I'm G to murder everybody
in this game guess what I did I did
murder everybody so it it's uh yeah so
fighting games I just didn't have the
time because um like I did I didn't
spend my time getting good at the
fighting game no fair enough fa brother
I love your journey your story is
amazing love the confidence you know
what I'm saying love you know your
perseverance and never one thing I
respect about you know just researching
was just like never allow anything to
deter your joy and and and your mindset
like I just love that aspect I do have
to ask a question that ad has asked a
lot of people where did you first hear
about IOP where was your first
experience hearing about us I'm very
curious okay well when you know you go
to the grocery store and you see pork I
love pork you're in the I love pork
section I was like ah I got it we ain't
doing a
joke it's too early for real though I
I'm a huge fan of podcast like I I love
uh kind of funny I love I know the those
guys you know PlayStation Centric but uh
I love I love podcast and I listen to uh
everything I love Colin um I love I love
the Last Stand guys you know I love all
that stuff um you know as I'm running
like because I'm I'm an athlete so I do
a lot of running I do a lot of Kicking
and and sometimes music doesn't do it
for me so I just pop on a podcast when
I'm on a long jog because I I do 10ks
every day oh wow you know and and that's
that's you know an hour of my life or 45
minutes depending on how good I feel and
um that's that's a lot so I pop on a
podcast and I listen while I run and
it's almost like nothing H you know
nothing nothing like time passes so
quickly so that's that's where did you
find IOP I'm just curious I have to know
this how did you find
IOP IOP you showed up
on I started to get heavily into you
when you started showing up uh on with
Maddie on um okay on defining Duke on
that okay yes defining Duke and why I
found even defining Dukes because Colin
and I you know it's a whole reach
around
right uh when when those kind of funny
guys were in IGN right car and Greg
together right yes and then they
separated and that's a long journey
right and then I found last stand right
and then Carrick was on
and then yes and then uh you popped up
and I was like oh I I've seen I I you
know this guy's awesome and I hopped in
and I backtracked a bunch I backtracked
so much again I run a lot I backtracked
a lot you went back to the old
episodes oh yeah man I I needed some
content and and there wasn't many people
that I you know many content I think
kind of funny shout out to them shout
out I love those guys but uh it's
there's not a lot going on there for me
anymore only because uh I don't know I
like the spice about drama you're about
the drama we yeah they're not they're
not very spicy ever since you know you
know Colin uh isn't there anymore I
think the opinions were very stagnant
and um I di so I died Fair again no no
calling out just yeah no shade no shade
it's just your preference that's my
thing yeah I still listen to them daily
good friends good friends a lot of them
over there no doubt no doubt no I
appreciate I appreciate that now this is
dope and then we got to ask the final
questions that we ask every guest in the
realm I need Lord games Le's top five
video games or franchises of all time no
pressure okay I got to do
Warcraft I got to do Warcraft because
War of the warcraft yes
um I got to
do got to do Pokemon because that's my
big biggest uh bonding that's my biggest
bonding game right I bonded uh a lot
with friends on that one and even my
girlfriend that I have right now uh
beautiful by the way uh she plays that
and we Bond over it every every year
that's what's up shout out to lady
gamesley yes
um that's twoo
Zelda Zelda tears of the kingdom and
breath of the wild and or Karina of time
specific
again yeah oring of time specifically
and then the other two follow not far
behind oh SK got s
and I don't think he's dead I don't
think he said skyw SW I don't think I
heard that he's a he he's a can an
offici
affiliate see unfortunately
unfortunately those don't get stripped
don't get stripped in
dance let's keep your dance intact let's
go next
those controllers sucked all right those
controllers sucked there you go remove
his
dance he ain't invited back no more
because so we got Z two more so I'm
fifth by the way just saying yeah we
taking two from
there you three D now keep it up going
be two D come back with the
smile with the dead pad
smile continue so
um where was I okay yeah Zelda um okay
this is hard two more I have to put this
is a weird one but it connects with me
uh a lot go um Age of Empires o yeah I
love age of empir first age reference
there we go let's go yeah Age of Empires
was a series that I I really man I love
tactics games like obviously well I love
that type of game cu the the I mean
Warcraft it has some DNA right Starcraft
it has some DNA uh I love Age of Empires
and I I don't know it's just it was the
coolest thing to me you know harvesting
the animals and like just I don't know
it was new silly but I love it RTS one
more yeah rtss are awesome one
more top five I'm not going to go the
League of Legends route because I find
that wow just uh really gave me both
competitive and and uh narrative so I'm
not going to go the League of Legends
route even though League of Legends is
probably my top plate in time sheer time
played I've been playing it for 11 years
10 years 11 years wow
um have to be really something for you
it just has
personal personal attachment so many
that's why this is that's why I'm a very
I have a lot you can always change it
later uh let's see I'll make this really
quick there was one on my list I have a
list here he's got the list prepared boy
ready okay you're you're I'm going to go
for it uh Worms 2 Worms 2 from Team 17
okay Worms 2 worms I don't know if you
know what this game is but it's yeah
it's you know what worms is it's
a yeah worms is dope yeah so worms to
I'm put at number five because the sheer
time of me kicking the bleep out of my
didn't Worms 2 launch on the what was it
this the Nintendo 64 I think they they
had exclusive on I played it on PC I
know it was on PC yeah man love the five
and final question I me know I know you
played your your journey started on PC I
do have to ask your favorite console of
all time and
why and why is it Xbox easy
in a witness Jesus hey oh hold on my dog
is about to bark one second hey hey stop
it she's she's a husky so she's very
loud can I can I just one second yeah
yeah yeah get the D wolf get the D wolf
hand to the D wolf quick I'm so sorry
about no no no you're good you good
you're good we we take care of the
animal you like to see hold on a second
yeah so yeah here we
go the dog at oh I like his background
back
fire the dog ate him
ha all right so sorry about that okay
I'll be right back okay take minut take
care minutes while we doing that saw and
see if any super chats are Flo in at
least CE them up we can que them up
while we got that pop they're right
here let me
see oh I wanted to I forgot to show you
guys the thumbnail I made for that video
that's spent an hour just on the
thumbnail
man he thought he said yo I got to do
this um this uh something for his show
right and I'm like yeah he says it's
gonna take an hour like all right cool
he hits me up like four hours later
King yeah hold up hold actually since
he's gone CH uh chat I I I want you
guys' opinion all right be real how's
this thumbnail
look Xbox excus I like that yeah yeah I
like
that it's been a long time on that I
don't know why but I spent a long time
on that getting them s rankings I could
I couldn't get the the text to like pop
the way I wanted them to like the text
on the it always looked weird so I had
to like put the background multiple
different ways like look this ninja
squirrel basic I'm back sorry about that
no you good you good you good so what
you got what you got for your favorite
console of all time and why okay so uh I
will go with the modern
day I have to go with the switch only
hear me out switch switch hear me out um
because it is the most comfortable thing
for me that I've ever played with so uh
besides many of Twitter people haters uh
wives I mean not wives girlfriends wives
wives I was like bro what you
do a shot that that didn't come out
right
so so point is uh the controls on this
switch were awesome and phenomenal
so I have to go with switch got to go
with switch no doubt Lord G the in the
round easy easy of use easy ease of use
and uh many many of my favorite games
are are on that system still and uh even
though they're nickel and diming me but
uh so at least you're being honest at
least you're being
honest that that stuff is ridiculous at
this point they're just taking their
library from every console putting it on
one so yeah yeah yeah and and they're
going to continue right we we think that
the next console is probably going to be
backwards compatible of some nature and
if it isn't then uh well damn yeah and
then you buy it
again yeah now salute Lord gazley
tremendous game his we love hearing
about your journey I'm assuming um you
still hanging out you're rocking with
because you know it's more show left to
go but um brother I'm I'm not done
talking sassy honestly I didn't even
touch on like notice how notice how our
super chats haven't been wild today I
believe this has been you sir it's all
it's all good it's all good know
what you play my joystick nobody I I
think yo I think we found out who's who
and what's
what the identity has will not confirm
or there you go so look so let's get
these super chats if not I I can take
care the Paul what what you want do D
don't take oh W pause pause on that yeah
I definitely shouldn't be
taking weekly we you do this I just that
was wild that was wild this is weekly
you you fall into that pit
bro the poll results are in realize the
reason people are saying that all in our
chats CU you guys give so much energy to
this
[Laughter]
stuffing what would you like to address
s how's the chat right now let's address
the super chats first
I we we got lot we got a lot a little
bit n someone said yo [__] handling
poles
now let me see there we have a JD game
of $5 Super Chat Jeff is a bully and
Xbox shouldn't keep letting him and
others bully them wow Xbox should pick
up the little bully and show him the
floor on his head oh okay Jeff Key's a
bully now wow that's what we
doing Dad mod gaming $2 Super Chat happy
Sunday realm give a like for the Lords
ah salute dadm in the building salute we
got JD gabri again $5 Super Chat on fire
today Mike Ms and XBox doesn't have to
support Jeff besides he leaks every bit
of Xbox info he knows so I say no no ads
no trailers no announcements J
nothing so somebody's a little mythed
at at certain snubs I can
tell yeah
JD G Going H today in the
chat we got JD gamer again $20 Super
Chat Microsoft has never won in the
consumer Market they are to data driven
take the uh money hit Microsoft to get
GTA 6 as a timed exclusive or with
exclusive content plus marketing to gain
mind share because the consumer Market
is all
about I was going to say JD gamer is the
only person I've really seen in the chat
that has argued with people in the chat
with super chats like and won the
argument cuz he he got no problem
dropping that 20 to say more and the
other dude dropping five so he's
restricted 150
characters I I I I tend to agree like I
know the panel is probably not down but
I I think GTA 6 would just be a
ridiculous yes it it they will spend a
lot of money but wouldn't that just be a
shock to everybody's system because it's
not you got to understand
the way the industry same as we're going
to talk about you know how people feel
about these game awards Microsoft
Microsoft is not allowed to do that
other people are and I give them that
Microsoft Microsoft does that the the
backlash would be ridiculous and people
that the backlash would be ridiculous on
the other end of the of the of the fence
and that isn't true I Gotta Give point
though to your point hold on one second
uh sorry adct the here here's the thing
right that like okay fortnite for
instance was so big right that it forced
Sony to do a ton of things right even if
whatever they didn't want to it forced
them to do a ton of things
right uh Tomb Raider you're talking
about Tomb Raider I assume um is not
even a not even a scent as big as as as
as GTA right so don't you think that if
GTA 6 come in even if they whine and
compl and try to destroy everybody which
you know guess what they they can't um
don't you think it would be such a huge
perspective shift or even the only game
that can actually shift units towards an
Xbox console at that point I think I
think I think the gamers fraudery will
come through and they're like well we're
not going to not are are you sure
because I mean that game no I'm saying
I'm saying I think the fraudery come
through and whatever Soap Box you're
standing on is going to crumble under
your
feet get GTA 6 I do think that's one of
I do think that's one of the few games
that would generate a lot of like
hypeness into the brand yeah but I I I
don't think I think the pr they would
get hit and the money they would spend
would probably outweigh the amount of
conss they could potentially sell yeah
because it the amount of money that Xbox
would have to sell give them to to to
lock down a exclusivity or anything of
that
matter for considering their budgets
like1 to two billion dollar Microsoft
touching that like let's not forget that
we saw the numbers on how much they were
paying uh take two to have GTA 5 in
there um for whatever amount
every Millions like 12 million a month
or something like that but we can agree
but we can agree that that that spend we
hold on yes we can uh can we agree was
was Google like Google does this thing
with the browser right they're like
default browser in in in uh iPhones
right for they pay a ridiculous amount
per per
year as no it's isn't it isn't it Google
as default browser I don't know I don't
I don't use iPhones but I would think
it's
Safari Mac no no no so so for iPhones or
I guess somebody in chat will correct me
if I'm wrong but one of to have Google
as the default oh that's for Android
then yeah even Apple though even Apple
I'm pretty sure but anyways they P they
pay a ridiculous amount of money for
something right but it's worth it right
we can agree that it's worth it for them
to spend all that money for for to get
the recognition to get the clicks to get
the get everything it depends yeah we go
along with this but yeah it depends what
what the financials as far as plan for
the marketing I'm assuming versus the
actual does that translate to sales and
and you know the perception May
translate to sales but like people in
sorry to interrupt you co people in the
chat are saying who cares about a bunch
of people on Twitter it's not the
perception that I'm talking about the
perception I'm talking about is they're
trying to go out and buy all these these
uh these Publishers these companies and
they're gonna have to deal with the
trade companies again they're G have to
deal with the regulation companies again
and it's going to look really suspect yo
they just they just got the hottest game
and locked it down to their platform
like we'll see we'll see it's a good
discussion we got to move on it's a long
show yeah it's yeah it's four o00 yes JD
gamer $20 Super Chat panel starts panel
starts on imagine imagine a world where
he was like he was like two we just all
we have is two topics today it's nothing
anything
yet JD gamer $20 Super Chat padle
thoughts on this imagine a world where
Microsoft Xbox did what PlayStation was
trying to do and simply went out and
bought up every single third party AAA
game of worth releasing in the next five
years forcing PlayStation to rely only
on their first
party
interesting interesting it's not the way
they think but yeah sure those we got
and we got hary chany $5 Super Chat
Happy Thanksgiving Lords happy holidays
to everyone in the realm likewise to you
brother absolutely salute although I
think we will be we will be here next
week if I'm not mistaken
yeah yeah all right then we have JD
gamer $2 Super Chat you can't save
Kong he going die baby I I wonder where
he got that from yo I was watching that
movie again yesterday cuz I love
watching mov here
weion I love to see KH get beat up we we
going we going long until he wants to
until he want that's how always they
want to get their balls off yeah yeah
yeah but I forgot they had to use a
deflator to bring Kong
back how you forgot about that because I
just worried about the whole front end
of the movie when he was killing him but
I forgot sure you was worried about the
front end of the movie they actually
killed
Kong they needed a
defense messy back to you then we have
Cory Tidwell with a $100 Super Chat
thank you brother appreciate that BL
blessings Cory just showing my support
keep the content coming fellas thank you
brother appreciate appreciate you not
that I'm pocket watching Cory tiell all
right but but Cory man yo you hit addict
show up you hit $300 now I'm like yo
listen Cory he need to advance the line
n n Cory no no no no no no no I ain't
worried about
that Cory Cory Cory he like you know you
missed one miss the front line I was
like where going no no no no come on
stop that that's that's what it sounded
like I know no I'm just one to it sounds
like you trying to find a way to word it
cck oh I'm not if I could get a chance
to talk thank you I I want to say thank
you for your all your support yes all
right because seriously I mean we just
ask for eyes we ask for eyes on the
product that's it and sharing it out and
giving it to everybody else y' guys are
going above and beyond and I appreciate
every last one of you and you know for
from from a dollar just your time
but Cory um I I seen your your your
super support all the way through and I
just wanted to acknowledge you that's
all thank you so much salute and we got
JD gamer they bullying me over there in
my stream man yeah they definitely do
yeah J game on fire today $20 to CH
Microsoft needs to stop worrying about
backlash they're going to get that
negative treatment anyway so make use of
it and do what Sony was doing get GTA 6
exclusive because after you do this
about five AAA games it's just
no no JD listen and I want you to think
cost billions of dollars to secure that
down like that yeah Microsoft is at a
point right now where they're going to
steamroll them and if Grand Theft Auto
is on everything all you want to do is
try to pull people to your platform and
it's not just Grand Theft Auto going to
do it like what is going on now someone
in the chat said they they they mess me
so much because it's for character
development it's good for your soul ad
it's good to make you a man that's what
they try to do you got JD gamer again $2
Super Chat Kong is dead we're just
waiting for him to know it
okay that
part there we got Tori Cory T well again
$2 Super Chat let's just say I'm doing
very well myself good for you I
appreciate you have no idea how much it
helps y we are caught up finally top
number one no it's not we got oh no we
got we got we have to read something
else we're gonna find out Cory tinwell
is Elon
Musk you still got a poll question and P
questions oh that's right yeah it's a
lot of them so um yeah last week's poll
results to end the people have spoken
with the Mass Effect reveal from N7 day
how do you feel byw is handling the
buildup to the game the winner of the
three IOP poll at 44% of the vote was
the I don't care my face is tired from
all the waiting group they are messy
coming in at second place said 38% of
the vote was byw needs to focus on
releasing an actual good game and
Dragon's Age game first and in last
place at 16% of the vote was love all
the secrets law and respect of the
entire Mass Effect Universe to generate
hype group Lord solve people are tired
of waiting that is the consensus
I don't know I don't even know what to
get what we're getting from them I would
say focus on making Dragon Age great
forget don't even talk about Mass Effect
yet don't even tease it don't nothing
get Dragon Age out have people confident
in the product you put out even if it's
if it isn't what we expect from quote
unquote BioWare make a great game on
your own steam don't worry about the the
the legacy of BioWare make that game
great and people will come back
you think about Mass Effect don't worry
about that right now let's speed through
these questions it's it's a lot all
right so shout out to the patreon y'all
coming through shout to adct for holding
it down with the uh patreon questions
and um yeah shout out to user not found
she starts it off hope all is well Lords
in the chat got something on my mind
recently that I can't stop thinking
about and it's the continued investment
Xbox has been doing in Japan and how it
really could have taken the wind out of
Sony sale if you think about it right
now a lot of discussion among Xbox and
Playstation fans alike is what Sony's
2024 lineup apart from Concord Final
Fantasy 7 rebirth foam stars and some
remakes remasters of the remix director
cut hashtag sorry I had to say it well
imagine if XBox hadn't put the work in
especially with Sega to get those
Japanese games which were typically
PlayStation exclusive on Xbox and take
the bullets out of the checklist
Warriors gun cuz in reality we know
these dude's favorite timed exclusive is
Twitter play Persona 3 Lo personified
tactica Yakuza man who Ras Yakuza the
man who rases name in infinite wealth
just from the top of my head all could
have been PlayStation exclusive instead
these games are instantly not only
multiplats and negated from exclusivity
talk but actually associated with Xbox
because of Game Pass what are the Lord's
thoughts on this am I talking rubbish or
am I actually on to something regardless
hope everyone has an amazing Sunday
watching the greatest gaming podcast
salute salute so what do you think about
using not F man he said that because of
Xbox's work in Japan does that take some
of the thunder away from what used to be
previous exclusives and now potentially
coming on a game pass for example like a
Persona 5 tactica I guess and um reload
and stuff like that anybody can that's
that's a no-brainer the fact of the
matter is I told you Phil Dominus
Maximus really expensive won't stop
until he actually and I'm not going to
use the word conquers the Land of the
Rising Sun he merges with the Land of
the Rising Sun and makes sure that you
know at least these games are on the
Xbox platform and you guys get a chance
to experience these games and not be
envious looking across the street
because it's a big thing to launch stuff
and Game Pass day and date or to launch
stuff and Game Pass at some point in
time to give a broader um idea of how
the Eastern uh culture games are CU some
of the western culture and let's be real
the Microsoft platform is really Western
culture based uh now you you have the
ability to see what's going on over
there and Peaks your interest and then
the next games that come out you're
looking forward to it solve addict
thoughts the king
said he he said copy and paste some of
those some of those are probably you'll
see like like we saw with C of stars
that we it was it was Xbox and Game Pass
and then all of a sudden at the at the
back end oh same day day and date on ps+
right so they may may be a couple like
that that they wait on and they'll
announce maybe Xbox just you know
whatever had that upfront marketing
whatever the case may be some of them
will be on on uh ps+ day and date as
well not all of them know and I do think
as a testament to their work over there
sometimes you know in the past
PlayStation's been able to sort of rest
on its Laurels knowing that anything
from Japan is kind of associated with
them and Xbox has to work extra hard to
to even get that sort of Mind share so
now the fact that it's in Game Pass you
can't deny it now now it's like okay cuz
if it was no it was no game pass and it
was still day and day on both the Mind
share goes to PlayStation 100% no matter
what right Game Pass is the game changer
there so good on them no I agree I agree
the patreon what's off
said yeah look U I don't have too much
to add for this um but yeah I do think
that it definitely helps them so that um
you don't want the perception that these
big games are missing your platform so
that's where I'm at with that we got to
move on a ton um snail killer has uh one
for us um hello Lords let's first put
birthday cicks on chat for Lord Cognito
birthday a salute I want to bring an
idea to know how you all feel we all
know that Cod is on high demand and Xbox
will not stop the money maker from going
however what if to give a one extra year
to every Studio Xbox pays EA to make
Titan 43 exclusive once again since it
probably won't be made without Xbox
monies anyway and it would launch
exclusively on Xbox on the year Cod does
not come out let's say 3 to 4 years from
now I understand Phil does doesn't want
that but it's just an idea to give a
break to Cod Studios and since Titan 4
is not getting made anyway it would be
cool for it to come back again I
apologize to the person who has to read
this have a great Sunday so so putting a
card on the not a yearly schedule and
somehow getting exclusivity for Titan 43
between okay that's that's that's that's
real P sky that a happening that way but
I will say and it goes back to what I
said in the past you want to give these
games more time you kind you add another
team you add another team throw somebody
else jumping into the Double Dutch and
now all of a sudden each team has an
extra year to work on that game minimum
right um I just saw shout out to VGC
Infinity Ward expands again with a new
studio in Austin Texas oh when was this
yeah this was a couple of hours this was
about it said three hours at the time oh
wow they expanded Infinity yeah yeah so
it's been so it's another another Studio
obviously working on Call of Duty right
um so um this is what they're going to
do probably they're going to try to add
to the support and you know Pie in the
Sky maybe we get some of these teams
that have been known for other things
may maybe out of that rut and put teams
that just want to make Call of Duty on
Call of Duty um but yeah I think that's
what it is you have you have to add to
it in order to give them more time to
make each of these games a little bit
more special um so we'll see if that
happens we'll see obviously Infinity W
expanding kind of lends to that but the
EA thing is high in the sky if Titanfall
comes back that is on Vince sella and
Vince sella alone I believe facts S I
mean um addict to the kick as far as s
said I I don't I don't think it's
necessary um the fact that the matter is
Microsoft you really don't know how many
IPS that Microsoft has and the ability
to switch move and Pace different games
in every year Call of Duty doesn't need
Titanfall as a a bracer in between now
you know war zone is a constantly played
game that will be their year round the I
think the the campaign is is going to
take a different face you have updates
on the war zone the battle pass and all
that other stuff that's coming I think
every other year you will get a campaign
that's on Call of Duty and they can just
plug and play it and I've noticed some
stuff like when I put in three CU I was
playing three that you know two is there
and and and it's just a linkage so the
the the interface in the background will
change with the iterations of the new
campaign modes that can be available
without putting pressure on the studios
to deliver a AAA you know uh story
campaign they can just take time do that
every two years Titanfall is not
necessary you have Doom they have so
many games that they'll be putting in
between that that you won't be looking
forward just for Call of Duty campaign I
agree they have enough in-house Studios
right now to be able to make stuff and
and with all it's ridiculous yeah you
can again beef up
pause addition Studios to to help them
out and I'm Titan for don't get me wrong
I'm more for if Microsoft wants to help
them come out with typ type four but I
think that's a completely separate
entity that doesn't have anything to do
with their Call of Duty pipeline stuff
so that's just me yeah moving onz we
still got more Benjamin amaru um can we
just take a moment to appreciate that
putting Destiny 2 in the best community
support has to be the biggest troll of
these ceremonies either they're high as
a kite or they're trolling just right I
think we all had that get the F out of
here moment when we saw that salute
Lords and happy belated birthday to the
great man himself Lord Cog salute does
everyone agree that Destiny and the
community support was a bit out of
pocket it was it felt like there was
slim pickings out
there fill out the category or something
no it felt like there was pickings it's
just none that they were willing to the
Halo infinite could have been there SE
thieves could have been there grounded
could have been there adct do me a favor
uh Super Chat came in from nintend on
and he said he he thought he sent his
patreon question but he didn't hit send
he just sent it if you could just get
that to me or read that for me that'd be
great if you can I still got a few more
it's the fact that um destiny is owned
by Sony we're going to get a Sony
product in the regardless even if it's
not deservant of
you know and we already know that bung
isn't deserving of
anything bu that's right e bu I call
them
bun bunes right now is e messy messy
hustle I see you just want a quick mic
check before we move on yeah everything
should sound good on my oh
yeah that Marshal Ms I see you no doubt
right all right all right and we got all
right Stitch too from stitch stitch um
okay we are back at it again IGN gave a
paper weight eight out of 10 gave a gave
a I'm assuming this is the PlayStation
portal he's talking about portal giving
a a paper weight 8 out of 10 and the
steam deck 7 out of 10 I would like to
hear your thoughts on this especially s
who is a huge fan of the deck play PS
Cog this uh steam deck does everything
the switch does and more also if the
switch 2 does not have back compa it is
DOA so well it's not DOA so you're fine
so I mean again I I'm not going to
comment on the portal because I didn't
get it and I don't have an intention of
get some people say it's great I've seen
some videos of it chopping up so I guess
I guess it's dependent on it really is
dependent on your Network and and your
distance from it I heard people playing
it on 5G saying it's
great and I've heard the opposite as
well so again you know I knew this was
going to happen short of me having to
buy it and figure it out for myself I'm
not you know whatever it is not for me
if you have a use case for it and is
working for you fantastic good for you
it is not for me at this point um now
the deck the deck the the improvements
to the deck the OLED deck are something
that I would have jumped on if the rock
Aly did not exist facts I would have
100% jumped on it um The Rock Aly exists
and for me the power difference is where
I I I I'm gonna lean towards that um
this is a great like mid gen refresh
OLED kind of like the switch OLED too
but this they added more things battery
life power stuff like that um obviously
PC stuff power utilization is different
you know there's a lot of tweaking and
twerking it can be done to to get this
to run a little bit better TW twe twerky
yeah you know refresh rates are higher
and all that stuff all that stuff is
there right all that stuff is there
which makes it a great upgrade Beyond
just the OLED screen but for me raag
Ally exists yeah it really is again I'm
not going backwards in terms of power my
my steam deck has been in the case since
I got the rock but he did he wanted to
know specifically about IGN the riging
yeah giving it giv this joint a seven
and giv this joint a a seven on a whole
streaming device that is not even better
than the gcloud but go ahead yeah I mean
what what am i g to say different people
have different opinions I doubt very
much that they looked at those and be
like oh we're going to catch Flack for
there were two different people who did
it right so they don't they don't stop
and look at this stuff the way we we
know that fans are going to look at this
stuff and be like hey wait a minute this
doesn't make sense so I'm sure once
somebody pointed it out they were like
oh is we're gonna catch flame for this
um but they're right I guess I guess the
person who played that portal must have
a great use case for it and love it and
not necessarily care for the other thing
now what I will say is this um and I
don't I forgot how easy or difficult it
is to get you know especially for the
steam deck the steam deck is limited and
there very Linux oriented it steam it's
not like the rag that is straight up a
PC and you could do you could do this uh
whatam call it this remote play on the
rck very simply as opposed to jumping
through some hoops with the steam deck
right so I will say that so if you're
making that comparison I get that at the
end of the day again I'm sure they they
found they looked at this afterwards
like oh man we're gonna catch flag for
this but I don't think it was purposeful
do I again I haven't played the portal I
cannot say it's an eight or I cannot say
that it sucks so
yeah look I get it you know people are
upset I'm which the same reason as far
as Steam deck you know not I mean um
what you call it the uh portal not not
for me there's no use case scenario for
me that I want to do that so um but as
far as the um what you call OLED steam
like I'm in the same boat you know as a
Alli User it's just it's not more
powerful so it's nothing for me but for
people who stti in the ecosystem and you
get the OLED the beautiful screen you
know salute to you if especially if you
don't have any of the devices so salute
to that but uh yeah and I don't think
the switch is DOA even if it is back
pack Stitch even if it's not it's
Nintendo going to sell bro they going to
sell yeah who did the switch DOA that
was it part of that no he said it's
going to be DOA if it doesn't have back
compack I said even if it don't have
back compack they going to make you buy
it again and they make you buy it again
they going be fine I think there SM this
time around but it's going to have back
compact that's something that you dudes
don't have to worry about they already
see the value in the digital uh space
and it's going to be ridiculous and like
we said I think kids are running the
show a little bit more now so I think
the kids are understanding of what
what's more modern somewhat right two
more we got to get hustling Stitch again
one more question do remakes of
remakes should be part of Game of the
Year category or should they have their
own category I think a separate category
is needed for those games I agree I
don't feel any remake should be part of
the game and yeah I've always standing
up to me that's remixing a record that
exists already just cuz you put a little
extra beat you know what I'm saying you
put you did what the the little the the
the Dre joint yo turn the treble up
right there turn
up I go back I go back the produc say
that's how Dr J produce your
J I go back to that ff7 though like ff7
is remake is like a different game man
like that's the only one you could kind
of make a small argument that's a remake
and to me I still would even put it in
there you know what I mean but okay y
thoughts I know I'm very strong opinion
it on this so no no I'm just surprised
by that one specifically because it is
such a departure from the it is I mean
if anything you can make argum for is
that but I still always feel if there's
Source material and then you traced
around it I'm you you you you just stole
his lines and in I you I you if there
are enough games in any given year which
I coincidentally this year there were
plenty of games to make its own category
right ex yeah sure sure
100% just give it to Sony trophy because
you
know all they do is remas remake so I
mean just give them cuz now yall see how
y can make sure that they have a trophy
every year give it to them just
automatically get about to get Elliot
Abby in 4k baby isn't it in 4k Now isn't
it yeah can't you just go now you could
go over there now for the same price and
just put it in and don't it just upgrade
now like anyway I'm because it's 10
bucks but I want that PC he said get him
kid get him I'm just saying I'm just
saying it's a bambooo tax I'm just
saying still there remix adct did leave
yeah I'm here yeah remakes your thoughts
I think the only exception is Resident
Evil
2 and Final Fantasy like anything else
you because Final Fantasy they're
they're capping off of the the
excitement of Final Fantasy 7 but it's
not the same game so to me you to me you
have to change something drastic and
there has been something drastic changed
now when it comes to Resident Evil 2 the
only reason I'm making that an outliner
is because I felt like that is one of
the original things that set off people
will buy these old games but you got to
make them good you got to make them new
and good what happened King now I just
so sick of tired these dudes talking
about Final Fantasy is a completely
different game no it's not yo like yo
you got Cloud you got all the same
people all the same people all the same
places all the same I don't care if you
told the story differently because you
put they instead of the I don't care
what you did and and I don't I don't
care if you you you you say you know
what let's turn let's tell the story a
little bit differently on how sephar off
came around the corner I don't care
about that the fact of the matter is
funny is the ignorance in this
conversation you clearly don't know
anything you're talking I don't know I
don't know he did not play that game
that's what I do know is when it show up
on Xbox I I play it cuz I don't care but
um the pro the problem is zro came
around the the problem is you guys know
I C hey
guys BR say hey guys yo you Wilding for
that one the problem
is y'all y y confusing what me and K
saying y'all talk okay it's a remake y
remake made it right because they sat
back and said yo how can we tell this
story differently but it's still the
same thing because if it wasn't the same
thing it wouldn't be Final Fantasy 7
remake listen in my mind the game the
game industry is so derivative of itself
anyway that I mean we've seen this type
of story 10 times over someplace else so
it's like to me let me let let me say
someone that has
beaten the the story isn't the same
thing King the
story different it's controversial how
far they're Devi they all right so so
let let me get this let me let me ask
these questions let me ask this question
yes yes is cloud part of the resistance
still is cloud part of the resistance
still Soldier yes okay so okay Cloud was
never
part
mer like you know final so no no no I I
played it before you I was on before you
I put in all I put in all those seven
discs before
you finished the game okay hold hold
real quick real quick how in Final
Fantasy 7 here we I finished it I don't
know I know I pay you don't know howan
up
this you don't know I know I was theread
dating day one and you wasn't were
you there was listen clearly clearly CLE
you was still in your infancy when I was
playing it here we go oh we got
with he he wanted beef measuring
finished yeah no my beef we gonna keep
measuring the beef a lot of beef
measuring the problem is the problem is
I'm just saying adct if it was
completely different like you're saying
right it's a completely different game
it would not be final fantasy7 remake
there was a reason he named It remake he
wanted to throw people off he literally
said it in people he wanted people to
buy it okay because if it was something
different they would try something
different he wanted to capitalize on
your Nostalgia and then when you play
the game you say oh it's a little bit
different here that's about it but no
I'm believe yall guys until it gets a
game pass anyway have have have both of
y'all got it off now
y I'm not going to argue with a
wall I told you when I walk in the room
he just all right we going move on we
going move on okay cool thank you beef
the beef off has concluded so dip beef
wow
dip pause dip down is the last one um no
actually you got the Donald Taco one
addict after this cuz I didn't I didn't
pull it up yet yeah yeah I got all right
cool so let's dip down and you take care
that one all right you can rest easy as
the world is safe for now you know he
always pits us against each other Dragon
the dragon it's always the Dragon Save
the World do something much love and
respect for always putting up with my
ridiculous question
love all the shows uhoh this one serious
though Tekken roster versus Street
Fighter roster who wins and we have to
agree we are never going to agree cuz sa
is here so let's just let's just say we
going to die right cuz s is a street
fighter man he gonna pick we what you
you gonna go with Kuma that's right s
that's right you doing doing evil rayu
uh listen I'm going you say what you say
is there like legit like devils and
stuff in Tekken we got we got the we got
oh yeah we got I'm going Street Fighter
oh got B yo I'm be honest with you i'
got to go Street
Fighter God what no y yo zo I'mma be
real with you like all the everybody on
that
Rost Canon Ryu gonna run wholesale
through all of them pretty
much we not doing what you got whatever
you guys
say I don't even know come on like is
there anything is there is there devil
type of people in Street F
Akuma anduma already fought if we play
Tekken 7 they fought to a stand still I
Ain see no he came through and just
bodied every that was a special match
they they and we had and we have a evil
rayu this is essentially a demon too
yeah we got we got devil J we got devil
not to cut you off S you have a violent
Ken as well violent K just cuz they said
aggressive Steve I'm supposed to be
scared just cuz they threw a name on
somebody in front aggravated psychop
power goton you got oh we dying today we
dying we dying n Co you got come on Co
bro they Fu they had Co you just the
only ho out
here I agree I agree
I'm officially I'm officially I'm
officially siding with solving King L it
is not taking anything away Ain nobody
get thrown in a volcano and live out on
your side that's a lie a nobody who got
thrown in a volcano over there who got
thrown in the Volcan the street Rost Li
that's a lie that's a lie listen listen
listen let's let's just stop we going we
just going to die no let
not nevere to this non I know I know I
know it's the problem y'all guys don't
get it he knows he knows in his heart
what it is but he's saying right now I
don't
know I don't know about violent Canon
aggressive Steve I don't know about none
of that so we going to move on we going
to move on WE a't G to take away from
Tekken being real violet
aggressive you a hear about Violet Ken
aggressive the roster on Street Fighter
is vastly more and it has way more
destructive people there what do they do
though
like I'm not hearing what they did like
no one got thrown in a volcano yet at
the end of the day I think has a lot of
strong I think they have a lot of strong
characters but Street Fighter has more
characters that can be classified as
having like superum strength we got's we
got to get the the TV show The adct do
they rate the powers we going to do that
anyway we going to move on we going
pretty sure if you look they've already
done that and we have we got to do that
so right we going to move on we going to
move on we going to do that on our next
battle thing we go
so since I know Cog wasn't allowed to be
in this topic I want to pull up with Ann
exclusive Nintendo news
network Nintendo was is so op that bad
Namco is building two Studios to work
exclusively on first-party Nintendo
games Nintendo has
essentially uh essentially acquire two
Studios without lifting a finger and
mostly if not entirely funded by big AAA
third party Publishers as far as I know
this is unheard of in the industry now
that I'm done bragging and how great the
number one publisher in console
manufacturer Nintendo is if Xbox and
Playstation W to enter a similar
agreement which third- party publisher
would you be would best fit both of them
um I'm saying capc for Sony and uh Sega
for
for um for Xbox
soft I agree you took mine yeah those
are pretty good I I would say popey
biscuits for Sony and um everything for
Microsoft for the
win yeah get him
King get him King G just G be yelling at
from the side the whole
podcast oh my God so are we good
everybody's good yeah all right first
topic of the show so quick so to to we
so we died we died we died I never agree
with you Psychopaths my goodness so so
so for the record Akuma has leveled the
mountain yeah f f Way did that to te
five but y'all don't play I understand I
understand y don't play Let's
go anyway hold get these couple super
chats real quick uh JD gamer $2 Super
Chat I love Kong but he got his tail
whipped um then we got Lao shimazaki
with the 500 yen Super Chat Xbox needs
to expand Game Pass to China and other
regions that currently don't have it all
my friends here in Japan have Game Pass
right now very nice salute then we got
Nintendo taku $5 Super Chat I thought I
sent my Pat okay we got this already
brother we got you then we got the
Rapture press Network I like that sounds
very very Messiah like
super here we go you don't need to have
GTA 6 exclusive just get it two weeks
early and Game Pass for three months
yeah that's true it's still going to
cost hundreds of millions of dollarss JD
gber
$2 Kong is laying in the corner
twitching half dead Shout Out
J that's how we doing we caught up You
Bing a little bit topic one yeah top
topic one yeah topic one I was gonna say
I'm Bing no now now you're back I I'm
Bing you said he was close I was close
no you good you good question do y I
mean we don't have have to do Crown your
Lord this week no we have to yeah we got
to we have to no CU next okay I'm just
saying okay got you okay some cooking
yeah okay got you oh I see what you say
you want you want to save it for okay I
see what you said okay no no what I'm
saying is that we still have time it's
not the show is until like the 7th of
December so we still have that is true
it's up to y'all if y'all want to call
it that way if we we going too long yeah
cuz CR your lord is a crazy long segment
we could we could push CR your lord back
a week if you want
yeah we can do that that works all right
cool we'll do that we'll do that cuz
that makes sense yeah cuz cry your Lord
will take up a straight up hour and
bye cry your Lord will return next week
all right so look this is addict's topic
I don't know if he wants me to set him
up with the all the Persona news or you
got it adct or how you want me you to
handle uh I only picked this topic so we
can jab little Jabs at solve all right
wait a minute but what happened to Xbox
tax and Game Awards what happen no we we
still do that we'll still do that okay
okay yeah we'll still do that all right
so um and that's when I give away the
next game cuz we got a game to give away
yeah so we do the Persona I I'll set it
up so um yeah Persona 6 s could be
breaking a 30-year tradition uh it
released as a multiplatform game
signaling a departure from the series
longstanding launch exclusivity to
PlayStation sega's response during
investor report suggest that releasing
Persona 6 on multiple platforms
simultaneously could lead to increased
sales and potentially reach the
Milestone of selling 5 million copies in
the first year
Atlas has been expanding its
relationship with Xbox and Nintendo
making it likely that Persona 6 will be
available on multiple platforms upon
release although an official
confirmation is still pending so they
actually spoke to um the represent this
call and they just said yeah we believe
that it would be possible for a major
Persona title such as a numbered release
to sell 5 million copies in its first
year by releasing it on multiple
platforms and simultaneously worldwide
from day one and uh I believe I'm trying
to get uh that is indicated by sees
heroi atami and I cannot pronounce this
kichi fukasawa that's the best I would
try so um this was during a quarterly
investor report so that was the first
bit of news um second bit of news
obviously his addict's been playing
Persona tactica and thoughts on that so
I guess we'll talk about that and then
we'll get into Mar RPG and some other
stuff but let's start off with the first
two bits of news this is your topic
addict yeah so you know I kind of I kind
of knew that this would happen as long
as PlayStation didn't secure it years
ago like after Persona 5 what I was told
is it was like that aren't normally made
years in advance usually made closer
towards the uh the game being finished
development unless it's like certain
things like they're funding the entirety
of the game like if Sony was funding
Persona 6 then most likely you wouldn't
see that but especially this you know
relationship that Microsoft has
established with Sega it I kind of
figured this would happen as long as
PlayStation didn't lock it down uh years
ago and it's looking like that happened
I mean look what's crazy is like if
Persona 6 comes out if if Xbox is able
to secure that game pass day and date
like they've got with all the Persona
games and all the yakaza games like you
know how big that would be because to me
Microsoft they're never going to tr get
into that area unless they have stuff
that's only on their platform uh the the
next best thing is to have Game Pass
games like like something like you know
Persona 6 and obviously when it comes to
something like that are they going to
get Persona 6 in Game Pass probably not
but it would be a really good look if
they did that you know apparently
finally Mist Walker is making something
that's not a mobile game so it's like
what what are they doing with that and
you know I see I see a lot of movement I
do I see you know it's just like um you
know can't I can't remember which one of
you said you know you look at what's
going on it was a patreon question
what's going on with it used to be we
didn't get no personas no yakas yeah
that's a fact and and these were a lot
of games every year that came out
especially how consistent they can get
these games out so it's just like look
when you look at these and you look at
the the landscape of things don't be
surprised when you see Persona 6p
popping up on that platform don't be
surprised and you know is it going to
sell was better than like the switch of
PlayStation obviously not but who be
acted like three people buy it on the
Xbox that's not the case like U but it'
be interesting to see if they if they
get a a Game Pass back you know I I
would I would be
very like like amazed that they were
able to convince Sega like yo you know
and if there was something they were
holding off with for a bigger one it
would be Persona 6 all f enough let
start with our esteemed guest Lord games
Lee um let's start just with the Persona
potential news of it being multiplat how
do you take that news that
information I'm going to be really
simple with it because I don't want to
take time time time
um Square enx needs to take note and I
think they will show up I think they've
already I think they will take not they
need to take not okay and you have to
teach the play bases that you will show
up on platforms you want to sell on and
that's that's the whole point if you
want to sell more copies and you want
those copies to be sold on xbo box where
previously they don't sell or whatever
like adct said they do sell but not to
assert like millions and millions and
millions if you want to teach them to
buy your stuff you have to be there you
have to be loyal consistently it's not
just being there you have to be there
consistently you know you can't you
can't skip out on three sequels and they
expect me to buy a prequel like yeah
that's that's exactly that's my thought
that's exactly what you have to do you
have to teach your your fan bases uh
where you're going to be and you have to
stay there stay so so we got to groom
them properly yes yes
wow moving on that's it that's that's my
thing fair enough Lord games the Lord
hustle hustle and motivate man just the
Persona news or potential multiplatform
at launch what are your thoughts on
these rumors potentially that could
happen uh it's much needed um I'm
surprised they haven't done that a lot
sooner but if the demand on Xbox in
particular if the demand is there then
you know throw those games on there I
think they um because they re-released
the three four and five the variance of
3 four and five on a in Game Pass and
maybe they was just doing that just as
like a quick test to be like all right
well let's see how many people really
want these and it look like those
numbers if this is true this room is
true it look like everything hit the way
that should have hit and if that's the
case then and and the good thing also
when so you saying said Xbox hit it
right PA oh man the good thing the good
thing hustle is when you put when you
put said godamn it yes the good the good
thing hustle is when you put like these
games on game pass and you give you know
all these millions of people that are
subscribed to Game Pass access to
Persona five four and eventually three
you know when Persona 6 comes out
there's a huge possibility that you have
you know got a lot more sellers because
you made the entry so low to make it
where anyone could walk in that that you
know put 15 $20 into into the service
for a couple months now now they might
actually buy your $60 $70 game when they
didn't even know your franchise existed
before
then fair enough Lord Sovereign my
brother just see do now he's your
brother but he couldn't side with you in
the we we're over
that we're over that we're dead anyway
what does it matter you know you know
cuz I remember you know there's certain
you know are you going to been the knee
now or later you know on the line I was
told this happen oh so we holding on
okay I see no we hold I Lear I learn
from the best you learn from King David
you learn from King David until until
it's official nowhere nowhere in this
press release did it say anything about
Xbox I mean I mean he did say multiple
platforms yeah aka the next Nintendo
platform in the PC
there this what we doing this what we
doing K not like this say this and I
will say this and I agree with hustle
100% all y'all frauds that talk about
they don't have Japanese games y'all
better play these games y' better have
played Royale when it was there y'all
better be playing tactica now and you
better play reload when it comes out
facts and because I I I do think this
obviously if they making it already
they're making they're not going to
start making Xbox version now right
whatever if it's a done deal is is done
already they just not saying I I was
told by somebody in the know most AAA
developers can have a port for Xbox in
six
months really okay so maybe so maybe it
could happen
I just I just want to know how how I'm
receiving these need yo he said
really means to me is I think his exact
words was 6 to n months so there was a
little wiggle room they putting it out
early before it so so let let's be clear
about this also about the the terms of
this the terms if it's one day later oh
oh this what we doing okay okay fine
fine that's what it was F he no we go
hold up that that was in the original
fine just I just want to clarify that
good I I take it I need these needes I I
want to
see
Yo imagine if if some bers gay three
energy happened here where then he wins
then he wins then he wins then he wins
I'm taking it all away they told I wait
till it's my turn but what to
hear we we messed up the we messed up
the time zone stuff I'm sorry lat okay
this what we doing okay Finish y finish
no again like I said in the past he he
learned from me he learned from the best
he learned from the best you better
watch out he gonna go on Playstation
switch to New Zealand and say I'm
play so uh but like I said in the past
if if this happens yes it needs to
happen um yeah it needs to happen man
that persona's gotten so big over the
years especially with five and it it got
to happen so um if it doesn't I I just
I'm G be honest I'm a Snicker and laugh
if there is some sort of play you know
because it's like really because it goes
to the point like why would Jim when he
was there not try to secure this you you
you know
howed you know how there's like a good
chance that I really feel like you
you're gonna lose this because Atlas
announced our brand new IP on Xbox
stage and that when I saw that I but
it's not Persona when I saw that when I
saw that when I saw that I pretty much
talk to my
like you can have you can have you can
have the reantaso whatever
weio that's the side joint that's the
side joint that's the side joint okay
okay that's what we doing all right now
this is good this is good to hear uh
holding on I respect it as you should as
you you learn from the best Lord kid
your thoughts on the Persona series
potentially being multiplat I already
know that's going to happen like oh boy
had a chance feeling was out there in
the landed Rising Sun they like yo you
see all the gays running around gay pass
hey little Sega hey little Sega how you
doing what's your name little Sega I'm
Pana oh that's so nice that you here
yeah and tactics we just launched inside
Game Pass we like you here oh okay so is
your big brother coming yeah he's going
to be born soon and he's going to be six
and he's coming here and we're going to
have so much fun did you say he's going
to be bored
soon he said he's going to be bor soon
and he sex and he's going to be six he's
he's the he's the sixth one of us and
and he's gonna show up and he's goingon
to love it to start Game Pass well what
about Sony we really don't like it there
it's cold it's
C we we like it
we like here where it's warm and fun and
everybody here interacts for real they
got money here they keep the lights
on all right all right little Sega go
have fun and don't worry it'll be more
of us we heard square is coming too
because they couldn't keep the lights on
over there because final fasy 16 lost
almost two billion for hanging out with
those guys a y t said what is this
stranger danger energy yeah very
stranger danger energy well well go
along little Sega have fun thank
you I keep it like but yeah you got to
walk the other direction yeah definitely
direction for sure I mean shout out to
the uh the quarterly theone calling the
cops what's the matter y'all don't like
little
Sega that's out of pocket hey little
Sega that's out of F jum this was fun
news to come across and uh yeah I guess
I just remember I was told King I was
told so many things I was told that the
shout out to ACG here remotely look at
the shine on his face right now yes bro
I sat here and I watched ACG and soft
jump me and tell me about how the Sega
deal was only about Cloud I said okay
cool cool F and then I wish I wish ACG
was here I wish ACG was here too oh
nothing about games y'all this is why y
counting your chickens too early oh I'm
counting I'm popping bottles
early this is happen y' so how extra are
you going to be if he's wrong still oh
let him I I'll take all the stipulations
he throws at me
so so for me I'm just sitting there I'm
like okay cool and we saw the all jokes
time we did see the relationship
continue to improve but the the the
strongest point that s and his brother
kaibu you too you too I remember you and
um they told me they said no Co because
Atlas run operates to its own beat they
do their own thing so then as we
continue to see but at the end of the
day they're still owned by Sega shout
out to the shout out to the queen
sarahan shout out to Phil Max you know
what Sarah heard you was like I got you
I just see those beautiful trips to
Japan and TGs and every year imagine
those conversations yeah I got this
podcast I listen to his name's coito she
did it for me she did the queen did it
for me the queen did it shout shout out
to Queen Mother
Sarah she did it for the tribe and uh
yeah I just see every year it just seems
to get a little bit better then you see
Persona 5 tactica new IP release you
know which we'll talk about and then
obviously the new IP that I forgot the
wild name that it has that it's coming I
thought that was big but look re
fantasio fantasio right but they hear
the all jokes out but they hear the
investors talking about yo this I they
should rename it to the beginning of the
end for Sal to hear them talking about
how much money they could sell they
would have sell 5 million this is giv
off a lot of Square Enix energy and to
me it's like yo the real the reality of
this they cannot miss the Xbox and the
Nintendo platforms it it's just too much
money on the table and these exclusive
deals are not netting the value that
they once had and this is historic cuz
to Sol's point and I understand why they
standing on the Square is because this
is a relationship almost nearly 30 years
P Persona 1 was what like 94 995 like
it's been a long time that these games
have historically had that relationship
but I do think it's about the money it's
about the business aspect and we we'll
see so I'm just gonna I'm just going to
be patient just going to be patient and
wait for those kns S doesn't lose often
y'all so I have to save this if it does
happen the way I anticipate it I just
can't wait so we will see when it goes
down what part of me was she's I could
like take a time machine and just see
the reaction to both ways like like I
want I want C to win not because Cog
will win the bet but because I want
Persona 6 on Xbox so so ironically right
now our roads are in the same direction
oh yeah we're definitely allow to go
this one the new IP is metaphor and it's
metaphor colon ref fantastic fantastic
whatever but abolute it it is always
about the money I agree asop par King
really quick because we got all hustle
in the building and I do want to get
side uh diversion as far as a game that
he's always preached about he's always
been in the realm he's
I'm telling y'all about this Mario RPG
you know the week is here one of his
favorite games you know what I'm saying
we were talking to him as far as his top
of all time oh attic out here
cooking attic out here cooking with it
playing right now no doubt so uh yeah
man let's get it let's get it so uh Lord
Hustle Man tell us about this Mario RPG
now is back out in these streets uh 27
years later if I did that math right in
my wow this game originally came out
1995 in Japan and in '96 over here where
we all reside in the states literally my
first RPG I want to before I even get
into it if you have a child or if you
never played a jrpg before and you like
Mario you start with this one there's a
reason why Gino and mow are such revered
characters and everybody wanted them in
Smash um I'm almost called you Alex adct
pardon me you about to find out today oh
you you saying all white people look
Alik
yo we not we not doing this we not he
said yo Alex Alex we not doing this he
said we not doing this right now we
definitely not doing that
um look I would say if you if you start
if you if you have a child and in all
servic if you do have a child um start
with this one okay start with this one
if you've never played the jrpg and you
you like Mario really start with this
one um I've never played this game yeah
oh I think I think you'll enjoy it I'm
going to finish Persona tactics and then
I'm putting all my attention on that
game unfortun unfortunately my my uh my
switch Pro Controller got stolen I don't
know what happened to it I've had it for
like four years but like I was sitting
there because I don't I don't touch my
switch all the time but what but I so I
went to play it for I I remember I had
it for tears of the
Kingdom but I don't remember where it
was when I went to play Mario wonder and
I looked everywhere I tore everything
apart so I've been playing on like the
little mini thing
like somebody's sketch came in and took
your Pro Controller oh man that's sketch
and y'all need to give it back because
that's the only way to play that switch
he's you got him out here playing with
those little ner what gley doing what
gley doing what you doing gley oh here
you go there go got the pro there you go
I see it I see it continue yeah no um
start with this um ad try to get a Pro
Controller because some parts in this
game you haven't encountered them yet
some parts are platform based cuz it's
it's want to buy another Pro Controller
just just for one game I just feel like
we're so close to the switch to I'm
might as well just wait for that sucker
don't worry it'll link over to it yeah
I'm like if it's Bluetooth it'll
probably work anyway but I I'll say
there are some platform games atct this
game is extremely easy I'm literally
this game came out Friday and I think I
got like 15 was in it some I got it on
my screen I'm just looking at it now
there're there's something in the game
called frog coins I'm not going to tell
you they significance but they make them
extremely do you get them for killing
frogs no no you you get them for you
actually get them for killing uh all the
enemies it's like a you're you're run
into certain encounters where um unlike
the OG version in this version you'll
run into certain encounters with like
special enemies a special enemy in this
case let's just use an example it can be
a gomba the SCBA just may have like 300
health as opposed to like the 30 it
normally has um the reward at the end of
that is a is a frog coin you don't have
to farm frog coins anymore that was like
one of the things that kind of like used
to like get me as a kid cuz like I used
to do it cuz I had the time to do it but
there's a lot a lot of quality of life
improvements got one of the one of the
improvements off rip is that they got a
auto saave feature oh okay Auto saate
feature and that game never had that
back in the day so just Auto saate
probably didn't exist back yeah it
didn't it didn't it catch it didn't um
finally right so they not only do they
have a um auto save feature they like
completely rehaul like the graphics as
y'all can tell and not only that yeah
they they changed some of the dialogue
they changed some of the item names they
changed they've changed a lot like
there's certain like like the bosses and
sub bosses they have like cut SC addict
I'm not sure where you are exactly but
the first sub boss you fight um cuz it
look like you were in the very beginning
I fought two things with hammers oh you
fought the hammer Brothers already okay
cool I wasn't sure if you was there yet
they had their own little mini cut scene
all the bosses have their own mini cut
scenes all of the Easter eggs from what
I can tell they're fully intact but um
there's something off about this game
and I do want to talk about
that something off yeah yeah it's the
the time hits the time hits in this game
I don't know if it's the input leg for
my I'm using a monitor so it can't be
that but um there's a game called I
believe it's called SE of stars
yes so see of stars actually from what I
understand I never played it but from
what people are telling me it's like yo
that they do Town hits better than the
originat really oh they formula yeah
they do yeah and what what's funny is
like C A stars like they and when you
get used to it because I'm still getting
I'm still getting used to the the Mario
one but C stars like it it it was like a
rhythm at at one point like especially
when you fight people that hit you like
eight or nine times you got to block
eight or nine hits that's that's
Boomerang thing is so good the boomerang
thing you do the combo Boomerang where
you shoot a fire at ice what water what
yeah that's that's my game that's my
game of the year so I always find like
those small subtle things all I found
that hilarious when I first tried it
because there was somebody streaming
this game and I'm not GNA say who
because I don't want to like feel like
I'm throwing shade at him he's a great
he he he played like a grade a bum i i a
DN why you got to talk about BG like
that oh man hold on you know well ad you
know BG is a fan of this game oh was it
really BG no no it wasn't trying to call
my man out like that shout BG don't be
doing that it's not BG it's not son he
know what he doing I bring um I bring
that up because there's a difficulty in
this game normal which is super easy and
then um they have a lower difficulty
called Breezy so like if you really have
like a three
Breezy you Breeze past easy baby if you
got if you got like a three-year-old or
something I mean like like young Breezy
let's go now this game is this game is
entirely too easy this isn't it's called
Mario RPG remake and it has a lot of RPG
elements but like this isn't like
Persona 5 this got it I'm almost at the
end of I'm at I don't want to say cuz
adct it's your first time playing I'm
let's put it this way I'm like if I
really play it right I'm like 30 minutes
away from the last boss wow see put like
and that's and that's not that's because
I'm a a Grizzle veteran like I already
know what I'm doing all my characters
all my characters is maxed out at the
max level which I'm not going to say
which I'm not cuz I add it because I'm
not gonna say what the the Mach level is
but The Mach level leveling ain't even
high and then like with you you can
equip a certain accessory with the frog
coins because fra coins I can say
they'll buy you certain items these frog
coins wasn't in the old one they were
but they just more EAS you had to you
had to
grind okay so that's what makes it okay
I got you yeah so you had to really
grind and get if they upgraded they up
it's a quality of life improvements
addict you'll find a I can tell you
you'll find a signal ring for Hidden
Treasures in the game but later on in
the game they make finding Hidden
Treasures a whole lot easier like toward
the end of the game and I was like do
they really made this super easy for
everybody
like it's it's extremely versatile and
I'm not sure who cuz it wasn't Square
who made this game it was it's another
company that started with an A and I
cannot pronounce it for the life let me
look it up
yeah
Mario awesome like when I when I tell
you that this game is still in line for
my uh my
Nintendo I don't a r t e p i a z z a
solve I me you going to have to put that
in the chat yeah you got to put that in
the chat you got to put that hustle
really quick uh you said it's a really
good game yes and you said it got a
little bit easier got a lot of bit easy
but it's still still good game it's
still good absolutely oh I see what
you're doing don't let the I see what
you doing see doing I see what you doing
yeah thank you thank you thank you I'm
not gonna say it so I don't piss off the
Dark Souls people I
mean
Piaza hey look look look look here man I
live to make those Souls people upset
I love it yeah shout out to them try
hard Gamers man they they got it yeah
try hard Gamers got it they got it hey
my
God anyway um no it's um it's it's
extremely fun it has a lot of and I was
referring to Blan earlier because he has
a phrase he said it's ooing with charm
he's right it it literally has a lot of
charming a lot of funny moments in it um
a lot of things remained untouched for
the most part like I said they added
things here and there um oh I'm not I'm
not going to get into it I'm not going
to spoil it apparently at toward the end
of the game they had postgame content
and I think that's like the Boss Rush
which that was they they announced that
already so gotta somebody I'm not gonna
say who but I follow because like I
looked up Mario RPG and I followed this
one guy he had like aund some other
subscribers he didn't outright spoil one
of the sub bosses but I knew it was a
sub boss but I didn't know how that boss
looked but he kind of spoiled it in his
title he spoiled it in his title alone I
was like
are you sure we're not talking about BG
cuz he
does BG be flag he'll throw it in the
thumbnail
like on my man crazy I got to relax no
no I'm I'm kidding of they slaying him
they turn into the BG topic for some
reason didn't that was you blame
[Laughter]
adic I'm the monster everyone needs but
doesn't want tell them about it tell him
the end of the game um they they do have
a Boss Rush mode I'mma say this I'mma
say this if you like me cuz I I maxed
out everybody basically toward the end
of the game but I got one of the
accessories and I maxed out Mario a lot
sooner than I normally would have
because I just enjoyed playing the game
that much and it didn't take it didn't
take long at all like first and foremost
it didn't take long at all another
quality of life feature addict you'll
see it after every battle that you have
it'll tell you how many more points you
have to reach the next level so it they
don't have a status they don't have the
status option anymore in the option menu
in fact they they changed the options
menu too um it took a little while for
me to get used to because I still like
regularly play like the OG version um
they got different what's up um I never
played this but just out of curiosity do
they have any bosses in the game that's
like stronger than the last boss like
someone really powerful oh okay I love
that I love that stuff oh my God yeah
yeah bro all right we got the co oh my
God yes yes yes and oh I'm not going to
say yeah they do they do um if you need
help on how to get to that boss I will I
can just got for the Chanel what we got
um working on no no no I I should put
that out I as much as you bloting about
this game I would love to coincidentally
I have a you know it's funny you bring
that up I have a how-to video on uh how
to beat a certain uh cuz Yoshi's in the
game I'll just say that yeah you oh I
got to be careful there's a on my
channel on how to I'll just say help him
and his friends in a certain way I got
that video on my Chanel so no more you
telling too much we want you yeah I won
I won't no
more I won't it's it's one of those
games to where like I thought it was
going to be cuz I'm I'm always one of
those guys like the Nostalgia kick is
there I got a whole Channel based around
Nostalgia now for shout out to shout out
to Retro shout out to all my retro heads
from from retro rebound to you know
salute oh yeah the Mad in the crew
salute for sure yeah he he he lit um
contration and um a
Omega first place let guys and girl like
I mean that I thought I was going to be
disappointed I I legit thought I was
going to be disappointed in playing this
game no sir no sir so we got official to
co side hustle gives it to co hey if you
don't own to If You Don't Own no other
switch game or no other RPG and you like
Mario you pick that up matter of fact if
yall this is a good RPG in general no
it's not like persona it's not like
Persona no but it's do matter as long as
it's good and it's all right no I
appreciate that brother this this is
this is huge and as one last thing cuz
it's a person for me that hasn't played
really that game ever that was the one
you too yeah that was the one that I
would say this would get me to play a
Mario game remix you kind of thing King
is ridiculous he posted something on
Twitter there will be a time in the
upcoming future where Xbox will sweep
every award category because they will
own
everything we will get to that topic cuz
clearly y want to talk about that top
who did that art who did that art
king I don't know I just stole
it anyway I I don't know who to give
credit to but iing cuz we got to move
y'all this we got we got topics two
quick things addict really quick if the
way that I um have my font look better
on my thumbnails I use glossy and from
my background picture and then I just do
drop Shadows um for my font number one
that'll help you with that number two c
what's up what's up you playing Yakuza
right now right Dragon yeah like a
dragon racing
in I'mma tell you this if you're a fan
of you should be a fan of Mario I think
you should get this game a try this game
is not long this game ain't even that
long I think you're going to fall in
love with the humor cuz I hear you I
listen to all the podcast I listen to
the final Duke and I be hearing the
slanderous
things I was outside I was outside I was
very slanderous very disrespectful I
know and I know I I know I know I know
they did you know oh I'm not going to
make that joke because this ain't my
platform this what I will say this what
I will say talk to me get give that game
a spin and I think your favorite
character is gonna be the third
character that you me I don't want to
say it for for the second I think that
there's a reason why a lot of people are
climbing ring for that character to be
super smash
BRS okay I'm telling you now he he that
Lit it's that real no that's what's up
is there anything else that y'all maybe
that y'all want to know without me I'm
not gonna spoil nothing obviously oh
wait you can hold over 999 coins in this
in the OG version you couldn't I'm up to
like what's that
4,439
coins yeah so it's easy it's always easy
to get money in this Mario no hustle I
appreciate you brother cuz um yeah this
is the one that I again I had my eye on
you know typical classic J RPG I like to
see Mario in that type of setting I know
they usually in a lot of different
things I know people going crazy for
Wonder traditional 2D but this would be
the J I would like to see him in so you
got my attention bro and I saw adct pick
I will probably pick it up that
definitely seems like this is my wheel
house for sure no doubt we got to move
on cuz it's so much stuff we got get can
I get my take on it I'm sorry yeah cuz I
got
T I was just listen to everybody have
sorry my bad so no no no the fact when
back in the days when it came out and uh
Square was working with Nintendo this
was like one of the times Nintendo lend
IP another development
and there was something that we never
seen but we were highly anticipated
because we really love Square RPGs and
they didn't miss back then so right now
if if y'all don't know about switch this
this thing that you can do you can when
they taught me this with vouchers they
have a voucher you can go in there is
$100 right so these games is
$69.99 you can go in there and pick up
two games under that $100 voucher and
those games will fit like so you I got
um Mario wonder and I got Mario RPG I
didn't know it was out until I was
watching addict show yesterday because I
had pre-ordered it and adct was like he
was going to go play Mario RPG so I ran
and started uh to play it downloaded it
and it's it's a welcome uh familiar call
back up resolution and I got to find out
all the new stuff that they do have
inside of it uh like hustle and him was
talking about so I was trying to listen
what not trying not to listen uh about
it but for you guys that want to save
money you have a switch and you're
trying to figure out how to do so in the
holiday you go in there and you purchase
this thing called vouchers you buy $100
voucher and you can get two games that
total over that
$100 but you don't have to worry about
that so essentially you can save up to
$40 $ 30
$40 if you get the vouchers and you can
pick two current new games or two games
that's in the past that you do want
because we know Nintendo really cut the
prices but there are deals to be had
inside the Nintendo shop but but you
know the caveat to that right King you
have to you have to be a member of oh
yeah of course and and it's cheap it
doesn't cost that much it cost 20
something bucks for you to get down for
the year that's it's it's the price to
is a small price to pay to save on
future games right so I see where the
value is in their online and then you
have the ability to do whatever go and
play their Sonic game their sonic
Collections and all that other stuff for
so the $20 is a minor uh thing for you
to get there online you save so much
with the vouchers that if you are a
switch or a Nintendo person who wants to
save some money and this is your first
time getting it look into the vouchers
it will save you tremendously no doubt
anything else on this we going to move
on cuz we got uh two more uh we got uh
the what you call it the MPD and we have
the um what you call it the Xbox tax
that everybody's been waiting for so uh
s how's the super
chats let me see hold on a
second let me see
Lord we got uh Lieutenant Hulk with the
$2 Super Chat man man Dan takes out the
entire Tekken roster that's
right aggressive angry Dan Man Dan Dan
Dan in in in The Pink Suit yeah then we
got Spartan 66 s $2 Super Chat Blanca
with the Pikachu move that's right
y Pikachu with the Blanca move be
correct
here just get it right then we got JD
gamer $5 chat Microsoft Xbox needs to
gobble up all of those AAA third party
exclusives and box Sony out just like
they plan to do to Xbox except except
that big bank takes little Bank very
aggressive very aggressive very very
very aggressive JD gaming once again not
done $2 Super Chat big bank takes little
Bank every time in all capitals thank
you shout
out thank you for your patronage
appreciate
you lieutenant Hulk once again $2 chat
over 700 in the chat hit that like
button hit that like we have almost
eight or 7:33 yes let's get up there
then we got JD gamer once again
no5 I want darkfield to gobble up all of
the relevant triaa third party games and
make them exclusive just like
PlayStation was trying to do but big
bank takes little Bank this man want
Xbox to own everything like he just like
they got to have and nobody can have
anything
else that's K that's K and and affiliate
yeah he hard body karate with this
continue that's it we're caught up all
right cool shout out to JD g go next
show all right so we got to get to it
this is K's topic I don't know how he
wants me to approach this but um yeah
NPD I guess uh shout out to Matt
piscatella you know talking about what's
going on in the month of October we had
the top 20 um bestselling premium games
for the month it was uh Marvel
Spider-Man 2 new to the list Super Mario
Wonder number two so you said Marvel
Spider-Man what two two yes number one
number one in NPD yes yes okay okay cool
then we have Super Mario Brothers Wonder
number two number that's number two
number two yes that is correct okay okay
that means Spider-Man beat beat yes yes
yes yes all right then we have all
Assassin's Creed Mirage which is new to
the list at number three oh that's dope
yeah Madden stays at number four and
then five we have uh EA Sports FC forly
known you know the Fifer joint uh Mortal
Kombat uh is still their six and then
seven is UFC brand new game NHL 24
Sonic Superstars 9 and hog Works Legacy
number 10 not in list anymore it's
number 14 for previously number one last
month but um yeah so that was that and
then I guess I don't know where else
King wants me to go as far as oh that
that we're finish you go yeah we just
wanted to you know hear the listen you
know who's what and you know so I made a
bet I made a bet you know that uh that
Spider-Man uh would lose the Mario yes
and and here's the okie dokie and npds
came out and they like King you lost
baby you lost you you ain't worth is
King that
98% oh man that 98% King he looking
right in the light and I'm like oh no oh
no I said so who put out the list they
was like Matt put out the list I was
like ah damn Matt is always right though
I like man I got I gotta suck this up
pause I gotta oh man I can't believe
this hold this out D I realize Nintendo
don't
report that is true that is true y guess
who got a digital copy me me me me so
I'm real right and all y'all out there
that's real and C digitally so we can
say that this list is skewed to who
because we already know Sony counts
digital they counts game they they count
this is what Sony count y'all check it
out this is how Nintendo beat them with
their hand tied behind their back let's
hear this right Sony counts away the
copies that they give away for promotion
Sony counts the um the ones that's in
bundles all right yeah King G like King
everybody count by peace okay okay all
right Sony does that so you talk about
all the review copies they they gave out
Sony counts that all right Sony counts
so every physical IND so only made sure
that they got all the numbers from all
across the Realms and it was like all
right we here with our
numbers did we win did we win they like
oh yeah you came out with you had five
million so how much did Nintendo sell
how much the Nintendo s Nintendo sld 4
million some ch right behind
you and Mario said you won Sony it did a
good
job and and Sony was like yeah I whipped
him I whipped him but a one a thing we
don't account to
digital that's how you said it that's
said no
no Luigi give me the numbers on the
digit of
celles so they F so so you implying that
Sony's popping their chest out and
Nintendo didn't even use full power they
didn't go to their highest level they
didn't even go to the 99th degree they
yo they only did one Dan they only
pulled one Dan
on it was a one Dan Black Belt situation
excuse me right now Sony came out was
like yeah you know we got everything we
did everything we pushed it all to the
Limit Nintendo said listen listen a
little
Sony it's all cool and nice but uh Luigi
give me them digital
numbers that'll be a number for five
million that's extra five in the tuck
stash said listen I let you walk around
and act like you got big bucks you know
who really got the bigger so they the
dude that's acting like they got money
but they don't got money you know
Mario's movie stars now they don't care
about you little dudes but at the end of
the day y'all didn't win y lost again
and Mario came out on your birthday hey
it's an hour
birthday Spider-Man man do the thing
with the webs you like to do Mario hey
Luigi count my coins I cannot with him I
can not I see where this is going I see
where this is going so it's funny though
it's funny so cuz I used to say these
arguments back in the day I used to get
killed but it's conveniently perfect for
King right now I see what he doing I I
got to use what I got to use to win how
I got to win and listen K and then I
told you Xbox Frontline news we're not
going to take it likely they did not win
NPCs especially when the near the second
uh runner up don't count what they count
right you You' heard here from King get
him from King get him King
get PlayStation's fault hold on that's
not PlayStation's fault uh Nintendo not
counting did you nintend they need no
they need to say what's up yeah it's
it's not n uh uh Sony's fault listen
Sony got to do what they got to do to
look good baby you know they got to do
their hair and their nails and you know
and they got to go get the BBL they got
to do all
you know how Sony do Sony got a fake it
till a make it Mario got to do it all
natural
baby it's all natury situation since
Mario said we're g to do it old style
you like an old style we G to do
physical no digital baby just all Natty
on you
baby give them the claw grip oh
man he said Mario gave you the CLA yo
out of pocket out of pocket anyone has
anything else to say on this as far as
Nintendo um I see games games you have
anything about this the Spider-Man
versus Mario match up yes I'm gonna keep
them really short this really really
short first off uh before I slandered
them I'm just gonna give them some props
uh
Spider-Man uh selling 5 million on like
what 45 million consoles or something
like that yeah right right that that's
that's crazy I I with Sony's credit um
to give them
credit they might finally
have a IP that can be something like
Mario right or can be something as big
as I don't know um yeah yeah Mario I'm
just going to say it right because Mar
Spider-Man's gigantic it's cross
generational right they have kids adults
alike it's something Sony has been
trying to do forever
MH and here's where I'm going to slander
them and I'm going to mic drop and leave
okay Sony didn't even create that
IP let's see what we do we doing we're
doing orig cre okay they can't create
that IP they've been trying for decades
to create IPS and they're just never
going to capture that and I'll leave it
there okay so then gets no love because
they have that Heritage right Spider-man
is
Spider-man and uh that's that's that's
what Spider-Man is and oh you talking
about from the character from a licensed
charact okay I see what you know oh yeah
licensed standpoint like they didn't
create Sony has nothing to do with the
creation of actual Spider-Man or but can
we give credit to actually making good
Spider-Man game no because I think if
you put I think if you put any any
talented
developer any talented developer you
give them Spider-Man that isn't a
licensed game to a
movie they're going to create a good
Spider-Man game wow and okay okay oh
yeah any Talent you put Bethesda that's
making these RPGs that span
gigantic like they're just gigantic
scale RPGs and then you shrink them to
the scope of a superhero game where all
the content is created mhm all of it
yeah the concepts the art right
everything's created all the stories
everything and then you tell them hey
guess what make a Spider-Man game with
this I think they could do it I don't
know since since Bethesda so well Renown
for their traversal
skills I saides because it's like have
we seen Avent with the Z
and say you say give it to Arcane maybe
yeah
I agree with him to a point when it
comes to you know more people than assia
can make these type of games but the
problem is is I don't think it's high
talented developers I I think there are
Studios that make similar games that
could pivot and make this just fine but
I think
Insomniac I got to see how they pull off
Wolverine okay because Wolverine is not
going to be like Spider-Man for some
reason people think Wolverine's going to
be traving around the map with his claw
jumping from building to building I
expect more over the shoulder Last of Us
template from Wolverine okay well you'll
be able to see that in 2025 yeah that's
what they said
2025 yeah yeah that's what I expect I
expect like kind of a god of war effect
going to Wolverine you're going to see a
lot of Q
QA uh qts I mean you're G just a lot of
you know over the shoulder types there
going to be a lot of cinematic cutcenes
there going to be that game's probably
have tripled the amount of um of uh what
what do they call it when you have uh
cut SC set pieces it's have a lot of set
pieces you know and that's that's what
you're gonna get and if they pull off
Wolverine and it's nothing like
Spider-Man then it's like okay hat off
but you know I can't take away for the
fact of what they've created I I can't
take away fact the fact what they
created though like they they have done
a very good job but at the same time
they've had the Batman games to look
over and see what they did right what
they did wrong if anyone I would say
Arcane is the one that really originated
that stuff they didn't really have a
whole lot of places to look at y
but sorry go ahead but you know at the
end of the day you know Spider-Man's a
good it's like I said multiple times
Spider-Man 2 you have venom Peter and
Miles how you mess up like I mean a lot
of a lot had Spider-Man games before no
no yeah but all of them all of them well
most of them time most of them tied and
constricted
toes to movie yeah more cash grab for
movie purposes or to you know get the
movie attention and and to be fair all
the people that are probably killing me
on Twitter right now or in the chat I
don't know
I I like Sony a lot again I only have a
a hatred for their controllers and you
know
that's all but I I love it but what I'm
before you tear my eyes out I
I I I I'm not saying oh my God Insomniac
and Sony suck at making games and they
don't have giant IPS they have giant IPS
but do those giant IPS sell 30 50 80
million copies you going I'm saying like
the Spider-Man IP and the Wolverine IP
uh have dedic audiences already right
and have most of their stories already
made right it's a golden mine to Sony to
have such a big IP now under a wing with
a talented developer I think it's a gold
mine for them and they finally could
break out into that Mario level sales
numbers right because I mean it's a
gigantic IP I don't think uh I'm saying
anything new there no absolutely no so
good good on them absolutely but Mario's
still better so wow and there you have
it there it is hustle your thoughts real
quickly on on this um I'm I'm going make
it super quick then I got to actually
get ready for work tomorrow um in samc
will yet again prove especially with
Wolverine like while they are while many
people view them as St even though of a
naughty dog you know I know naught
naughty dog has a lot of attention to
detail but yo here's what I'll say
um Spiderman is Game of the Year for me
I'm I'm G to keep that really short I
want to keep that really short um
earlier you guys were talking about
Platinum trophies and should you get
them or should you shouldn't you get
them I'm not the platinum trophy type of
guy but I'm one trophy matter of fact
I'm like nine takedowns away from a
platinum trophy in this game I really
enjoyed it that much I want to
correct uh I really want to correct one
of you all who said um the stories you
better not correct me man no no it's not
you adding no no no it's not that it's
not that um and Sh had kind of took
their own liberties with this story
so I'm extremely impressed with how they
just were able to Pivot and they
Implement they're implementing a lot of
things and if y'all play Spider-Man too
if you beat it you know what the the
very last cut scene is you know what the
post credit scene is yep I'm looking
forward to that yes real quick another
thing I want to point out and maybe King
can speak on this because I don't really
keep up with the Marvel stuff even
though Insomniac okay here's the story
of Spider-Man 2 would would Marvel
technically have to approve in this some
way shape or form or give a thumbs up or
a thumbs down like to me that's big by
itself having like the people doing
these cinematic stuff that's like yo
that's good that's gonna hit to me I I
think that helps too I can answer well
oh my fault K my fault I can yeah the
thing about it is is just the fact that
this game is not centered in the main
timeline in a sacred timeline this game
is like an elor type of game uh a
different world you know because if you
go to see the movie if you go watch the
movie uh Spider-Man into the Multiverse
um you get a chance to see different
Spider-Man they actually bring up the
Sony Spider-Man and he has his own world
so this story is being told in that
world and I believe the Disney Marvel
allowed them to craft it in a way that
is centered to their world only and that
world won't bleed off into the normal
Continuum and and in that way they have
the flexibility to tell the story how
they want to tell it as long as they
don't do anything egregious to the
characters uh they have the car blonds
to craft the world how they want to
craft it and that's what I've seen so
far they do and there's an interview on
IG kind of funny and with the one of the
creators of uh Spider-Man 2 they pretty
much was like all the stuff that you
said King they got the cosign from all
be like y we like they said we like this
so I think that that's dope and I I
think that in terms of Storytelling what
they're doing I really enjoyed they even
got their last of us on in um Spider-Man
2 certain I was like yo that's so heavy
handed but I enjoyed it nonetheless um
yeah was real quick I'm just telling the
ls to check the Facebook yeah we we said
we was GNA do that yeah we we got you
adct no doubt everybody's good uh yeah
to that point to that point like okay
hustle I agree I agree with both what
I'm trying to say is like the to create
new characters from scratch right right
is one thing and pivoting story on
Craven and Doc O is another thing what
I'm trying to say is like Sony's for for
a very long time has been trying to
create universes to burst out right kind
of like God of War and whatever it tooks
eight games for them I don't know how
many games eight games 20 games for them
to get God of War into a spot that's in
the L like Big Shiny lights right now
right 20 million sold or whatever it's
really hard to create your own
characters and your own world that from
a blank slate right Spider-Man is not a
completely blank slate so I think it's a
big like it's a gold mine for Insomniac
such a talented set of people to have a
like worlds and worlds of Worlds that
were already created to kind of pick and
pull from and Stitch together into a
coherent story is all I was saying but
uh good on Sony for making it happen no
doubt no doubt hustle you your final
thoughts on that before we head out
final thoughts go play Spider-Man 2 go
play Mario one then definitely go play
Mario RPG no doubt real quick one last
thing about Mario RPG my fault this game
will not be uh best RPG in the game
awards next year oh as as I love this
game it won't be it won't be it won't be
okay F enough what about this Xbox tax
at the game
awards he hey yeah I'm I'm I'm going sit
back and and let y'all cook I think that
you I'm say said I'm not touching that
no no no cuz oh no for real for I don't
care for real for and got smoke for
anybody who who's talking to Xbox teag
BS cuz it's BS it's BS how about that
how about Starfield sold what it sold in
in September which is awesome which is
definitely awesome to see for a new IP
but how about ain't nobody else talking
about that dur no more how about that
how about how about if it released the
same day as Spider-Man we all know what
really would have happened how about
that if it would have dropped the sameit
tell we're never we're never getting out
of never get out of this I got I got
said I leave that alone but n really I
got I got I got I got to let him finish
his part because I gotta I got to just
give him one R buff before he slide out
the door he just west you hey so all
right so so you you you stepped up here
and you was talking about all this that
the third right so Sony put out their
bundle what what month did they put out
their bundle with Spider-Man 2o ear you
would have to educate me it's September
right what game launched in September
this sir
what Starfield Starfield launched in
September right okay so you had the
bundle ready you had the digital codes
you had everything in the box ready but
you said not that
dude not that
guy doing so so we said we gonna move to
October we gonna do this on the 20th and
Mario said he like out that day too so
you can run from him or you GNA get this
smoke and you know what Sony said we
could take our chances against the dude
that don't report digital so so wait
wait wait wait report digital rep out
this topic he going to report digital he
going to report physical and he GNA
report every goddamn thing so we not
going to mess with that dude cuz that IP
kind of strange over there and he might
knock our socks off and if you go and
look and see how much Starfield sold
compared to uh
Spiderman we know that he would have
came up short regardless with all the
stuff that he would have brought to the
table King was trying to avoid this so
in order to move you move for a reason
you had to you had everything ready you
had the the the room was set up
everything was nice but you didn't
launch and you held
Che so I want to know why the hell the
Spider-Man run from September that's
what we doing okay that's what we doing
um so so so wait a minute wait a minute
wait let's get it so so so the good
folks over there at PlayStation were so
shook so shook sure but new IP that's
right terrified hold on that's riddle
with bugs and we know but we know
talking about bugs man
gotg that's a man and he got bugs in
this game but let's go get it yeah and
those loading times on Starfield were
were even more egregious uh you
got you got a
fast me finish go ahead go ahead where
the co-op what's everything talk to me
about so so so egregious that that Todd
Howard uh affectionately referred to as
God Howard correct that's right he's a
God he a God of this yeah yeah he is he
said yo if you want my game to run right
you need the top of the top PC that's
right that's right that's right that's
what man said yeah that's what he said
and Playstation ran from that yeah he on
let me get that too right no no no Mario
said we going in October baby yeah all
right on your on your birthday listen
listen let me let me tell you something
first of happy birthday car thank you
thank you to app secondly secondly that
that no what's a Starfield what what is
the thing that
starfi I'm so glad I brought this with
me today I am not I am not asking what
it is as ask the average person what
Starfield is they probably don't even
know what it is or what how much did how
much did Starfield sell in the month
that they came out king you know I'm not
worried about no
sales
about now now you not worry
but we just talked
about I don't number one I don't ever
worry about sales numbers in particular
and since we are talking since okay well
I'll talk to you I'm here talk to it
probably would have sold more if it
wasn't in Game Pass but you know that's
neither here nor there but it's sold
though that's the thing that's the thing
it sold more in Game Pass andc and on
Xbox and it did more and it made your
move like y had the car y had was
ready had you had the hold you had wings
remember you had
wings you had the game why you had the
digital C so all right check it out you
know how I know y didn't want to smoke
you know how this I do I just got get
ready for work tomorrow hustle work
tomorrow shout out you know how I know
y'all was scared hustle oh yeah you know
how I know y'all was scared go ahead
tell me all I need to know y' sold a
console
with the digital code so the digital
code and everything was ready y'all was
ready y had the wings ready you had the
console ready y'all was ready I said do
not hit that live button they G to start
counting us and this dude is rap so the
new IP looked at you and said I'm ready
for everything you got and we going to
do it in September you said you said we
got the stuff but we ain't ready to
fight though
we'll we'll see you when all the smoke
calm down we going to October don't you
worry about that you apply Spider-Man
was ready for release in September King
this what we doing he was ready and you
know you know this is when Todd this is
when they bully balled y'all Todd in
them was holding the date y'all came out
and said the DAT and y' y'all said yeah
we gonna have this game out you know
y'all know September cuz I had the
situation ready and I was waiting for
y'all and Todd said we going in
September Sony said all see you in
October surprise brother where we H we
going to go on October 20th to oh my God
this y was going to get knocked out and
y'all got knocked out regardless so you
and it was buggy so you want to talk
about bugs right I don't think I think
if you're a Bethesda fan I think that's
the last I think that's the last
thing this is it this is where this is
where the fraud alert come out on you
you got 30 years of roaches in your
careb
not the 30 years of roaches not 30 years
of uncleanliness so so so 30 years of
roaches
but hustle hustle what's up the first
the first uh Spider-Man was it bugi was
it bugville I didn't play too much of it
so I
couldn't now you reallying so you just
show there right
quick to put FR save yourself come on
now God how you going to show up and
talk about two and you ain't been there
for one was you there for miles at least
I I played in be miles all right so so
you knew that the Puerto Rican flag
shouldn't have been the Cuban flag did
you absolutely I knew that the Cuban
flag did you know that because I mean
did you call that part out so what how
did you feel when they came up with
their own version of Spanish like did
you understand they was really speak
Spanish and not speaking Spanish I mean
I
would let me tell you this shout out to
all my my Puerto Rican brothers and
sisters T we was offended we was
offended hey as you should be you you
really should be cuz that that was it
was broken no it was broken okay all
right so so now we talking bugs let's
talk since you I think you want to take
that there
though I actually I actually do I
actually do I know about that I'mma make
listen this is definitely a video later
I'm just say that right now I'm I'm
going make you do it to yourself this is
where you going to do it to yourself
this where yourself is going to do you
in can you or can you not say that this
game has the most games most bugs out of
any game Insomniac has ever brought to
the table if by most bugs I'm going off
my own
personal Insomniac so let me cuz cuz I
do have a bit of a history with
Insomniac even even from Sunset over
drive too right right I've had two soft
locks one in the mement park and it was
like one for like a mission select but
I've had two hard crash no one hard
crash in like a 40 hour spare and almost
got the Platinum so I'm not saying that
the bugs are there I'm saying for me
this is what happened and I bought that
game day one man I went out to the
midnight release and I was playing it
that night too so for me everything
seemed to work just fine okay I'm not
saying that the so tell tell tell all
right so let's get back to the question
I
asked all right is this the most bugs in
an insomniac game that you've ever
played I mean three of them dog you
talking about three could you answer the
question sir is this the
most you start to slip hustle you're
starting to slip I'm try trying think
I'm trying to think back the Morales
uhhuh was it I don't think it was that
bad I don't
think Ratchet and Clank cuz I played and
beat that one I'm I'm about to end that
one that one wasn't that bad either not
like
this stop his I don't I'm okay with with
the quote bugs I'm I'm okay with because
my experience didn't really stop me from
playing it was you talking about three
you talking about less than five okay
can we get back to my question hold on
before I even get back to your question
all right go ahead sir how how was this
cuz I'm assuming you played in Beast
Starfield correct all right listen
listen listen let's get to this
that as how many sir sir sir sir sir
sir before before I answer your question
cuz I'm G do a whole lot faster than you
I want you to answer the question is
this the most bugs that you've ever
encountered in an insomniac game yes or
no sir sir it's it's it's only hard for
me to answer that because my time with m
is Morales I'm trying to figure out did
I have that much best not forget that s
part I honestly can't remember
sir so you misremember
sir the missing don't do it like that
don't do it like
that I'm GNA take that I'm going to take
I'mma take that as a yes this is the
most bugs that you have
encountered Inn again and I'm going tell
you this I I I've encountered one bug in
Starfield I told you the woman was
floating and I had to I had come back
what's that game
where what's that game where it says the
battle has been
decided so so we we going we we we the
beef off is over now
right hold hold on I just want to say I
just want to say to the like I have
anything to do today I I just want to
say to the realm it's
official don't come for me unless I S
for you cuz I'll finish you off but God
bless hustle and motiv Shout
Out number one hold on let me go get
something hustle
because you can figure out if you can
remember by the time I come back list
that's cute stop being hustle before you
go please tell five people where they
can find you cuz you hilarious and you
got to go to work and we're not trying
to get nobody fired so where they can f
it's it's it's tomorrow I just wake up
at 3: in the morning um hindsight with
hustle was my new channel I'll tweet
y'all so y'all can just tweet it back
out so actually Focus I actually focus
on Retro Gaming content um so a few of
the Spider-Man games that were spoken
about earlier like we shadows and I
played Shadow Dimensions just recently I
kind of like that game too even though
the camera was kicking my behind I'm
just going to focus on like the Retro
stuff that's just something that I
really enjoy um that's why I'm super
excited about uh Super Mario RPG and
pretty much everything after that uh
K is there anyone else hold on hold on
hold on before before you before you
finish no no no he can I finished
already he doing he done am I though
because I I believe the game one of the
games that I really enjoy playing this
year two of the games that I really
enjoy playing this year up for game of
the year uh nominees how about uh
Starfield doing
it so this is like a perfect transition
to the to the last topic let's get to
the last topic Xbox this sounds like a
perfect transition to the last topic
Xbox tax let's go all right so U we that
we're going to now do that um yeah so it
looks like the streets are talking y'all
the streets are talking obious see see
man apprciate you guys
apprciate God
bless in your absence I do all I do want
to I do want to throw a red flag on the
on the field and say King has no right
to complain about the the the length of
the show today yes yes complain about it
was like three beef offs that I had to
deal with listen hip
hop Hip Hop look at that you got to be
calling you hip hop cuz normally hip hop
bring this type of smoke so hustle and
motivate I hope you have a blessed day
sir and um I want you to go back and
understand we made you
move you know what just go just go with
it you could have played that game in
September but we gave you a September to
remember have a blessed day it's all
good the Video Game Awards y'all just
watch the Video Game Awards and watch
Starfield not be nominated yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch Spider-Man get
beat
salute be be a mess out the door salute
Spiderman going be a two time
loser here looking
crazy your man a got a
shot better shot than y'all
I'm he shot a shot on the way
out and he get the last word he had to
get the last word and they gave your
that easy entrance to get a go ahead you
got
Nom all right uh final topic I put I put
his Twitter in the in the all jokes
that's the homie L of jokes all right
streets are talking the nominees have
gone you know have have been released
you know out here for the game awards
you know some some people had issue
certain categories and nominations are
lack thereof so we got to get to the
main topic though this was actually
trending y'all Xbox tax to the main
topic five hours in Xbox tax so is it
real what are we feeling what's the
streets looking like start with I'm
scared to start with games through but
we going to start with
games Lord G we GNA start with you I'm
nervous I'm nervous all I have all I
have is good things to say
um I I okay is the Xbox tax real
sir
oh we got a about
say I have to watch my words I yes why
is it real only yes it's real because I
don't want to fight
King he said I don't want he don't want
to smoke with okay smoke I'm done I'm
done
you down n n you're a taon do Champion
you better use your feet let's
go why is the Xbox tax real according to
Lord gab
um I think
there's just from this like fact that
Xbox has been smaller and late to this
whole industry uh yeah I think it's
ingrained in people's culture to like
certain consoles because they have long
long long hard histories and fan base is
and let's face it when Xbox could have
had a like that building moment which is
I think 360 when they had that big like
explosion uh they could have built upon
that fan base a little bit and grew it
steadily from there but they fumbled it
right they they they fumbled it they
didn't walk out there with uh many of
their own IPS that they could kind of
like put up into the light kind of like
the 18 God of War are out anyways um so
it I yeah I I think in a very small way
I think subconsciously you know the
people have a small bias maybe yeah okay
no fair though you're standing on it
respect Lord addict we had a video out
this week with this in the title
trending
everywhere the the the Realms are
divided is there an Xbox tax at the game
oh I don't necessarily think there's an
Xbox tax I think there is this thing
going on the industry and there's just
multiple first off I don't think a lot
of people play Xbox and so I think they
aren't connecting anything Xbox related
because it's it's it proofs in the
pudding like you know besides high-fi
Rush what did Xbox realistically win
that's not abk's games I mean get
nominated for like pretty much nothing
and it's just like you know there's no
reason see th and Halo uh Halo infinite
shouldn't have been on there and it's
just like I don't think that you know
it's like media buys I don't think
there's a media B I think there's just a
lot of people in the media that don't
like Xbox interesting I think when it
comes to these judges once again how are
these judges chosen who chooses these
judges you know we've seen the the
nomination judges that's cool but it's
just entities you know at the end of the
day
literally the people voting on this is
the exact same people who's doing the
Metacritic score
stuff and it's like obviously it's like
as an entity like a whole entity
together it's just it's crazy to me it's
just like I don't understand how you
know you look at through all the years
you know regardless what you fell by
Halo infinite it was still an
87 and the media acts like the game was
horrible look at gears 5 it was like 84
85 and
that to me that's strandy I think it was
it was the year what year did uh that um
gears 5 come out oh trying to remember
can't remember you told I know was like
nominated was that the same year 2019
okay 2019 Game of the Year 2019 nominees
so here here was the The Game of the
Year nominees and and please tell me if
this sounds logistic to you guys
control Super Smash Brothers ultimate I
give them that one death stranding
to me and to
me okay Resident Evil 2 rebank you love
that re love Resident Evil 2 is
definitely going to be better uh SRO
that one game of the year the outer
worlds was a solid game U but to me
control and death stranding gears
deserve to be in one of those spots well
gears had some hiccups in that game but
it and to me it was a better game than
both of those games it had a lot of ups
and some downs but it's just like like
to me it just it it feels like to me
it's like I said these people don't play
Xbox they play everything on PlayStation
and then when it comes down to choosing
things on Xbox do we even know they play
these games when it comes to strategy
games are these judges playing strategy
games we don't know you know why because
we don't know who who are
they and it's just like we we see
throughout years I I seen individuals at
GameStop say the best case scenario you
could do is sell your playst your Xbox
we've seen constant you know times where
IGN has forgot to put Xbox in in in in
the in the trailers for third party
games like there's just so many things
that constantly happen throughout the
year and then people want to sit there
adct you're just being too hard no it's
because I'm tired of not holding people
accountable how many times can Dustin
come out and say we we took down the the
the trailer we fixed it we put Xbox in
it we put it up love Dustin to death how
many times can that happen before we
like yo what what's going on here this
how do how do you consistently and I
understand if it if it's like okay I
don't understand how how do you how do
you
forget that Xbox is it's coming to Xbox
is a third party game tell them mic and
it was big games I think they did with
Resident Evil 4 or something like that
like these aren't small
games okay okay no you saying you
standing on you standing on and you look
at like the the categories they're
bigger joke than the
judges how is
cyberpunk coach that isn't a coach my
pointa so people sit there and they're
like ad horrible they're like cuz I I
they're like addict you know what like I
just personally feel like you're being
too much the they got a they got a
certain demographic these people they
they just didn't like the game that you
liked okay that's cool they clearly they
don't even know what the hell's going on
in their own industry cuz choosing
people that's not even active in the
indust dude had to tell them that I'm
not even a coach this year take me off
the Nom just that right there right
there how do you mess up that bad yeah
but it it's an indictment right it's an
indictment on not knowing the genres and
the categories and who should be it and
who shouldn't and the sad part is people
sit there and say well if they gave it
to the fans it'd be a popularity contest
to me it's a popular contest with the
media oh look look at the biggest games
come out this year they're all on that
day
list okay he he's got a lot to say um s
very curious Xbox tax is it real where
do you stand on
this
uh he smiling I'm
scared I think
the I think the possibility for it to be
real exists and I think I just think
that the the the hill that a lot of
people dying on with Starfield is the
wrong it's the wrong game to die on that
Hill for um I think um but I do think it
does the possibility for it does exist
because the possibility for manipulating
this whole process exists and I think
there's no greater uh sort of proof of
that than hogwart's Legacy did you did
you guys see how like I don't know if
they do this often but why is the Video
Game Awards like promote in a Last of Us
remake did you see that Last of Us Part
Two remake and they promoted it they
show but it's the marketing show I I
listen all this hate that key gets i'
understand if the game came out hold up
I'd understand if the game came out
during the get Video Game Awards and
they're announcing it afterwards but how
is the Video Game Awards I don't see the
market games like that just going to
randomly Market The Last of Us Part Two
remake it just it it's it's it's it's
like what they got the exclusive
marketing rights because because key
Key's whole thing is the
marketing honest let's be honest the
awards are an afterthought right yeah it
was actually yeah it was so you know all
of this other stuff is an afterthought
it's a marketing show everybody watches
it to see what's coming next all this
other stuff is an afterthought if
they're marketing it I assume there's
some kind of money sir are we kind of
insinuating that some's paying thank you
I'm just trying to
it's about Mark obviously some some kind
they sat down and be like hey we're
going to announce this here or whatever
this the case may be what the money is
or if their money is going back and
forth all I know is at the end of the
day he understands that people come to
it for this you could say in his heart
of hearts he could want it to be about
the devs and it's a special moment and
I'm sure he's happy that he's able to
provide that platform no matter how
skewed it may be how broken it may be
right I just think think he's happy with
that but the fact of the matter is like
I said the idea that the process is is
potentially broken is no more evident in
the Hogwarts Legacy I agree because with
Hogwarts Legacy though I I do feel that
ultimately at the end of the day maybe
the game uh overall wasn't going to fit
especially with this the field of games
this year was going to fit into the game
of the year category the fact that it
wasn't nominated for anything basically
across the board indicates that the that
the industry there
a faction of the industry of the voting
faction of the industry was able to get
together and essentially block something
off by acting like it doesn't exist or
everybody's feelings about about JK
Rowling somehow were able to to coales
into this one feeling and everybody kind
of knew hey now we don't touch that with
a 10-ft pole uh it's not even going to
going to get talked about um so and and
much like the Starfield thing where
people talk about at the end of the day
you can the team could go home laughing
knowing that their game sold
ridiculously well the game has done very
well they put out a very good product
they should be very proud of and the JK
rolling thing people could take that
with they could do with that what they
will at the end of the day this team did
never deserve to get penalized for how
people feel about JK rowand it was
always stupid and the fact that you
allow those feelings to permeate into
into the Integrity of your work is what
Ely bothers me because this speaks to
the Integrity of your work of what your
word means when you say I review games I
talk about
games so with all of that said is there
a potential for people like I don't I
don't care so there's a potential for
buas to exist is what you say 100% now
when I go back to the Starfield thing
and people gonna be mad at me but I'm G
tell y
right I love Starfield it's in my top
five games in the year I mean that may
mean nothing to you because I played
five games this year
Bas or I I started 50 but I play five
AB but when I look at this list right
and I'm not talking about how I feel
about I'm talking about how I see the I
see everyone else perceiving competitive
when when you look at this list y' to
get Starfield down there the way people
are are seeing it and perceiving it the
way it's been talked about you would
have needed to get to close to 10
nominees to to get to Starfield I'mma Be
I'm G keep it a bug and it's not it's
not Leon Kennedy coming in and shooting
out your kneecaps now it wasn't that cuz
I I I firmly believe that you know a
street fighter six probably would have
gotten in there before it I firmly
believe a see of stars as the as the
Indie darling would have gotten in there
Diablo and this is talking about how the
industry is perceiving the game now how
I perceive the game I'm Gonna Keep it a
buck it would have been for Starfield to
make it in this field of games the way
it's been talked about high five rush to
me would have probably been more of a
lock than Starfield to get into this
into this field um so it it's one of
those things like I I understand it I
just don't think Starfield is the G the
the hill to die on when it comes to that
uh there's other things that in the past
have been kind of like to to addict's
point the the gear stuff where it's like
this is a much more polished refined
product that let's say this more people
generally like right and I I think the
high-fi rush is is a good example of
that where it's generally well-liked
it's it's at 89 Metacritic so it's like
it's it's right there right um but
everybody had pretty much has positive
to say about it I think that's the type
of product that's going to get you over
that hump I think something like
Starfield was never going to get over
that hump in this sort of year of so
many games kind of being above that 90
Metacritic so that that's it that that's
my only thing but I definitely believe
that the envirment the environment
totally exists for the Xbox tax stuff to
be real and I'm not I'm gonna admit like
I in in the past I've seen it and I'm
like man what is this like why does it
always feel like Xbox has to do the
extra thing right and I pointed to the
fact and maybe some people agree don't
agree I know King disagrees because he
he he really loves the fact that game
PASS gives you so much variety but I go
to your point uh Cog where it's like the
hashtag just one is what people see as
the standard of Excellence whether we
like it or not right cinematic game
that's that is what people see as that
is Excellence so when we talk about
these other genres that Xbox has been
bringing back those are great those are
fantastic I love those when you think
about the people that are voting for
this stuff right um you do have your
older guard right people that still work
at these Outlets or whatever but you do
have plenty of younger people who have
never sat down to play a Starcraft never
sat down that that's not their thing so
those games as as amazing as they can be
they're not getting to shine because
nobody different gen yeah oh oh this is
definitely the fact that Microsoft has
made it their point that that game pass
is going to have this morgas Borg of
genres and we they haven't really
acquiesced to the giving us the just one
right they haven't really done that
right so it it is that thing of like
well eventually they will they they'll
make a game in that vein right uh
Whatchamacallit hellblade is looking to
be a game in that vein or whatever um
even high-fi Rush kind of as a you know
double A type game of that of that ilk
is coming but to me the the industry has
been trained for this is what Excellence
is the third action game right template
and then they haven't given that
template so is it fair no it's not at
all fair because great games are great
games and I think what bothers me most
overall about that is that it that
template and that way of thinking should
not exist in this space because we're
talking about the gaming Enthusiast
space the people that should be smarter
than that and realize that greatness
resides in all genres of games so the
fact that it's gotten so uh to use one
of Colin words myopic and it's very sort
of horse blinders on this is what
greatness is it's it's disheartening to
me because these are the people that are
supposed to be the Professionals in the
space and I'm like hey there's much more
to it than that got um so it it saddens
me to see that that's kind of the trend
but that's where I'm at with it um yeah
I got you I want I want to break
protocol real quick because oh Alex has
something relevant shout out to the
homie oh no it's Alex T out Super Chat
my 10f hat prediction is Allan wck 2
will get game of the year over Boulders
Gate 3 epic is publishing it and epic is
also a partner of the game awards also
journals don't journalists don't like
playing games they'd rather watch
them shout out to Alex shout out to Alex
for being Messi shout games leader did
you want to jump you your head up I'm
sorry yeah just really quick uh first
first off my God we're gonna tell in in
some categories like in the RPG category
if Final Fantasy something like Final
Fantasy 16
wins okay
if that wins anything in the RPG real
first off what was on there lies of P
yeah I mean
if my God it's ridiculous yeah um we're
gonna see in that category right and
we're GNA
see to me the big thing is like Diablo 4
guys uh yeah diao 4 diao 4 I I'm sorry
um Diablo 4 was incredible and I I
really do think that we just like gave
it a good score they gave like the
Diablo head in the studio and the yeah
in the big building the the review job
and then you have the round table and
everybody votes it out out the room
because you know that they just had
their say they have to be like we're not
biased you know Diablo 4 right we gave
it an eight 8.8 but then like 90% of
them don't care you know how is it even
going to get into the reward at that
point right right because there's round
taes at each of these websites and then
they vote on their pick and then
boom diabo Resident Evil just the fact
that Resident Evil 4 I mean the Remake
is on there is crazy because if you drop
that out we could actually see the bias
if Diablo 4 for instance like s said
wouldn't be there at that point we could
probably talk but they're so good at
disguising it and maybe they just don't
see it maybe they don't see it but I
think they're disguising it I'm gonna go
the spicy rout oh you go going I'm going
spicy we mustache twirling all right
Diablo 4 took a decade to make but they
put a remake in
there okay fair enough they put a remake
in there a decade to make from the
ground up I a rem brand new I get it
brand new I get you I get you ridiculous
I anyways I want to get King he's been
patient so King streets is talking man
said is is the Xbox Xbox tax was
trending K you better not disappoint me
there there was there was a there was a
video out
there there was a video
boy us us nerds can be vicious to one
another we are nerds and and I want I
want you to know nerd nature right nerd
nature we click up you find that cool I
find that cool too I play that little
niche
stuff I believe all them dudes got
PlayStations all of them all right I
believe all of them got PlayStations I
believe maybe uh 5% of them have an Xbox
I believe uh they don't even play on the
platforms what you saying I yeah I
believe 80% of them have a Nintendo so I
believe that their PlayStation dominant
Nintendo uh they use as a support and
you know go out and get all the
Nostalgia games or whatever to be in
that that group but box guys as as far
as nerds go we're kind of shunned right
um when it comes to the video game genre
we're we're we're like dude Bros a lot
of us we are gym dudes you know you know
neand
dud four Dan ones exactly we we're four
Dan and then the PlayStation dudes y'all
of you know the real geeky nerd type of
dudes you know and y'all sit there in
Corners talking about certain things
then you have Nintendo Duce y'all really
bond with the Nintendo Duce we are the
outside we're looked at as the
opposition to be honest with you we're
the rough guys if y'all had a fight
y'all would not send PlayStation dudes
and Nintendo dudes in y'all send the
Xbox dudes in first that's that's what
that's what it is y send us in because
we the Rough and Tumble ones we we them
dudes right now look at
IGN they all want to be inclusive they
want to be together with each other yo y
I don't put that Xbox out there H you
play Xbox you get sweaty like that
no I don't geter like that I know you I
know you not picking that Xbox I know
you ain't gonna put that I Ain put that
in there so these conversations are
happening it's collusion it's collusion
for sure it's collusion for sure for
sure first first and I'mma tell you and
I got facts I got facts okay you to hear
this listen I love you Paris I love you
to death but I got to do it to you got
call you to the congregation
I know listen listen listen you said on
our platform that um hog uh Hogwarts
Legacy won't get
nominated right and you gave the
political reasons why okay the talk
around
it not on the merits of this
game not on the merits of itself not on
the merits of of everything that the
developers put
in on the merits of a
creator that doesn't make the
game this game was
ostracized because the human element
that is involved felt that they wanted
to make a political
stance this is where your
integrity is gone not you Paris the game
IGN game awards the individuals that
have the ability to say yay or
nay now if you
think somebody disconnected from the
game in that space right can say
something that can affect the game not
the quality not the writing not bugs not
anything and excluded from every
category there's a
flaw so there's a
possibility that that same
flaw has infested the thoughts and minds
of the People review or putting these
games up for the awards the nominations
that Microsoft is inherently bad you
have people that would
Champion them not winning the ABK
deal and the fact that they did win
I'mma take a political stance I'm not
going to vote for their game their new
IP that if this IP takes
off this is the IP that they can be like
damn they got against uh Sony and if
that's your beloved
platform and it's not there you feel
away don't tell me you don't feel away
because I feel way when a game is
launched on a PlayStation even though I
got a PlayStation and it's not on the
Xbox platform but I don't have the vote
to deny these
dudes and I'm telling you out of spite I
would do things so if I'm telling you
this and you know 90% of the people's
going to lie to you and they're not
going to tell you the truth and how they
really feel because they don't want it
to affect their viewing
numbers the element to have an Xbox tax
and we see it Xbox is running with a
book bag with bricks on their back
Nintendo is jogging the hill without
bricks Sony is jogging the hill with
bionic
legs what is the is the bionic legs the
help from the media that's that's the
help from the media I'mma tell you
this all you're doing is making a bigger
stronger
Warrior you cannot stop no matter how
much you try to oppress one group it
will not work it's going to be a period
of time and I put it there that you
won't be able to deny Microsoft anything
because they will own everything and I'm
seeing all and I and I put it I put it
as a thought experiment and I see y
saying that's not cool King because if
they do that then competition is not
there MH you forced him to do
that you forced the good kid to be bad
you forc the good kid to say I got to
even the odds because these dudes aren't
listening to me I'm doing the best I'm
doing everything and I'm going above and
beyond and they're not listening so I
must fight you will not save
Kong no matter what you're doing all
you're doing is making Mecca
Godzilla and you know meca Godzilla stop
long heart you know King Kong heart got
stopped and Y y'all y'all doing it so I
want y'all I want all of you dudes all
of you all of you that that didn't put
uh any Xbox games up there when it
happened and I'm looking at y'all y'all
looking at the dead body and I'm
standing next Y and I'm saying y'all
could have save C you standing over with
the dead body I'm standing there with
them because I got more soy stuff than
you you I got more to lose than y'all
but I'm telling you cuz y'all don't buy
games I'm telling you y'all going to
kill
Kong because do it to Y don't want to
keep it real and y'all haven't kept it
real So Kong is GNA die because of
you and and Jeff Jeff it was your hand
that did it cuz you sat back and you
didn't stop it and you kept pour salt in
the wood gotta kill Co in order to save
Xbox we got a kill
Co you are a fool that was good that was
good I was thoroughly entertained that
was thally ENT ad adct adct did I give
you what you want to
say it was efficient man this this a
good one this the Xbox tax this is what
they talk about this what the streets is
going on man a jumping look this what I
feel I'm going to say no but my
reasoning is different I don't think
Xbox tax exist I don't think there is
bias in the games industry yes we are
human beings we all have bias we all
have favorites I personally don't think
that they are mustache twirling yeah
that's how we going to get him I don't
think that's happening however I will
say my major issue with the game awards
in this situation this topic is there is
genre bias it is clear kind of what s
has said to me which is clearly people
play on specific platforms that they
prefer and even in years where for
example which is considered the bad year
for Xbox would be 2022 right no
Starfield no refall that year and
grounded and penate dropped grounded is
a great game penate is a highly reviewed
great game narratively it was it didn't
make the cut another example that you
can give is Forza Horizon 5 I learned a
harsh lesson this year Starfield is my
personal game like I love that game but
to Sol's point where he is 100% right he
said Cog this type of year right it's
just too competitive the landscape is
too much and he is correct Rand th made
a bet with and lost to they they are
correct I knew coming in I was against
the eight ball because I know I love
Starfield the way I do but it wasn't
didn't get the critical Acclaim from a
Metacritic perspective right but what I
look at was like the year before and I
look at a Forza Horizon 5 which
theoretically did get the Metacritic uh
sensation what about 92
93 and made people try Racing for the
first time but what it showed me by not
see this is not about winning game of
the year to me this is about nominations
when I don't see things nominated
because they're in different genres that
is a problem that exposes to me that you
don't play these other genres unless
it's hashtag just one it feels like the
Metacritic thing applies to only certain
genres exactly so to me this is a deeper
issue this is go developers I love y'all
but if you make strategy racing
multiplayer live service God bless you I
don't think you going to get nominated
for any game of the I don't care how
great your game is because the outside
of I would give the one outlow where I
was proud of them which was OverWatch
OverWatch wasn't my game of the year
that year it won but it won was it um
did they own them then I don't know all
I'm going to say is I don't know about
all know do we own ABK by that time I
don't
know all I know where you going I know
where you're going I'm just going to
tell you what I see so when I saw
OverWatch with even though it wasn't
cogs game of the year it didn't have
narrative I said oh wait this is still a
good thing Co get out of your feelings
because I said it's took you a couple
years it took me a year you know you
know I struggled I struggled right I was
for it I thought Uncharted Uncharted had
it in the bag I was like I was so happy
hash just one naan Drake strong
narrative graphical Fidelity I will say
the chat starting to bring it up I was
going to say a second ago yeah I do
think that just because like bers Gate 3
most most years wouldn't get what it is
now right that's huge to be there yeah
huge bers Gate 3 is an outliner it's not
the
analy and what I'm trying to say is when
I saw back to OverWatch when I saw
OverWatch I said this is still good for
the industry get out your feelings call
because it's showing that a team based
shooter with great mechanics that's fun
that's popular and people are playing
this game it deserves it great so now in
my mind I'm like genre Bas over right we
all games that are great if they're in a
different genre they got a shot to be
nomin I'm not even talking about winning
this is about nomination and I got to go
back to this this year now look I know
there's some people in opposite fence I
make kill for it if you are a remake I
do not want to see you on no game of the
year list all you did is remix a verse
somebody already came out with you you
literally have a foundation in place for
you and you are just adding on to the
foundation that does not surpass an
original thought created from scratch
games Le I'm with you all day every day
we going to war tawan doing this one
right so my thing is both feet act both
feet facts and to soft point we gon to
talk about bias and what's going on
hogwart's Legacy King King said it
beautifully if we're going to sit there
and say again I'm not saying game of the
year I'm talking about in any category
art Direction one of the most popular
games of the year still to this day we
saw them NPD numbers but it's not about
NBD it's about impact right if you're
going to tell me that hardw work's
Legacy cannot be nominated for any
category you are making a political
statement you are showing that despite
the developers saying hey we don't agree
with the law Master despite the the LW
Master not making the game despite the
game having a trans
character you are saying none of that
matters you are not part of this show
you have made a statement that is bias
clearing through so if if to King point
if you could do this why is it hard for
people to say that the other things are
not possible that we have to be honest
so for people who saying yo you just you
guys are just in your feelings because
your favorite game no you've already
demonstrated they've demonstrated to
your face they can make a political
state so it's excuse my leg it's F the
devs who made hogwart's Legacy right
because they none of their feelings got
put into this they are getting penalized
because of the lore owner the owner of
the lore is is made a statement that's
all she would probably and I don't think
she would get upset like they
put the the they put a transgender in
the game which is something that she has
spoke out again to show their opposition
to the L Master none of that mattered
you are not part of don't don't show up
here you're not welcome here that's
basically what's being said okay fine
let's get to if okay you guys in your
feeling okay fine now we going to talk
about these categories right we
have cyberpunk in the best ongoing game
next to games like fortnite Apex Legend
ongoing a game that already existed that
just added an expansion what are we
doing we got Dave the diver diver in the
Indie category ball this game is not
even in the category it should be we got
Sports in E uh Sports and racing in one
category in strategy we got skinny Sky
skylines that launch broken and the devs
told you yo bro it's broken we sorry you
know what I'm saying this was nominated
by the game awards what are we you're
just exposing yourself for not knowing
what's going on in in these categories
it it's clear as day you got that you
got one year we had seafu in the
fighting game category category oh that
is a disrespect to the fgc what are we
doing and to se bro I am the biggest
Destiny fan known to man what the hell
is Bungie doing on the community best
community support when they fired half
of their community staff and comm's team
what are we doing so it's clear as day
they are not in tune with the categories
they only playing specific genres and
that's it and that's fine if that's the
case please jaffy had said it best hire
committees who actually play in the
genres you don't because this is
embarrassing this is embarrassing for
some of these nominations that we're
seeing here that's what people this is
bigger than Fanboys being upset these
are media pundit these are developers
telling you yo what's going on the
developer joshu from pendit yo we made
the cut for pent what's the difference
what's the deal with the nomination
selection in in the cut off date we made
it we still wasn't categor and that game
got tens remember pent got tens a lot of
tens all over the place tens that's
right that's right Penman is was is
eligible this year yeah it it's look I I
I I want to be clear I'm happy that the
game awards exist we need our Oscars
right this is not saying death for the
show I'm not doing that but at the end
of the day if we going to do it let's do
it right let's stop playing I understand
you're here for the marketing but this
is embarrassing if you care about games
you have to change your explain us to
your PR how did you get to that
conclusion that Destiny should have been
a community and the sad part Co I don't
think there are any interest whatsoever
in having that conversation because they
don't know how to they don't how to
approach it and you could tell they
don't play Live service and they don't
play multiplayer games right because if
you do you would know Halo infinite has
improved you would know see thieves have
improved you would know that these games
are actually doing well no further than
the destiny Fiasco you literally Pro you
literally nominated Destiny for the best
community game when it literally just
laid off the entire Community I would
buy Destiny fan only it's only there
because Sony owns
them because any other time they be like
n let's go to something else look at the
end of the day it's just it's just
embarrassing that's all and you guys
could do better we we love that it's
there so again I'm standing on there is
genre attacks there is genre bias and we
need to improve it because as King was
King had a funny tweet we see
you we see you what what you doing so
it's like you got to correct it and that
that's pretty much where I'm at with it
but um we'll be at the New York game
shout out to the New York G shout out to
the real game
shout we'll be there we'll be there see
youman this yearman we'll be there with
Neil dman oh have I'm taking pictures
with your favorite dude Neil
dman be there hey Jeff see you at the
New York that that'll be January 23rd of
at the SGA SVA theater come pull up and
again what I love about you know and I
got to plug cuz what I love about they
do is they wait until the whole year is
over right
do it right to do it right yeah and that
that's another thing that like I
understand Jeff's like reasoning behind
it but I was in his spaces once when he
was uh like explaining the scenario he
didn't really have a good reason to
explain he's just like the Grammys don't
do it so we're not doing it marketing
it's marketing this is a marketing show
this is a marketing show and we get it
all we're saying is again we just want
these developers work so hard and I'm
always going to be Pro developer and
there's nothing painful at than to me
like we we're guys we're XCOM guys right
you know XCOM 3 could never win game you
know solve me and you Tekken Street
Fighter right Tekken can never win game
never they're basically telling me if
you're racing if you're any genre other
telling you only 25% of the games made
can be qualified for game because they
don't play the games it's so obvious
it's so obvious Street Fighter Street
Fighter six oh amazing I mean Street
Fighter fantastic absolutely
fantastic again again a remake look
again a remake instead of that game I
I'm just gonna I don't know yeah no no
you're right you might be a thing it
might be a genre
genre you know how I know that there's a
bias goe and I can tell you from my own
experience in the chat where y'all be
like all right so who wants to review
this game immediately we say okay so
what what platforms is available
and so when they say PC I be like right
when when they say PlayStation I my bro
I say I do it I'll do it I'll do I'll do
it hold on I gotta I got a shout out my
bro Kai Batu L KATU is in the chat I'm
gonna ride for him giz tactics deserved
it for years but not acknowledged at all
it's true they don't play those games so
again just hire people in those categor
stri
strategy I know I'm try to help cuz I
don't want to just be the guy that
complains that's not trying to offer
Solutions no when it when it's dead and
done when we kill them
all do n n n n No More Night Sky man yo
it's good y'all got this year have fun
with this
year we coming for you you can't say it
come it's over it's over it's
over the fact that what Alex said makes
a lot of sense it's like look even
though that that might may or may not
happen uh the fact that epic is a
partner they're publishing a game that's
been nominated for game of the year if
it does win how do we know there was
nothing behind the scenes ah they
tainted the
pool anyway I'm done I got a game to
give away yes please it's just like you
know when it comes down to real quick
when it comes down to the whole thing
where it's like you know the part that
just irritates me is like and we've
we've brought it up on this podcast
multiple times I don't like the fact
that it it doesn't seem like it's a
video game award it seems like the video
G War something they do on the side you
know they they they got they they focus
like 50% on the on the what's announced
there which you know we care about that
they they they focus no they focus 50%
on the ads which I get it and they focus
25% on the advertisements and they uh
not the advertisements the uh 25% on the
U you know the the trailers and then
they focus another 25% on the U the
awards itself it's like to me there's no
reason that
the the action adventure game of the
year is one of those things where they
just Jeff CH up there and who won this
and who won that they're just blowing
one after another to your point it's
very I agree it's very disrespectful
when developers get their award off
screen they just read the list that they
want it and they don't even get a chance
to and I get it may be a time issue you
can't read everybody but it just feels
time issue they need more time to do
it's ironic that a lot of the time the
strategy wases one of the ones that get
an off stream like that yeah anyway
that's good so adct I mean King you want
to get your um so our unknown benefactor
that's an industry plant that I can't
say the name of the individual has given
another game now I told y'all tweet at
me and and and show me who won now if
you ain't on Twitter put it in here that
you won let me know what's up all right
next game and I don't even know the
game all right so it's
mqf 4
C next is
96 K9 D next is F2 V
D4 next is
g69
RV and last is
qm3 YZ good luck let me know what the
game is and tweet at me no doubt and for
all those who stuck around we will do
Crown your la maybe next week where we
actually go through all the categories
and then we try to defeat sa with his
always good picking way anyway super
chats and then um actually before we do
super chats let me give a shout out to
Lord gainley rocked with us the entire
way mon in the building TKD in the
building that's crazy yeah 20 hours 20
hours you just w we getting ready to
leave no brother appreciate you man love
your story love that you reached out you
know where can a find people find you
tell us what you got going on
Sir uh well you could uh find me on
Instagram that's my biggest platform uh
so Anthony
550 um and I also got Twitter at gamley
TKD
uh all one word um and um I just want to
say uh there's people out there uh that
look like me but don't act like me so if
they look like me they have a disability
just uh show them kindness and and
support and uh you know not all of them
act like me is that a good thing or is a
bad thing like I'm trying you know what
leave that to your
imagination they definitely don't
deserve the same smoke I'll eat all this
smoke but show them show them some love
and uh you're the best community out
there and thank you for this no but
thank you so much for the kind words and
it really it really affect us when we we
realize you know when we talk and we
joke around every Sunday you know the
people who actually listen and it means
a lot to say hey you want to come on the
platform and talk and and really we
really appreciate you and the support
and obviously look I just I'm just
admirer of your perseverance and how
your attitude and your confidence and
you just who you are you know and that
how was he able to get on the show y
never said yes salute shout out to the
patreon shout out to all the realm of
the of the Lord's you know for the
support for so long and being part of
our patreon being part of our movement
being in the super chats being what T is
he a part of I don't remember the teer
specifically off top but he's one of our
tear he's one of our one of our top
supporters but I to me it's just about
how much you affect people and I think
it's really cool to see your story
learning about your story was really
cool and again salute brother always
always welcome and all love the
legendary TKD Lord gamesley Anthony
Capello in the reals salute you already
know exactly so we got um so we got
super chats you want me to do the poll
what you want me
do got a couple of super chats got
Apollo dingo $5 Super
Chat at no Xbox taxs just put out more
than two games and you might have a
chance to get nominated or
win he speak to Quality he say spoke to
quantity just put out more when when we
overwhelm you and there's nothing that
y'all could do I want to have I want to
see if you had that same
energy messy yeah we got Nintendo onaku
$5 Super Chat hustle Starfield is still
in the top 10 most played games after a
month and a half please come back next
month when Spider-Man 2 is not even in
the top 20 D goding
them I just want you stick around I want
to know why Spider-Man ran tell me tell
me why spider man Rand though
that's
that we got Necromancer Z member for 24
months Lord gold if Outlets like IGN uh
Kotaku and polygon want to have unequal
coverage they need to be given less
access while Outlets like ILP Lords of
gaming and ACG be given more access for
giving Fair
coverage I'm with you sir and iur and
and I'mma tell you right now I would
never give IGN to none of them dudes a
review code go buy your stuff y feel it
out want to hate hate by yourself not
with my
dollar we have Necromancer z uh shout
out to necan putting uh put this put the
crest in the chat for gifting 10 ILP
memberships yeah he hooked everybody
upate that I saw that um and then we uh
this is Alexis the $10 one my 104 High
prediction Allan way 2 will get game of
the year over uh bz3 epic is publishing
it and epic is also a partner of the
game awards also joural don't play don't
like playing games they'd rather watch
them you Ali W's a great game but I we
GNA see that'll be interesting yeah that
would be crazy I laugh so
hard then we got visual walk through
five pound Super Chat that's an
interesting name this is why I think
there should be 50 reviewers for Xbox
PlayStation Nintendo and PC games as
that would make it a lot better and look
like less
biased see
hopefully they figure something out yeah
they need to figure something out yeah
make sure everybody have the the systems
that they're talking about yeah jaffy
had a great let me just read this real I
forgot to read this is really he said
cuz he he had issues with with the
nominations and he said look there's
three things number one get all the
games to the nominating committees
digitally and set up a system adct GNA
love this where you can tell if a person
has played at least 50% of the game if
they have not they cannot vote in the
category they can be included two higher
more people five people specifically one
of a fan of a specific game type genre
Action Sports strategy whatever have
them play The Fringe stuff that people
miss and they can force to those Game
Force a game into the uh games the
nominations for the nomination
committees yeah then three make the
categories clear the fact that the Game
of Wars has direct has directing and
design as the same category is not only
nonsense but insulting the fact that art
Direction on the game awards uses this
to determine the nominees for standing
creative and Technical achievement in
artistic design and animation is insane
there are literally four different
criteria each unique from each other
lumped into a single category it also
reminds me of sports and racing or what
like it it's clear you know what I'm
saying that they're not playing anything
but anyway that that's pretty much what
he would say I just wanted to get his
boss out I wanted to mention
that and somebody proceeded to uh rip
into him for for for the Starfield stuff
but he was like why would I care if
Starfield got in or not yeah he was like
this has nothing to do with Starfield
this is bigger yeah it's bigger than
that then we have M Bell $5 Super Chat c
as Lord command of the midnight Suns
Army rally the troops it deserved to Nom
in the strategy category absolutely
especially over some City salines that
launch broken like what are we doing no
absolutely you know I go hard for Mid
night son shout out to Solomon the man
Jake Solomon you already know and we got
Spartan 66615 Super Chat Sony got the
golden joystick award for re4 and it's
not a first party game that was weird
what is everyone thinking the Xbox taxes
real Xbox is going to show you that's
right always payback it's h the north
then we got then we have plague injected
with the $10 Super Chat thank you don't
want none of
that Super Chat crazy to think that the
company that pays to keep games off of
Xbox off of Game Pass and to not use all
of the series X's power would paid to
influence Xbox media coverage I think
that's a that's a bridge too far but
okay I got
you um let me see Mike
Untitled Danny yeah Mike Untitled we
have Danny passion official and then
Mike Untitled um $5 Super Chat critics
should have some level of objectivity
when it comes to nominations instead
they pick and choose when they are
critics versus where when they're
console Warriors not even console
Warriors I would say I think it's the
politics more than anything else um
Reggie mobile 95 Super Chat shout out to
the Lords for six hours of discourse
bless y'all for
this hopefully hopefully couple a couple
of people shifts and you know keep it
happy there we have Spartan 6615 Super
Chat they announced the nominees before
the date was up for consideration they
snub any game they want if it is good or
not for a certain platform that's the
truth I mean I didn't say it that's what
uh Josh said he went in on
them then we got a sir duck member for
40 months Lord bronze great show fellas
y'all make my overnight shift there you
go today more tolerable save Kong
Godzilla needs his sparring partner
remember iron sharpens ey NOP NOP no we
got rhan we got we got gther we got
everybody else let Kong die Kong has
been bad for the industry we got to get
him a Pap we got other people we can
mess with that's Kong is bad for the
industry yeah Kong is bad he leave pool
droppings all over the
place out of here then we have SIMPLE
Jack $5 Super Chat new to the realm
simple ja new to the realm y'all be
killing me I agree on that the game
awards isn't isn't a perfect and many
genres should be in the running for TGA
also Kong is drowning Kong can't Kong
can't can't breathe under water that's
for sure cute
that's it we good yeah we caught up all
right no doubt let me get the P all
right oh with the recent announcement of
the Nomes at the game awards which do
you think would benefit the show the
most the choices are eight higher
committees who play specific titles in
genres so that they could have input on
the nominees B flesh out the category so
they are not all lumped together C let
devs accept Awards on screen D I don't
care I still got that
Xbox shout out to all those in the realm
as it goes up again salute my man
Anthony Capello Rocker with us the
entire joint go check him out up on
Twitter let us know when you get the
next when you you competing again you
doing some Taw you compete soon so we
anything we can promote for for next
year maybe not yet he's thinking about
it he's M he said he's muted he might be
muted he might be muted he figuring
something he going to let us know y'all
real let us know if he's in another
tournament or whatever we could I heard
I heard he supposed to be fighting over
ring shout out to gy versus the re lost
a lot of shout out to Al o sh Al o but
re lost a lot of
weight my God crackhead mode like it's
all no more no more horse
be word that was it right that was it he
look like he's smoking yeah yeah yeah it
look wild it look wild it look wild l
five people find you but you got to go
to
sir he's muted everybody
muted you can find me on Twitter Lord
addict I you know appreciate everyone
coming through we had a a pretty crazy
show
today you I blame
King blame you better blame hustle blame
I blame King you're the one that uh
engaged in it he he tossed out some Bait
A going to be you jump straight on that
that's right yo you going to get these
ones and twos you step up I got to
defend the crown he going to come over
here sideways you going to get I feel
you I feel you uh after the podcast I
will be sending you to my ranking every
XBox One exclusive game uh you can you
can talk smack in the comment section
it's fine uh but but but no I don't care
about how much snap you talking people
really came at me over Quantum break but
you we'll see we'll see we'll see we'll
see what you guys think but I'm kind of
curious I'm GNA send you guys over there
after the so once again I want to
appreciate every coming through it was
it was it was a pretty uh Big Show and I
want to thank Our Guest uh for taking
the the 5 hours and 49 minutes out of
his time to come in here and talk to
us EAS L and Sol W if find people find
you what you got going on Sir oh yeah
I'm about to get my ass beat when I get
off of here I I already
know I'm so late for so many days but
shout out shout out to Lord gamy I was
supposed to have so much done before
Grace got home and she's on her way home
now she's been gone all day dishes ain't
done nothing else done no I did those
thish is done so shout out to Lord
gamsey and we've been uh planning this
for quite some time right kind of
communicating the DMS and everything
glad it's able to happen glad your story
is out there for everybody to to hear it
uh it is amazing it's amazing what you
do keep it up brother um so glad to have
you in the realm finally and uh yeah we
will see let's see if I get some gaming
in we'll see it's Thanksgiving coming up
this week next so we'll see so Happy
Thanksgiving to everybody we'll talk to
you guys on Sunday we will be here on
Sunday absolutely you already know and
the king with the beef
offs multiple beef
offs first first I want to say um to my
my combat brother uh gamesley um thank
you for showing up uh thank you for
showing handic capable people across the
world that uh don't use uh your what you
have perceived deficiency is as any
excuse you know um your family didn't
treat you anything any way different I
love what he said that yeah yeah and um
they also encouraged everything that you
did you know when you said that you
wanted to take a break off from work to
do this to do that it supported you and
um and was well worth it you know
because what do you five time champion
at this time right now um totally dope a
lot totally dope totally dope and um I
truly respect that because what people
don't understand and this is for people
that have full functions over everything
going into a sport where you have to P
your self up against another individual
it's terrifying within itself but to go
in and you're handy capable that's a
whole different level of thought process
going in that's why I was asking your
thought process when you steep on the
mat and you know you're a true champion
and like I said you thought about every
scenario and how that you could take
this away and that away and you're
calculating up to the last millisecond
before they say go because you know
every second counts so I truly
appreciate you and everything that you
have done and and your family for being
super supportive fact for everybody
that's in the
round let that body in the bushes that
we we we we got today shout out to H
Mo man oh my shots on the way out let
that be a warning Jesus Undisputed for a
reason Xbox tax is real Xbox
Frontline videos every day uh shout out
to all the members the soldiers that
come through remember we have Rank and
file and You' be ranked anywhere from a
S to an X as a soier status I patreon
here allow uh games leag to come on I'm
going to be crafting a patreon coming up
so I want y'all when you get a chance to
check out our patreon if you like the
fact that games came on look and see
what tier that allows you to get in and
you too can be on ION Lord's podcast and
have the conversation with us and we can
go into your history and everything like
that Xbox Frontline news is doing that
you have uh the members we're going to
have patreon and uh our store for the
merch is going to be up soon I'm working
in the background to get your badges and
stuff like that live show calling y'all
did so much me and attic was so pumped
off of last week's show it was crazy and
also check out adct live show on
Saturday which I found super hilarious
going back to back with them shows your
man got a live show on Wednesday he got
a live show on Saturday he helps me on
my live show on Friday adct does a ton I
want a lot of you guys um you know to
check out his stuff and give him that
support you know keep on pushing our
numbers up as far as I'm almost at five
I believe attic is almost at 7 um let's
just keep on pushing and you know IR
Love's podcast is almost at 21 got a
statute to giveaway yeah um and we got a
console to give away so hopefully y'all
can get that console yes before the year
is
up you know um I'm going to keep on
fight and fight night Fridays is coming
it's coming it's coming it's coming
coming shout out to Rob y'all see yall
soon what oh no K KATU think it's all
sweet like somebody duck in the f n I'm
when I te hit the streets you can see me
put hands on you sir on look everybody
enjoy your suay that's all I got ad we
good bills paid everything good yeah
everything's good I'm send you guys over
there make sure make sure yeah Mak it
sure make sure good all right cool we
good yeah I'm sending yeah I'm sending
them over to uh to the video like I said
man be nice to me in that comments nah
nah stand on it you was talking strong
got stand on it
now we out peace
[Music]
PE
is